thank you
welcome back to the devops week by
simply learn so far we have mastered
devops testing the next crucial stage in
devops week is the integration of devops
with Cloud the benefits of using devops
with Cloud projects are also becoming
better defined they include application
development speed delivery to meet the
needs of the business units faster user
demands that quickly fall back into the
software and low cost for development
testing deployment and operations in
today's session we'll be learning
exactly how to integrate devops with
cloud and experience the real-time
working of devops with popular Cloud
platforms so without further Ado let's
get started so we will start by watching
a short animated video to understand the
basics of devops and then learn the life
cycle of devops followed by its
advantages
we will look at what cloud computing is
the benefits of cloud computing and the
different Cloud providers
moving ahead we will learn the important
devops tools and Frameworks such as git
Jenkins Maven selenium Docker and others
then we will focus on learning about the
different Cloud providers and explore
more about them so we will learn about
Amazon web services Microsoft Azure and
Google Cloud platform in detail with
Hands-On demonstrations
so let's get started
meet Tim Tim builds a robot in his lab
a climate-controlled and pollution-free
environment
once he's done he drops the robot off at
his project partner Mia's house Mia
takes it out to her backyard to ensure
that the robot meets the requirements
but here is where the problem arises the
change in the environment causes the
robot to malfunction Mia is now really
annoyed and she has a lot to correct and
it seems to her as though Tim didn't
really do much this wall between them
leaves a poor robot to bite the dust
well what if we broke this wall Tim and
Miana work together in a common space
Tim develops each block of functionality
of the robot which is then immediately
checked by Mia both are now working
simultaneously instead of waiting on the
other to finish their task as a man a
feature is ready for use they are put
together to build the final product they
develop a common mindset and share ideas
to further speed up the process they use
several tools which can automate every
stage this means that the robot is now
ready sooner with less iterations and
manual work from an organization
perspective Tim would be the developer
while Mia the operations their Union is
the core of the devops approach devops
has several stages and set of tools to
automate each of these stages let's have
a look at these Tim first puts down a
plan in terms of software this could
mean deciding on the module rules and
the algorithms to use once he has the
plan he now codes the plan with tools
such as git Tim has a repository for
storing all the codes and their
different versions this is call Version
Control next this code is fetched and
made executable this is the build stage
tools such as Gradle and Maven will sort
this out now before deployment the
product is tested to catch any bugs the
most popular tool automating testing is
selenium once the products are tested
Mia must deploy it the deployed product
is then continuously configured to the
desired State ansible puppet and Docker
are some of the most common tools used
that automate these stages
now every product is continuously
monitored in its working environment
nagios is one such tool that automates
this phase and the feedback is fed back
to the planning stage and finally we
have the core of the devops life cycle
the integration stage tools such as
Jenkins is responsible for sending the
code for build and test if the code
passes the tests it's further sent for
deployment this is called continuous
integration let's now have a look at an
organization that has adopted the devops
approach which of the below sequence of
steps would they follow to develop a
software Lydia answers in the comment
section keep an eye out for the right
answer on the comment section or our
YouTube Community
Giants such as Amazon Netflix Target
Etsy and Walmart have all adopted devops
and seen a considerable increase in
delivery and quality in 2014 an hour of
downtime for Netflix would cost two
hundred thousand dollars it became
absolutely crucial that Netflix prepared
themselves for any sort of failure and
so they took to the devops approach and
implemented it in the most unique way
they developed a tool called Simeon Army
this tool created failures and
automatically deployed them in an
environment that did not affect the
users the team would troubleshoot these
failures and this gave them enough
experience to deal with any degree of
collapse with everything being automated
and happening simultaneously
organizations can now deliver at a much
faster pace so considering the benefits
of devops and its Divergence from the
traditional methods would devops be the
future let us know what you think in the
comment section below hello this is
Matthew with simply learn and today
we're going to introduce you to devops
so let's go through waterfall so
waterfall is a traditional delivery
model that's been used for many decades
for delivering Solutions not just I.T
Solutions and digital Solutions but
either way before that it has its
history it goes back to World War II so
waterfall is a model that is used to
capture requirements and then Cascade
each key deliverable through a series of
different stage Gates that is used for
building out the solution so let's take
you through each of those stage Gates
the first that you may have done is
requirements analysis and this is where
you sit down with the actual client and
you understand specifically what they
actually do and what they're looking for
in the software that you're going to
build and then from that requirements
analysis you'll build out a project
planning so you have an understanding of
what the level of work is needed to be
able to be successful in delivering the
solution after that you've got your plan
then you start doing the development and
that means that the programmers start
coding out their solution they're build
out their applications to build out the
websites and this can take weeks or even
months to actually do all the work when
you've done your coding and development
then you send it to another group that
does testing and they'll do full
regression testing of your application
against the systems and databases that
integrate with your application you'll
test it against the actual code you'll
do manual testing you do UI testing and
then after you've delivered the solution
you go into maintenance mode which is
just kind of making sure that the
application keeps working there's any
security risks that you address those
security risks now the problem you have
though is that there are some challenges
however that you have with the waterfall
model the cascading deliveries and those
complete and separated stage Gates means
that it's very difficult for any new
requirements from the client to be
integrated into the project so if a
client comes back and it's the project
has been running for six months and
they've gone hey we need to change
something that means that we have to
almost restart the whole project it's
very expansive and it's very time
consuming also if you spend weeks and
months away from your clients and you
deliver a solution that they are only
just going to see after you spend a lot
of time working on it they could be
pointing out things that are in the
actual final application that they don't
want or are not implemented correctly or
lead to just general unhappiness the
challenge you then have is if you want
to add back in the client's feedback to
restart the whole waterfall cycle again
so the client will come back to you with
a list of changes and then you go back
and you have to start your programming
and you have to then start your testing
process again and just you're really
adding in lots of additional time into
the project so using waterfall model
companies have soon come to realize that
you know the clients just aren't able to
get their feedback in quickly
effectively it's very expensive to make
changes once the team have started
working and the requirement in today's
digital world is that Solutions simply
must be delivered faster and this has
led for a specific change in agile and
we start implementing the agile model so
the agile model allows programmers to
create prototypes and get those
prototypes to the client with the
requirements faster and the client is
able to then send their requirements
back to the programmer with feedback
this allows us to create what we call a
feedback loop we're able to get
information to the client and the client
can get back to the development team
much faster typically when we're
actually going through this process
we're looking at the engagement cycle
being about two weeks and so it's much
faster than the traditional waterfall
approach and so we can look at each
feedback loop as comprising of four key
elements we have the planning where we
actually sit down with the client and
understand what they're looking for we
then have coding and testing that is
building out the code and the solution
that is needed for the client and then
we review with the clients the changes
that have happened but we do all this in
a much tighter cycle that we call a
Sprint and that typically a Sprint will
last for about two weeks some companies
run sprints every week some run every
four weeks it's up to you as a team to
decide how long you want to actually run
a Sprint but typically it's two weeks
and so every two weeks the client is
able to provide feedback into that Loop
and so you were able to move quickly
through iterations and so if we get to
the end of Sprint 2 and the client says
hey you know what we need to make a
change you can make those changes
quickly and effectively for Sprint three
what we have here is a breakdown of the
ceremonies and the approach that you
bring to Agile so typically what will
happen is that a product leader will
build out a backlog of products and what
we call a product back clog and this
will be just a whole bunch of different
features and they may be small features
or bug fixes all the way up to large
features that may actually span over
multiple Sprints but when you go through
the Sprint planning you want to actually
break out the work that you're doing so
the team has a mixture of small medium
and large solutions that they can
actually Implement successfully into
their Sprint plan and then once you
actually start running your Sprint again
it's a two-week activity you meet every
single day the two with the actual
Sprint team to ensure that everybody is
staying on track and if there's any
blockers that those blockers are being
addressed effectively and immediately
the goal at the end of the two weeks is
to have a deliverable product that you
can put in front of the customer and the
customer can then do a review the key
advantages you have are running a Sprint
with agile is that the client
requirements are better understood
because the client is really integrated
into the scrum team they're there all
the time and the product is delivered
much faster than with a traditional
waterfall model you're delivering
features at the end of each Sprint
versus waiting weeks months or in some
cases years for a waterfall project to
be completed however there are also some
distinct disadvantages the product
itself really doesn't get tested in a
production environment it's only been
tested on the developer computers and
it's really hard when you're actually
running agile for the Sprint team to
actually build out a solution easily and
effectively on their computers to mimic
the production environment and the
developers and the operations team are
running in separate silos so you have
your development team running their
Sprints and actually working to build
out the features but then when they're
done at the end of their Sprint and they
want to do a release they kind of fling
it over the wall at the operations team
and then it's the operations team job to
actually install the software and make
sure that the environment is running in
a stable fashion that is really
difficult to do when you have the two
teams really not working together so
here we have is a breakdown of that
process where the developers submitting
their work to the operations team for
deployment and then the operations team
may submit their work to the production
servers but what if there is an error
what if there was a setup configuration
error with the developers test
environment that doesn't match the
production environment there may be a
dependency that isn't there there may be
a link to an API that doesn't exist in
production and so you have these charges
that the operations team are constantly
faced with and their challenge is that
they don't know how the code works so
this is where devops really comes in and
let's dig into how devops which is
developers and operators working
together is the key for successful
continuous delivery so devops is as an
evolution of the agile model the agile
model really is great for Gathering
requirements and for developing and
testing out your Solutions and what we
want to be able to do is kind of address
that challenge and that gap between the
Ops Team and the dev team and so with
devops what we're doing is bringing
together the operations team and the
development team into a single team and
they are able to then work more
seamlessly together because they are
integrated to be able to build out
solutions that are being tested in a
production-like environment so that when
we actually deploy we know that the code
itself will work the operations team is
then able to focus on what they're
really good at which is analyzing the
production environment and being able to
provide feedback to the developers on
what is being successful so we're able
to make adjustments in our code that is
based on data so let's step through the
different phases of a devops team so
typically you'll see that the devops
team will actually have eight phases now
this is somewhat similar to Agile and
what I'd like to point out at the time
is that again agile and devops are very
closely related that agile and devops
are closely related delivery models that
you can news with devops it's really
just extending that model with the key
phases that we have here so let's step
through each of these key phases so the
first phase is planning and this is
where we actually sit down with a
business team and we go through and
understand what their goals are the
second stage is as you can imagine and
this is where it's all very similar to
Agile is that the code is actually
started coding but they typically
they'll start using tools such as git
which is a distributed Version Control
software it makes it easier for
developers to all be working on the same
code base rather than bits of the code
that is rather than them working on bits
of the code that they are responsible
for so the goal with using tools such as
git is that each developer always has
the current and latest version of the
code you then use tools such as Maven
and Gradle as a way to consistently
build out your environment and then we
also use tools to actually automate our
testing now what's interesting is when
we use tools like selenium and junit is
that we're moving into a world where our
testing is scripted the same as our
build environment and the same as using
our get environment we can start
scripting out these environments and so
we actually have scripted production
environments that we're moving towards
Jenkins is the integration phase that we
use for our tools and another Point here
is that the tools that we're listing
here these are all open source tools
these are tools that any team can start
using we want to have tools that control
and manage the deployment of code into
the production environments and then
finally tools such as ansible and Chef
will actually operate and manage those
production environments so that when
code comes to them that that code is
compliant with the production
environment so that when the code is
then deployed to the many different
production servers that the expected
results of those servers which is you
want them to continue running is
received and then finally you monitor
the entire environment so you can
actually zero in on spikes and issues
that are relevant to either the code or
changing consumer habits on the site
imagine you're the owner of a small
software development firm and you want
to scale your business up however a
small team size the unpredictability of
demand and limited resources are
roadblocks for this expansion that's
when you hear about cloud computing but
before investing money into it you
decide to draw up the differences
between on-premise and cloud-based
Computing to make a better decision
when it comes to scalability you pay
more for an on-premise setup and get
lesser options too
once you've scaled up it is difficult to
scale down
and often leads to heavy losses in terms
of infrastructure and maintenance costs
cloud computing on the other hand allows
you to pay only for how much you use
with much easier and faster Provisions
for scaling up or down
next let's talk about server storage
on-premise systems need a lot of space
for their servers notwithstanding the
power and maintenance hassles that come
with them on the other hand cloud
computing Solutions are offered by cloud
service providers who manage and
maintain the servers saving you both
money and space then we have data
security on-premise systems offer less
data security thanks to a complicated
combination of physical and traditional
I.T security measures whereas cloud
computing systems offer much better
security and lets you avoid having to
constantly Monitor and manage security
protocols in the event that a data loss
does occur the chance for data recovery
with on-premise setups are very small in
contrast cloud computing systems have
robust disaster recovery measures in
place to ensure faster and easier data
recovery
finally we have maintenance on-premises
systems also require additional teams
for hardware and software maintenance
loading up the costs by a considerable
degree
cloud computing systems on the other
hand are maintained by the cloud service
providers reducing your costs and
resource allocation substantially so now
thinking that cloud computing is a
better option you decide to take a
closer look at what exactly cloud
computing is
cloud computing refers to the delivery
of on-demand Computing Services over the
internet on a pay-as-you-go basis in
simpler words rather than managing files
and services on a local storage device
you'll be doing the same over the
internet in a cost efficient manner
cloud computing has two types of models
deployment model and service model
there are three types of deployment
models public private and hybrid Cloud
imagine you're traveling to work you've
got three options to choose from one you
have buses which represent public clouds
in this case the cloud infrastructure is
available to the public over the
internet
these are owned by cloud service
providers two then you have the option
of using your own car this represents
the private cloud with the private Cloud
the cloud infrastructure is exclusively
operated by a single organization this
can be managed by the organization or a
third party and finally you have the
option to Hell a cab this represents the
hybrid cloud
a hybrid cloud is a combination of the
functionalities of both public and
private clouds
next let's have a look at the service
models there are three major service
models available es pass and SAS
compared to on-premise models where
you'll need to manage and maintain every
component including applications data
virtualization and middleware cloud
computing service models are hassle free
is refers to infrastructure as a service
it is a cloud service model where users
get access to basic Computing
infrastructure they are commonly used by
it administrators if your organization
requires resources like storage or
virtual machines is the model for you
you only have to manage the data runtime
middleware applications and the OS while
the rest is handled by the cloud
providers next we have pass
pass or platform as a service provides
Cloud platforms and runtime environments
for developing testing and managing
applications this service model enables
users to deploy applications without the
need to acquire manage and maintain the
related architecture
if your organization is in need of a
platform for creating software
applications pass is the model for you
pass only requires you to handle the
applications and the data the rest of
the components like runtime middleware
operating systems servers storage and
others are handled by the cloud service
providers and finally we have SAS SAS or
software as a service involves cloud
services for hosting and managing your
software applications
software and Hardware requirements are
satisfied by the vendors so you don't
have to manage any of those aspects of
the solution
if you'd rather not worry about the
hassles of owning any it equipment the
SAS model would be the one to go with
with SAS the cloud service provider
handles all components of the solution
required by the organization
time for a quiz now in which of the
following deployment models are you as
the business responsible for the
application data and operating system
one is two pass three SAS 4. I ask and
pass let us know your answer in the
comments section below coming back to
cloud computing some of the most popular
Cloud Computing Services in the market
are AWS or Amazon web services Microsoft
Azure and Google Cloud platform want to
learn more about them and how they
differ from each other click on the top
right corner for an analysis of how
these service platforms are different
from each other hi there I'm Sam from
Simply done and I work as a
multi-platform cloud architect and
trainer and let me welcome you to this
learning video called what is cloud
computing before cloud computing existed
if we need any it servers or application
let's say a basic web server it does not
come easy now here is an owner of a
business and I know you would have
guessed it already that he's running a
successful business by looking at the
hot and fresh brewed coffee in his desk
and lots and lots of paperwork to review
and approve now he had a smart not only
smart looking but a really smart worker
in his office called Mark and on one
fine day he called Mark and said that he
would like to do business online in
other words he would like to take his
business online and for that he needed
his own website as the first thing and
Mark puts all his knowledge together and
comes up with this requirement that his
boss would need lots of servers database
and softwares to get his business online
which means a lot of investment and Mark
also adds that his boss will need to
invest on acquiring technical expertise
to manage the hardware and software that
they will be purchasing and also to
monitor the infrastructure and after
hearing all this his boss was close to
dropping his plan to go online but
before he made a decision he chose to
check if there are any alternatives
where he don't have to spend a lot of
money and don't have to spend acquiring
technical expertise now that's when Mark
opened this discussion with his boss and
he explained his boss about cloud
computing and he explained his boss the
same thing that I'm going to explain to
you in some time now about what is cloud
computing what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the use of a network of
remote servers hosted on the internet to
store manage and process data rather
than having all that locally and using
local server for that cloud computing is
also storing our data in the internet
from anywhere and accessing our data
from anywhere throughout the internet
and the companies that offer those
services are called Cloud providers
cloud computing is also being able to
deploy and manage our applications
services and network throughout the
globe and manage them through the web
management or configuration portal in
other words cloud computing service
providers give us the ability to manage
our applications and services through a
Global Network or Internet example of
such providers are Amazon web servers
and Microsoft Azure now that we have
known what cloud computing is let's talk
about the benefits of cloud computing
now I need to tell you the cloud
benefits is what is driving Cloud
adoption like anything in the recent
days if you want an IT resource or a
service now with Cloud it's available
for me almost instantaneously and it's
ready for production almost the same
time now this reduces the go live date
and the product and the service hit the
market almost instantaneously compared
to the Legacy environment and because of
this the companies have started to
generate Revenue almost the next day if
not the same day planning and buying the
right size Hardware has always been a
challenge in Legacy environment and if
you're not careful when doing this we
might need to live with the hardware
that's undersized for the rest of our
lives with Cloud we do not buy any
hardware but we use the hardware and pay
for the time we use it if that Hardware
does not fit our required environment
release it and start using a better
configuration and pay only for the time
you use that new and better
configuration in Legacy environments
forecasting demand is an full-time job
but with Cloud you can let the
monitoring and automation tool to work
for you and to rapidly scale up and down
the resources based on the need of that
R not only that the resources Services
data can be accessed from anywhere as
long as we are connected to the internet
and even there are tools and techniques
now available which will let you to work
offline and will sync whenever the
internet is available making sure the
data is stored in durable storage and in
a secure fashion is the talk of the
business and Cloud answers that million
dollar question with Cloud the data can
be stored in a highly durable storage
and replicated to multiple regions if
you want and the data that we store is
encrypted and secured in a fashion
that's beyond what we can imagine in
local data centers now let's bleed into
the discussion about the types of cloud
computing very lately there are multiple
ways to categorize cloud computing
because it's ever growing now we have
more categories out of all these six
sort of stand out you know categorizing
cloud based on deployments and
categorizing cloud based on services and
again under deployments categorizing
them based on how they have been
implemented you know is it private is it
public or is it hybrid and again
categorizing them based on the servers
it provides is it infrastructure as a
service or is it platform as a service
or is it software as a service let's
look at them one by one let's talk about
the different types of cloud based on
the deployment models first in public
Cloud everything is stored and accessed
in and through the internet and any
internet users with proper permissions
can be given access to some of the
applications and resources and in public
Cloud we literally really own nothing
beat the hardware or software everything
is managed by the provider AWS Azure and
Google are some examples of public Cloud
private Cloud on the other hand with
private Cloud the infrastructure is
exclusively for an single organization
the organizations can choose to run
their own cloud locally or choose to
Outsource it to a public cloud provider
as managed services and when this is
done in this service the infrastructure
will be maintained on a private Network
some examples are VMware cloud and some
of the AWS products are very good
example for private Cloud hybrid cloud
has taken things to the whole new level
with hybrid Cloud we get the benefit of
both public and private Cloud
organizations will choose to keep some
of their applications locally and some
of the application will be present in
the cloud one good example is NASA it
uses hybrid Cloud it uses private Cloud
to store sensitive data and uses public
Cloud to store and share data which are
not sensitive or confidential let's now
discuss about cloud based on service
model
the first and the broader category is
infrastructure as a service here we
would rent the servers network storage
and we'll pay for them in an hourly
basis but we will have access to the
resources we provision and for some we
will have root level access as well ec2
in AWS is a very good example it's a VM
for which we have root level access to
the OS and admin access to the hardware
the next type of service model would be
platform as a service now in this model
the providers will give me a pre-built
platform where we can deploy our codes
and our applications and they will be up
and running we only need to manage the
codes and not the infrastructure here in
software as a service the cloud
providers sell the end product which is
a software or an application and we
directly buy the software on a
subscription basis it's not the infra or
the platform but the end product or the
software or a functioning application
and we pay for the hours we use the
software and in here the client
maintains full control of the software
and does not maintain any equipment
Amazon and Azure also sell products that
are software assets this chart sort of
explains the difference between the four
models starting from on-premises to
infrastructure as a service to platform
as a service to software as a service
this is self-explanatory that the
resource managed by us are huge in
on-premises that towards your left as
you watch and it's little less in
infrastructure as a service as we move
further towards the right and further
reduced in platform as a service and
there's really nothing to manage when it
comes to software as a service because
we buy this software not any
infrastructure component attached to it
there are lots of famous well-known
organizations around the world they have
moved or have migrated to the cloud
environment plentyrest is one company
which is one of the world's largest
visual book marketing tool with more
than 70 million monthly active users now
Pinterest was able to scale its business
because it was all built on Amazon web
services with a company with a less
number of employees Pinterest decided
that they do not want a dedicated staff
time to manage a data center instead
Pinterest uses AWS or they used AWS to
manage their high performance social
application and store more than 8
billion objects and 400 terabytes of
data in AWS Cloud using a service called
Amazon simple storage service or in
short Amazon S3 and not only that they
are running 2 lakh 25 000 instance hours
a month and they run that on Amazon
compute service called Amazon ec2 or
Amazon elastic compute Cloud Spotify is
an another company that got benefited
using AWS it's an online music service
offering and it offers instant access to
over 16 million licensed songs Spotify
needed a peculiar requirement it needed
a storage solution that could scale very
quickly without incurring long lead
times for upgrades long story short
Spotify used Amazon S3 which is Amazon
simple storage service and Amazon S3
gave them the confidence in their
ability and to expand their storage
quickly while also providing High data
durability the third biggest company I
want to mention is Netflix it's the
world's largest internet television
network with more than 100 million
members in more than 190 countries
Netflix uses Amazon web services for
nearly all its Computing and storage
needs now that includes database
analytic recommendation Engines video
transcoding and a lot more not only that
this company is planning to use AWS
Lambda to build an automated or an
rule-based self-managing infrastructure
and replace some of their inefficient
process to reduce the rate of errors and
replace inefficient processes to reduce
the rate of errors and save their
valuable time Expedia is another famous
company that got benefited by using
Cloud Expedia provides travel booking
service through its Flagship site called
expedia.com and not only that they also
run 200 plus travel booking sites around
the world Xperia is all on AWS and by
using AWS Xperia has become more
resilient with an high scalable
infrastructure and better cloud services
because it had offloaded the it
management to the cloud provider itself
in this case AWS and because of this
Xperia's developers have been able to
innovate faster while saving the company
millions and millions of dollars as next
thing let's talk about the different
Cloud providers Amazon web Services AWS
is a cloud computing service provided by
Amazon it provides a mix of
infrastructure as a service is platform
as a service pass and package software
as a service called SAS offerings
Microsoft Azure formerly known as
Windows Azure is a cloud computing
service by Microsoft and it sort of
specializes in using Cloud for building
testing deploying and managing the
applications through this service
throughout a Global Network that
Microsoft manages it also provides
software as a service platform as a
service infrastructure as a service and
it supports lots of different
programming languages and tools and
Frameworks including both Microsoft and
third-party software and systems IBM
cloud is a cloud computing service
offered by IBM IBM Cloud includes
infrastructure as a service software as
a service platform as a service now the
difference is here it offers through
public private and hybrid Cloud delivery
models VMware on the other hand is an
Dairy of Dell Technologies and provides
cloud computing and platform
virtualization software and services it
was the first commercially successful
company to virtualize the x86
architecture Google Cloud platform on
the other hand is offered by Google it's
a suit of Cloud Computing Services that
run on the same infrastructure that
Google uses internally for its end user
products such as the Google search and
the YouTube you're familiar with
alongside a set of managed tools it also
provides cloud services including
Computing Services data storage Services
data analytics and machine learning
services digitalocean on the other hand
is headquartered in New York City with
data centers worldwide digitalocean
provides developers cloud services that
help to deploy and scale applications
that run simultaneously on multiple
computers as of January 2018
digitalocean was the third largest
hosting company in the world in terms of
web facing computers let's let's talk
about cloud computing in AWS Amazon web
services AWS is a cloud computing
service provided by Amazon and these
services are accessible over the
internet and because AWS provides
infrastructure as a service it's a
flagship offering we can create and
deploy any type of application in the
cloud on top of the is that Amazon
provides and you know the best part here
is the subscriptions are pay as you go
type you use less and pay less and only
for what you have used you use more pay
more but still less per unit for the
service used attractive isn't it now
let's talk about the life cycle of the
cloud computing solution the very first
thing in the life cycle of a solution or
a Cloud solution is to get a proper
understanding of the requirement I
didn't say get the requirement but said
get a proper understanding of the
requirement it is very vital because
only then we will be able to properly
pick the right service offered by the
provider getting a sound understanding
the next thing would be to define the
hardware meaning choose the compute
servers that will provide the right
support where you can resize the compute
capacity in the cloud to run application
programs getting a sound understanding
of the requirement helps in picking the
right Hardware one size does not fit all
there are different services and
Hardwares for different needs you might
have like ec2 if you're looking for is
and Lambda if you're looking for
serverless computing and ECS that
provides container rest service so there
are a lot of Hardware is available pick
the right Hardware that suits your
requirements the third thing is to
define the storage choose the
appropriate storage service where you
can backup your data and a separate
storage service where you can archive
your data locally within the cloud or
from the internet and choose the
appropriate storage there is one
separately for backup called S3 and
there is one separately for archival
that's for glaciers so you know you
knowing the difference between them
really helps in picking the right
service for the right kind of need
Define the network Define the network
that securely delivers data video and
applications Define and identify the
Network Services properly for example
VPC for Network Route 53 for DNS and
direct connection for private P2P line
from your office to the AWS data center
set up the right Security Services IM
for authentication and authorization and
KMS for a data encryption at rest so
there are variety of security products
available we got to pick the right one
that suits our need and there are a
variety of deployment and Automation and
monitoring tools that you can pick from
for example Cloud watch is for
monitoring Auto scaling is for being
elastic and cloud formation is Define
the management process and tools you can
have complete control of your Cloud
environment if you define the management
tools which monitors your AWS resources
and all the custom applications running
on AWS platform there are variety of
deployment Automation and monitoring
tools you can pick from like cloudwatch
for monitoring Auto scaling for
Automation and cloud formation for a
deployment so knowing them will help you
in defining the life cycle of the cloud
computing solution properly and
similarly there are a lot of tools for
testing a process like code star and
code build and code pipeline these are
tools with which you can build a test
and deploy your code quickly and finally
once everything is set and done click
the analytics service for analyzing and
visualizing the data using the analytics
Services where we can start querying the
data instantly and get a result now if
you want to visually view the happenings
in your environment you can pick Athena
and other tools for analytics or EMR and
which is elastic mapreduce and Cloud
search all right enough of theory and
let's have a quick look at how two
services in AWS ec2 and S3 work together
and benefits us here are two ID
professionals talking to each other one
says I have an application which takes a
lot of storage and works only on Linux
system which I do not have at the moment
and the other one is a smart guy and he
immediately replies that he could use S3
to store data and retrieve data and use
ec2 for all its compute needs and then
the Curious conversation builds up and
the first person wants to know what is
easy to and S3 and the second guy starts
to explain that AWS ec2 is a web service
that provides a secure and resizable
compute capacity in their cloud and ec2
it can also be used to launch as many
virtual servers as we need and about S3
he explains AWS S3 is a simple storage
service provided by AWS and about S3 he
explains further saying that using
Amazon S3 we can store and retrieve any
amount of data at any time on the web
alright so the very first thing is to
have an AWS account so create an AWS
account and second thing is to create an
AWS S3 bucket and upload the files there
you know the files that ec2 server is
going to pull from will get stored in S3
as first thing all right so the first
thing is to create an S3 bucket so let's
create an S3 bucket and let's call it as
a website bucket and these names will
have to be unique so let's see if this
bucket name is available it says bucket
name already taken or already exist so
let me top it up with SL meaning simply
learn all right so we were able to
create a bucket and in that bucket let
me upload a Content that basically is
going to be my index file that's going
to go and sit in my web server so let me
also make it public and view it alright
so this is the content that I have
stored in my S3 and this is the content
I'm going to push to my ec2 server right
Second Step create an AWS S3 bucket and
upload files we're done with that third
is to create an ec2 instance that's in
other words create an virtual machine in
the cloud let's go and create it all
right the third thing is to create an
ec2 instance so let's create an ec2
instance it's plain and it's very simple
I'm going to keep everything as defaults
here all right so I've launched an ec2
instance as you see it's running I also
have an IP address public IP address
here with that I have logged into this
easy to instance and I'm in the folder
slash War slash www HTML and as you see
there is nothing in there at the moment
and This Server also has Apache
installed in it as you can see and now
I've browse to the IP address of the ec2
instance and it's showing a page which
is the default Apache page all right if
I had any files in this folder that
would get shown as the web page instead
of the default page our task is to save
files in S3 and move them to the ec2
instance so S3 is going to act as a
storage or a repository or a source code
control in this example all right so
let's do that all right the third step
is to create your ec2 instance and
that's what we have done and the ec2
instance has no files in it and the
fourth step is to synchronize the source
code bucket with the easy to instance
let's do that the actual command to do
that would be AWS S3 sync and then the
name of the bucket from which we're
going to pull the code and the folder in
which we're going to put the code or the
data all right so it has downloaded
something look at that and now if we go
back to the test page and do refresh
there you go it's showing the page that
it pulled from S3 so here I can use S3
as the source code control bucket and
any information that I put in there will
get reflected in ec2 instance once I do
a sync every day and that's how I use S3
as my storage for or ec2 all right
finally we were able to synchronize S3
bucket and the ec2 instance and we were
also able to view the results in the web
browser of the ec2 instance the data was
copied from S3 to the ec2 instance and
that we were able to view from the web
browser AWS as you are in gcp are three
of the world's largest cloud service
providers but how are they different
from each other let's find out hey guys
I'm Rahul and I'll be representing
Amazon web services I'm chinmayi and
I'll be representing Microsoft Azure and
I am Shruti and I'll be representing
Google Cloud platform so welcome to this
video on AWS versus Azure versus gcp
talking about market share Amazon web
services leads with around 32 percent of
the worldwide public cloud share Azure
owns up to 16 of the worldwide market
share and gcp owns around nine percent
of the world's market share let's talk
about each of these service providers in
detail AWS provides services that enable
users to create and deploy applications
over the cloud these services are
accessible via the Internet AWS being
the oldest of the lot was launched in
the year 2006. Azure launched in 2010 is
a Computing platform that offers a wide
range of services to build manage and
deploy applications on the network using
tools and Frameworks launched in the
year 2008 GC CPA offers application
development and integration services for
its end users in addition to Cloud
management it also offers services for
Big Data machine learning and iot now
let's talk about availability zones
these are isolated locations within data
center regions from which public cloud
services originate and operate talking
about AWS they have 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical regions
this includes regions in the United
States South America Europe and Asia
Pacific they are also predicted to have
12 more additions in the future Azure
available in 140 countries has over 54
regions worldwide grouped into six
geographies these geographical locations
have more than 100 data centers gcp is
available in 200 plus countries across
the world as of today gcp is present in
61 zones and 20 regions with Osaka and
Zurich being the newly added regions now
let's talk about pricing these Services
follow the pay as you go approach you
pay only For The Individual Services you
need for as long as you use them without
requiring long-term contracts or complex
licensing now on screen you can see the
pricing for each of these cloud service
providers with respect to various
instances like general purpose compute
optimized memory optimized and GPU now
let's talk about the compute services
offered first off we have virtual
servers for AWS we have ec2 it is a web
service which eliminates the need to
invest in Hardware so that you can
develop and deploy applications in a
faster manner it provides virtual
machines in which you can run your
applications azure's virtual machines is
one of the several types of computing
resources that Azure offers Azure gives
the user the flexibility to deploy and
manage a virtual environment inside a
virtual Network gcp's VM service enables
users to build deploy and manage virtual
machines to run workloads on the cloud
now let's talk about the pricing of each
of these Services AWS ec2 is free to try
it is packaged as part of aws's free
tier that lasts for 12 months and
provides 750 hours per month of both
Linux and Windows Virtual Machine genes
Azure virtual machine service is a part
of the free tier that offers this
service for about 750 hours per month
for a year the user gets access to
Windows and Linux virtual machines gcp's
VM service is a part of a free tier that
includes micro instance per month for up
to 12 months now let's talk about
platform as a service or past services
for AWS elastic Beanstalk is an easy to
use service for deploying and scaling
web applications and services developed
with java.net node.js python and much
more it is used for maintaining capacity
provisioning load balancing Auto scaling
and application Health monitoring the
past backbone utilizes virtualization
techniques with the virtual machine is
independent of the actual Hardware that
hosts it hence the user can write
application code without worrying about
the underlying Hardware Google app
engine is a cloud computing platform as
a service which is used by Developers
for hosting and building apps in Google
data centers the app engine requires the
apps to be written in Java or Python and
stored data in Google big table and use
the Google query language for this next
let's talk about virtual private server
Services AWS provides light sale it
provides everything you need to build an
application or website along with the
cost effective monthly plan and minimum
number of configurations in simple words
VM image is a more comprehensive image
for Microsoft Azure virtual machines it
helps the user create many identical
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
unfortunately gcp does not offer any
similar service next up we have
serverless Computing Services AWS has
Lambda it is a serverless compute
service that lets you run your code
without facilitating and managing
servers you only pay for the compute
time you use it is used to execute
backend code and scales automatically
when required Azure functions is a
serverless compute service that lets you
run even triggered code without having
to explicitly provision or manage
infrastructure this allows the users to
build applications using serverless
simple functions with the programming
language of their Choice gcp Cloud
functions make it easy for developers to
run and scale code in the cloud and
build image driven serverless
applications it is highly available and
fault tolerant now let's talk about
storage services offered by each of
these service providers First off we
have object storage AWS provides S3 it
is an object storage that provides
industry standard scalability data
availability and performance it is
extremely durable and can be used for
storing as well as recovering
information or data from anywhere over
the Internet blob storage is an Azure
feature that lets developers store
unstructured data in my Microsoft's
cloud platform along with storage it
also offers scalability it stores the
data in the form of tiers depending on
how often data is being accessed Google
Cloud Storage is an online storage web
service for storing and accessing data
on Google Cloud platform infrastructure
unlike the Google Drive Google Cloud
Storage is more suitable for Enterprises
it also stores objects that are
organized into buckets Amazon provides
EBS or elastic Block store it provides
high performance block storage and is
used along with ec2 instances for
workloads that are transaction or
throughput intensive Azure managed disk
is a virtual hard disk you can think of
it like a physical disk in an
on-premises server but virtualized these
managed disks allow the users to create
up to 10 000 VM disks in a single
subscription persistent storage is a
data storage device that retains data
after power to the devices shut off
Google persistent disk is durable and
high performance block storage for gcp
persistent disk provides storage which
can be attached to instances running in
either Google compute engine or
kubernetes engine next up we have
Disaster Recovery Services AWS provides
a cloud-based recovery service that
ensures that your it infrastructure and
data are recovered while minimizing the
amount of downtime that could be
experienced site recovery helps ensure
business continuity by keeping business
apps and workloads running during
outages it allows recovery by
orchestrating and automating the
replication process of azure virtual
machines between regions unfortunately
gcp has no disaster recovery service
next let's talk about database Services
first off for AWS we have RDS or
relational database service it is a web
service that's cost effective and
automates administration tasks basically
it simplifies the setup operation and
scaling of a relational database
Microsoft Azure SQL database is a
software as a service platform that
includes built-in intelligence that
learns app patterns and adapts to
maximize performance reliability and
data protection it also eases the
migration of SQL Server databases
without changing the user's applications
Cloud SQL is a fully managed database
service which is easy to set up maintain
and administer relational postgresql
MySQL and SQL Server databases in the
cloud hosted on gcp cloud SQL provides a
database infrastructure for applications
running anywhere next we have nosql
database Services AWS provides dynamodb
which is a managed durable database that
provides security backup and restore and
in-memory caching for applications it is
well known for its low latency and
scalable performance Azure Cosmos DB is
Microsoft's globally distributed
multi-model database service it natively
supports nosql it natively supports
nosql created for low latency and
scalable applications gcp cloud data
store is a nosql database service
offered by Google on the gcp it handles
replication and scales automatically to
your app applications load with cloud
data stores interface data can easily be
accessed by any deployment Target now
let's talk about the key Cloud tools for
each of these service providers for AWS
in networking and content delivery we
have AWS Route 53 and AWS cloudfront for
management we have AWS cloudwatch in AWS
cloud formation for development we have
AWS code stock and AWS code build for
security we have IAM and Key Management
Service for Microsoft Azure networking
and content delivery we have content
delivery Network and express route for
management tools we have Azure advisor
and network Watcher for development
tools for management we have Azure
advisor and network Watcher for
development we have Visual Studio IDE
and Azure blob studio for security we
have Azure security Center and Azure
active directory for gcp we have the
following tools for networking and
content delivery we have Cloud CDN and
Cloud DNS for management we have
stackdriver and gcp monitoring for
development we have Cloud build and
Cloud SDK and finally for security we
have Google Cloud IM and Google and
Cloud security scanner now let's talk
about the companies using these Cloud
providers for AWS we have Netflix
Unilever Kellogg's NASA Nokia and Adobe
Pixar Samsung eBay Fujitsu EMC and BMW
among others use Microsoft Azure so as
seen on your screens the companies that
use gcp are Spotify HSBC Snapchat
Twitter PayPal and 20th Century Fox
let's talk about the advantages of each
of these Services Amazon provides
Enterprise friendly Services you can
leverage Amazon's 15 years of experience
delivering large-scale Global
infrastructure and it still continues to
hone and innovate its infrastructure
management skills and capabilities
secondly it provides instant access to
resources AWS is designed to allow
application providers isvs and vendors
to quickly and securely host your
applications whether an existing
application or a new SAS based
application Speed and Agility AWS
provides you access to its services
within minutes all you need to select is
what your request wire and you can
proceed you can access each of these
applications anytime you need them and
finally it's secure and reliable Amazon
enables you to innovate and scale your
application in a secure environment it
secures and hardens your infrastructure
more importantly it provides security at
a cheaper cost than on-premise
environments now talking about some of
the advantages of azure Microsoft Azure
offers better development operations it
also provides strong security profile
Azure has a strong focus on security
following the Standard Security model of
detect assess diagnose stabilize and
close Azure also provides a
cost-effective solution the cloud
environment allows businesses to launch
both customer applications and internal
apps in the cloud which saves an ID
infrastructure costs hence it's Opex
friendly let's now look at the
advantages of gcp Google bills in minute
level increments so you only pay for the
compute time you use they also provide
discounted prices for long-running
workloads for example you use the VM for
a month and get a discount gcp also
provides live migration of virtual
machines live migration is the process
of moving a running VM from one physical
server to another without disrupting its
availability to the users this is a very
important differentiator for Google
Cloud compared to other Cloud providers
gcp provides automatic scalability this
allows a size container scale to as many
CPUs as needed Google Cloud Storage is
designed for 99.9 durability it creates
server backup and stores them in an user
configured location let's talk about the
disadvantages of each of these services
for AWS there's a limitation of the ec2
service AWS provides limitations on
resources that vary from region to
region there may be a limit to the
number of instances that can be created
however you can request for these limits
to be increased secondly they have a
technical support fee AWS charges you
for immediate support and you can opt
for any of these packages developer
which costs 29 per month business which
costs more than 100 an Enterprise that
costs more than fifteen thousand dollars
it has certain network connectivity
issues it all also has General issues
when you move to the cloud like downtime
limited control backup protection and so
on however most of these are temporary
issues and can be handled over time
talking about some of the disadvantages
of Microsoft Azure code base is
different when working offline and it
requires modification when working on
the cloud pass ecosystem is not as
efficient as iaas Azure Management
console is frustrating to work with it
is slow to respond and update and
requires far too many clicks to achieve
simple tasks Azure backup is intended
for backing up and restoring data
located on your on-premises servers to
the cloud that's a great feature but
it's not really useful for doing bare
metal restores of servers in a remote
data center let's now look into the
disadvantages of gcp so when it comes to
Cloud providers the support fee is very
minimal but in the case of gcp it is
quite costly it is around 150 dollars
per month for the most basic service
similar to AWS S3 gcp has a complex
pricing schema also it is not very
budget friendly when it comes to
downloading data from Google Cloud
Storage today we're going to delve into
git and what it actually is and how it
fits within your devops tag so a little
scenario before using geodes one of the
challenges that a lot of developers and
development teams would have had is
developers would be working on different
types of code whether it was database
code whether it was python or whether
it's Java or.net and they would have a
central server that they would be
pushing all of their source code in but
there was little or no communication
that was actually going on in between
all the developers you know the
challenge you had with that scenario is
that when people would be checking in
code you could be like you know there'll
be conflicts and you'd have to roll back
different code versions and and this is
really kind of the challenge that git
addresses git is a tool that allows all
of a developers no matter what stack
they're working in to have access to all
of the code and it makes it much more
effective at being able to have
development teams work on small medium
or even massive applications and some of
the big biggest applications out there
are managed through a git distributed
server environment so let's jump into
what we'll be covering so you have a
clear understanding of the value that
you're going to get out of watching this
presentation so we're going to go
through devops and the tools have
available for devops we'll talk about
what version control means within a
devops environment and cover the two
different types of Version Control
centralized and distributed and then
we're going to zero in on get which is a
really fantastic distributed Version
Control System I'm going to go through
and understand the features workflow
branches and commands in git we can give
you a demo and then summarize all the
activities at the end of the the
presentation so what is devops well this
is one of my favorite questions I love
the idea of what devops is so devops
really is a culture of being able to
deliver Solutions faster where your
development teams and your operation
teams work effectively together the idea
is to be able to continuously build out
Solutions and have testing codes that's
built into your Solutions so that no
matter where they are in the stage of
the integration and deployment life
cycle they're always being tested and
you can always have code being ready to
be released out the idea is that instead
of having big releases that you'd have
maybe once every two weeks or once a
month that you would actually have a
continuous stream of releases because
you always have code that is being
tested you have your network that's been
tested you have your environment being
tested and you'll be able to provide
feedback directly to the appropriate
person whether they're in depth or
whether they're in arts to be able to be
successful at being able to deliver
Solutions faster the bottom line your
Dev team things like operations and your
operations team begin to fill and think
like developers it's really a fantastic
way of being able to speed up delivery
and have your team just think and feel
and act in a different cultural
environment so let's have a look at some
of the tools that are available to you
in devops environments if we look at
devops it's really kind of split into
two areas the dev side you have building
code planning and testing and then on
your upside you have release deployment
operating and monitoring but the tools
really all interact with each other and
what's really great is that the tools
are either open source or very very low
in cost and in fact most of the tools
that you're seeing in front of you right
now are open source tools which means
there's no licensing to you and you can
actually effectively manage them and
Implement them within your team right
now so let's have a look at some of the
dev tools that you have for doing code
versioning and so some of the tools that
you may have used in the past include
subversion team Foundation service and
git these are all different types of
Version Control software that you have
out there one of the oldest ones is
subversion it's a centralized Version
Control System it's one of the tools I
used years ago it really is good at
doing what it's supposed to do which is
just a very simple version controlled
solution it's open source so it's free
there's no licensing there are
challenges with working with it because
it is a centralized tool rather than a
distributed tool we'll get into that in
a little bit but for a very basic
Version Control System you know it does
what you wanted to do team Foundation
Service Solutions something that many of
you in Microsoft world may have been
using for a long time and the thing
that's great about TFS is it's built
right into the Microsoft environment
it's the server side the services side
of building out your Solutions with
Microsoft just recently in the last
couple of weeks at the beginning of
September 2018. Microsoft actually just
rebranded TFS as Azure devops and so you
have Azure pipelines and there are five
now Azure tools that you replace TFS but
these are all tools that are very
similar in concept the old TFS tools are
very similar to the centralized SVN
tools whereas the new tools that are
part of azure are actually much more
aligned with get so what you're seeing
is Microsoft moving from the centralized
server to a distributed server with
their new Azure devops tools which is
fantastic news for every developer
listening to this and then we have get
and get is a distributed Version Control
System it is again open source which
means that you can start using it right
now without fear of having to have any
costs or any penalties and the thing
that's really good about it is that it's
really you can use it for almost any
kind of digital project and what it's
good at is being able to create that
historical record and versioning of your
source code whether you're doing a web
application a mobile application or
you're actually building a python script
for a machine learning solution so let's
dig into what version control systems
are and how they can be of value to you
so the role of a version control system
is to allow developers to be able to
check in their files into a repository
and here you can actually see how we can
check in three files into a repository
and that repository then becomes a
snapshot or a historical record of the
files that we're working on and you want
to be able to have it so that the
repository is flexible enough so that as
you want to be able to scale and add in
new files or new versions of a file that
you can actually do that easily within
your VCS environment and the goal is to
be able to constantly have each of these
versions available so that anybody wants
to be able to check out the file can
actually have the latest version of see
a history of how that file became what
it is today let's look at centralized
Version Control Systems and then we'll
compare it against distributed Version
Control Systems so a centralized version
control system has a central server
where all the files are stored and
everybody has to check in and check out
from that centralized server and all of
the versions are managed within that
server environment the problem is is
that it if that Central server crashes
which doesn't happen but very often but
it can happen you end up losing all of
your files and I was actually on a
project where that actually happened to
us and we lost six months of history of
how the application was created
fortunately for us we actually had a
backup but it didn't have all the
historical data so we were able to at
least continue working but we just lost
a lot of files and it took a while to
get back into place so let's now look at
and compare this to a distributed
version control system with a
distributed Version Control System you
still have a centralized server that
manages the files but the difference is
is that as a developer you check out all
of the files for a project so you can
actually manage the whole project
locally on your development machine and
make your changes and then you can just
check in and out the changes that you've
made to the centralized server the
opportunity you have here is that the
server itself if it goes down you're not
going to be in a a situation where you
lose all the history because everybody
that's working on the actual application
has all of the versions of the code
locally on their machine now one of the
more popular distributed Version Control
Systems that out there is git I mean it
really is probably the most popular by a
margin compared to a system out there so
you know let's dig into you know what
actually is get so git is a version
control system for managing files and as
a developer you have a git client on
your machine and you're able to make
changes and create local repositories of
a program on your computer and then you
can sync up with a remote service such
as GitHub or gitlab or the new Azure
Labs environment where you can actually
store files remotely and then allow
remote teams to have access to those
changes in the actual application you
may made so you can track your changes
easily you have it's the the tool is
inherently distributed so it makes it
very easy to manage the code for large
teams and you can bring people in very
quickly and you can have people come in
as Specialists and spin them up quickly
and have them work on a piece of the
code and then drop them out of the
project if you want to have a check on
how this works go and start contributing
to any of the the many thousands of Open
Source projects at GitHub where you can
go in with your get tools and just
contribute to those projects and then
finally one of the things that I really
like with Git is that it's not a linear
development approach it's not starting
from a and going into Z it's a
non-linear approach which allows you to
have branches that people are working on
in parallel to your master Branch where
people are actually doing the delivery
of the production code so let's step
through some of these features so get as
you can imagine the first thing it does
is track history that's probably the
most important part of having a Version
Control System it's a free open source
you can actually go and use it right now
there are no costs of actually using it
it is a non-lineared environment that
allows people to be able to build out
new features in parallel to the master
Branch so that you can be constantly
having the master code out there without
and adding in new features without
breaking the code and you can
automatically create backups by because
each developer has a version of the code
remotely it's incredibly scalable some
of the biggest projects out there now
are being managed through git and
because of this scale the collaboration
becomes a byproduct of teams working
together and branching just is so much
easier I would then get so as you can
see this whole thing leads to a very
effective distributed environment so
let's step through some of the the
workflow that we have available for git
so the way that git works is that you as
an operator as a developer you have have
the get client on your local development
machine whether it's a Linux machine a
Mac or a PC and you connect to a remote
server and you pull down the latest
working copy and then you're able to
make all of your changes uh locally and
you can modify the codes you can review
changes and you can commit those codes
to your git repository that you have
locally and then you can push those
changes back up to the remote server and
as soon as you push them into the remote
server those changes then become
available to everybody else working on
the project so they can be constantly
keeping everybody updated on all the
work that is happening so you know
typically the way that it would work is
you know you would start off with having
the working file the working directory
that you have locally then you would
stage those files into a staging area
and then you get those files ready to be
committed to your git repository and
these are all actions that you would do
locally and then connect to a remote
server and then later when you go back
into work and you your project the first
thing you should always do is check out
that code so you always have the latest
version of the code and everybody's kept
in sync so let's talk about branching
and get so the way that branches work is
that if you imagine you're working on a
project and projects always have a
tendency of getting bigger than you
imagine and what you want to be able to
do is keep that main product working and
keeping it working effectively but if
you want to be able to add a feature to
that product you may have two or three
different groups that are working on
multiple features
simultaneously and what you want to be
able to do is give them the freedom to
work on those individual features and
the way you do it in git is that you can
create branches off the master and while
you're um of the the main branch which
is called the master and so each person
could be working on their own separate
branch and then when they want to they
can then later merge those branches back
into the main master and all this time
the main Master still works and still
able to produce the right code for the
customer but at the same time it allows
the developers the freedom to be able to
write in their new features and so we
can look at this in a little bit more
visually with the master branch and we
can put in small features and large
features that we can then merge them
back as we need to so this kind of
covers some of the commands that we have
in git so the First Command you'd want
to use is called get init and that's
allow you to go into a folder on your
local PC and or your local Mac and
convert that file that folder into a
local git repository and that creates
that repository then you want to be able
to make changes to that repository and
you the commands you'd be using in this
instance would be and commit or status
and you want to be able to sync your
repositories through the remote server
so to be able to put the code that you
have on your computer on the remote
server you push you're going to get the
code from the remote server you'd use
pull and then add origin and then if you
want to do parallel development from the
master Branch the main branch you would
use Branch merge or rebase as ways to be
able to do parallel development and now
we're going to go through and do a demo
on git so we're going to do a demo on
get so you can feel comfortable running
the commands and the interface and
you're able to get get running correctly
in your environment so the first thing
we're going to do is we're going to set
up which version of git that you have
and then we're going to see if we can
establish some Global configurations
within your git environment and we're
going to do sandeep.dash as the name
email address is sandeep.simplylearn and
then we're going to do a list of the
different configuration settings we have
so to check the version of git that we
have we do git dash dash version in our
terminal or command line window you can
also use Powershell they'll actually get
you running in the same environment as
well all of these tools are going to be
command line tools and then the next
thing we're going to do is we're going
to assign some Global usernames and and
a global email address so that we can
actually access the git account itself
locally on the device and so we're going
to Dash and we're going to put in config
dash dash Global user.name Sandeep and
then a git
config.global user.email and
sandeep.d at simplylearn.net and now
we're going to check the list of
usernames and email IDs in our
configuration environment with Dash list
and you'll see that we have everything
in there correctly here is our username
right here and our name and our email ID
so if you need any help when you're
actually doing any of your work and get
all you have to do is to get help config
or git config dash dash help and this
will allow you to actually get access to
the help screens so let's just go and
type that in git help config return and
this takes us to the help page that's
running locally on your device and here
we have a breakdown of all the different
commands and what those come commands
actually do within a git configuration
and we can go ahead and we can do git
config dash dash help and that will
actually take us to the same page so two
ways of doing the same thing so we're
going to go ahead and we're going to
create a test repository on our local
system and we're going to do that with
make directory called test and then
we're going to move our cursor within
command window terminal window to the
test folder and then we're going to
initialize that folder to become a git
repository so let's go ahead and do that
so we're going to make a new directory
and we're going to call it test and
we're going to move the cursor so it's
actually in the test folder we do CD
change directory to test and you can see
now we're actually in the test folder
and now what you have to do is
initialize this folder as a git
repository and so we're going to do this
as git init and it's now a new get
instance that we can actually now use
for managing our git environment so
we're going to create a new file and
we're going to call it info.txt and
we're going to put some content in it
and we're actually going to put it in
the folder that we've just created so
you can actually see what it's like to
test out the get environment with a file
that hasn't been checked into it yet so
let's go ahead and do that so we open up
our photo directory and here you can see
we have the test folder and we're just
going to go ahead and create a default
test file so right click Text new
document info.txt open that and we'll
just you can put really whatever you
want in here we're just going to put in
this information right now name equals
Sam registration number one two
479 and save that file close it out now
if we actually go ahead and run a get
status command you'll see that the
info.txt file is in red that's because
that file has not actually been checked
into the project it's a new file that
we've added but it hasn't been committed
yet into the git repository so let's go
ahead and see what it takes to actually
add the file to the git repository that
we just created so we're going to do
that by doing get add info.txt and then
we can commit that into the history of
that git repository so we can do so it
now has Version Control and we can start
doing uh forking and other kind of sim
activities when we connect later to our
GitHub git environment so we do get add
info Dot txt and remember we're actually
still in the test folder so it's going
to look for that file in that folder and
just add it in and now if we go ahead
and do get status we'll actually be able
to see that the info.txt file is in an
act active color first of all we have to
commit it so we go get commit Dash M and
then we're going to commit and we add in
some quick text you can write whatever
you want committing the text file it's
now actually committed into the get
repository and it's all running locally
on your PC so we're going to go make
some changes to the file and we're going
to save it and we want to be able to see
how we can use git to compare the
differences between the two files so
let's go over and we're going to make
some changes to the info.txt file here
we are here's info.txt which is going to
add in a new line we're going to add in
the line address and we'll save that
file and now when we go over to get
we're going to be able to review the
difference so we're going to do git div
and here you'll actually see that we've
added in a new address file so now you
can actually see this is the difference
and the difference between the two
documents now as you can imagine when
you have code this would become more
elaborate where actually Google should
show you code that's been pulled out if
you've reduced any of eliminate engine
code or if you added in new code really
useful so we're going to go ahead and
add our get username to a remote
location so we can actually start
testing out the file that we've created
into a remote repository in this case
we're going to use GitHub and you'll be
able to see how we can actually then
save that file into a git repository
that somebody else could then access and
be able to make edits too so let's just
go ahead and make those changes so git
config Dash Global user dot username and
we'll do simply learn and that will
associate it with this git repository
that we've just created locally so
simply on dash GitHub so simply learn
GitHub is the username that we use on
GitHub so we're going to go over to
GitHub here we are in GitHub and then
correct new Repository
and then as you can see with Sim so
we're in simply learn Dash GitHub and
we're going to call the new repository
test we're going to make it public so
anybody can access it and you'll see
that it automatically adds a readme file
and we have our test environment set up
correctly so we'll go ahead and copy the
URL link which is github.com simply
learn GitHub forward slash test.get copy
that and we'll go back over to our
command line window and so now we're
going to add the username to the GitHub
configuration so what we're doing is
we're connecting the local repository to
the remote repository so we type get
remote add origin and then we'll paste
in the address and this then allows us
to connect the local repository that we
created in the test folder with the
remote repository and now we're
connected so now that we've connected we
can actually push the file that we have
in the local repository on your PC or
Mac to the remote repository in the
GitHub server environment so let's go
ahead and do that so we're going to do
get push and push pushes the command to
push the documents from the origin which
is the local file to master and must as
a remote file hey and there we are
success so what we have now is the file
that we just created in our local get
repository is actually now in the remote
repository as well so anybody can access
it so let's go have a look at that so
we're going to refresh the GitHub page
and hey there we are there's info.txt
has been uploaded and we're ready to go
that's great that's uh that's what you
should be seeing so refreshing your web
page on the remote GitHub folder and it
could be any get service we're just
having to be using GitHub because it's
free to use you'll be able to see that
the local file has been installed and is
now part of the git repository in the
remote server so what we can do now is
we're going to create three more files
and we're just going to call them
info.txt info 2 and info three and then
we're going to push them out to the
remote server and we're going to merge
everything together into a single
environment so let's go ahead and create
create those three files and we're just
going to add those into the folder so
let's go ahead create new text document
info one and then we're going to create
info 2 and then info three get my typing
right here okay here we go there we are
okay I'm opening info three and I'm just
gonna enter some text in here and what
we're going to do is illustrate how we
can do branching and each of these files
I'm going to save and then close out and
now I can go over and so let's create a
new branch and we're going to call this
one first underscore branch and we go
get Branch first underscore branch and
this will be a new branch of the code
environment that we're creating and so
hit return and that allows us to create
a new branch and so what we do is we're
going to move to the new Branch so we're
going to do get check out first
underscore branch and that allows us to
move into that branch and you'll see
that info.txt is already there which is
good that's what we want to see now what
we need to do is add in the new
documents so here we have the different
steps we've taken we created a branch we
moved to the new branch and now we're
going to go ahead and add the info 3 txt
to that Branch so you can actually see
everything coming together and we're
going to go ahead get add info 3.txt so
we're just adding a file like we were
previous see with our initiation our
first initial git folder and that file
has now been added to the first Branch
so we're going to go ahead and commit
the file to the first branch and then
we're going to merge the documents into
the master Branch so we have everything
together so let's go ahead and do those
steps we're going to do the commit first
and then we're going to merge everything
together right so we do git commit Dash
M and we'll just put in we're just going
to say uh made changes to First branch
and that's just a documentation so that
we know what we've done and there we are
we've committed the file so we had that
file info 3 txt committed and now we're
going to go ahead and merge the files
into the main master and so we can
actually have everything together as one
consistent environment and we do that by
typing in so this list out what we have
in our Master file so we just do LS and
that will show everything in the folder
and we have info.txt info 1 txt info 2
txt and info 3txt are now all in the
first Branch so let's go ahead and we're
going to merge okay so actually before
we merge we have to check out the master
Branch so we do get checkout master so
it gets us into the master branch and
you'll see that we have just one file
there info.txt so we're going to list
out the files in the master branch and
so so what you'll see is info dot text
info one text and info two texts are
there but info dot info three text isn't
there because that was created in a
separate Bunch so let's go ahead and
merge the first Branch into the master
Branch so we do git merge and we do
first underscore branch and there we are
we've merged it in and excellent that
looks good so let's go ahead and list
out the files that we have in the master
branch and we do LS and then you'll see
that we have four files including the
info three dot text that we had in a
separate Branch now all in the master
Branch welcome to git commands git is
one of the most popular distributed
Version Control tools of recent times
and like any other distributed Version
Control tool it allows us to perform
various Version Control tasks without
really needing a network connection
before I jump into my demonstration let
me spend some time explaining to you the
git client server working model what
does it take for a couple of users to
collaborate and start working with Git
the bare minimal thing that any user
would need in order to start working
with Git is something called as git bash
or the git client this comes as an
installer for all popular operating
systems like Windows all flavors of
Windows Linux Mac OS and other operating
systems so once you install git bash you
get a command line utility using which
you can fire up your git commands and
ensure that you can can bring up
repositories you can work with these
repositories by adding files to it
committing changes to it and all those
git commands would work perfectly well
so you can bring up a small repository
and you can work with your repository
using this git bash but what does it
take for you to share this repository
with another user who has also got git
bash installed on his system this is
where you would need something called as
a git server so for user1 or one user to
share his repository with another user
he would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present Market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with a cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that I
can think of are GitHub which is one of
the most popular git servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the github.com
and then the other one is is an
Enterprise server which comes as a black
box that can be installed into your data
centers so typically organizations who
don't want their source code to be put
up on the cloud but go for this GitHub
Enterprise servers wherein they buy this
servers and these servers are hosted on
their data centers other popular variant
of the git server is bitbucket this is
from the famous atlassian products and
it integrates very well with all other
atlasian products like jira in recent
times there's one other variant of the
git server called gitlab which is
getting very very popular these days
because gitlab not just provides a git
server it also provides something called
as a runner this is a part of the
continuous integration strategy where as
soon as you have a source code check-in
that is going in you have this Runner
that kicks up and builds your particular
project so all these are bundled
together in a git lab and gitlab also
provides you with a Community Edition
which is almost free of cost having said
that there are a bunch of these tools
available people for my demonstration
what I'm going to do is I've already
registered myself on the github.com by
providing my username and my password
and I'm going to use a free account so
whatever reposit is that I'm gonna put
up on this server is all public by
default so I will register Myself by
using my username or my email ID and my
password so this set of authentication
is also referred to as https
authentication so in order for me to
share my repository with say user 2. the
first thing that I got to do is have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once I have
that I can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
whoever wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as is registered properly on the
git server he can use his credentials
and pull down this repository and work
with this repository so this is the
https way of authenticating and sharing
repositories another popular way of
sharing repositories or working with
each other is called as SSH
authentication as many of you would know
SSH means nothing but creation of a
private and a public key a bunch of keys
public and private are created on the
client machine while I create a keys I
will be asked for a passphrase I need to
type in a passphrase and remember my
passphrase and then I take this public
key and kind of post it on to my account
within my git server so that whenever
I'm going to connect next time using my
command prompt or any of the tools it's
going to challenge me for my passphrase
as long as I remember my passphrase
correctly I can authenticate myself and
get into the server so both https and
SSH are popular ways of communicating
with the git server having said this let
me just get started by installing the
git bash on my local system and then
fire up some of these git commands and
build up some repositories make some
changes in my repository commit these
changes and later use my GitHub
credential to connect to my GitHub
server and push my repositories out
there
let me now go ahead and find my git bash
for my windows so that I can go ahead
and install it so I just type in git
client for windows open up a browser and
type in for this the first one that I
find is a GUI tool I don't need this GUI
client I need this one so this is a git
client or the git bash that I was
referring to it's about 40 Megs and let
me just download this pause this video
for some time so that the download
happens and come back to you once I have
the download the download seems to be
complete when I'm recording this video
the version that I have the latest
version that is there is 2.19.0 and this
is a 64-bit version for Windows so I've
got that downloaded let me go ahead and
find it and install this EXE
all right I go ahead choosing all the
default options I want it to be
installed in SQL and program files under
the git folder everything looks good for
me I'm not going to make any changes
here
get Bash from Windows yes I may want to
use git from Windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open SSH that's fine
next card next card no I don't want any
of these new features
so what I'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that I can
start using my git commands
and the version that I'm using is
2.19.0 which as I record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good I don't want to
see the release notes I'll say again
launch git Bash
so what I get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good it's a Git
Version it sounds good say git help all
right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so I ended up
installing the git bash I can go ahead
with all other commands
now that I have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before I do
anything I just need to configure It For
the First Time stating what would be the
username and the email ID with which I
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iPhone Global which means that
this setting that I'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double code in my
case I am using a simply learn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen iPhone Global this is
also a global setting
and this would be the email ID
the email ID need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email ID that
I would be setting up it to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email ID has been picked up the
way I wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you're placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where I'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so I will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
This Is My Demo so this would be a
folder so I would use this folder as a
base folder for creating all other
repositories as a part of this demo so
let me create my first repository a
repository is nothing but a folder so
let me create my first folder called
first repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all I navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment okay so let me create a
repository out of this how do I create a
repository of this is pretty simple I
just run a git init command
when I say kit in it it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing in it was
an empty repository so it initially is
an empty repository in this particular
folder for all I look at my content you
would see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since I've
configured my Explorer to view all
hidden folders I see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command kit init
if I get into this folder I see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info this
objects
this references a bunch of stuff that is
there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing now if
you notice here when I was in the folder
the repository did not have anything
after this now when I say git in it
there is something called as a master
that shows up so typically what happens
is whenever a git repository is created
for the first time it creates a default
Branch the name of the branch is called
master and that is why you would see
Master within braces this doesn't mean
anything else other than we have a
repository out in this particular folder
and by default there is a branch called
master and we are currently on that
Branch if at all I create multiple
branches in this folder whenever I
navigate to different branches the
branch name within this brackets would
change all right so far so good so we
created a folder we made it a git
repository by initializing that with the
git in it and then I have not put
anything yet in the repository so let me
try to do that let me create a few files
within this particular repository so I
use a touch command touch is a Linux
command it kind of creates this
particular folder if all you're not
comfortable with the file creation by
this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so I create a file called touch
master.txt and open up in the notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what I'm going to write inside this
I save this and I come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this tell you there's no
commit set you're in the master Branch
there is an untracked file and this
shows up in thread it also gives you all
the command that is supposed to be run
so if at all you want to add this file
you would say git add and the name of
the file and then you're going to commit
it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository now that a git notices
that there is a new file in this
repository called master.txt if at all
you want you want us to let git know
that you want to track this file we need
to add this to the repository so the
command to add that is called git and I
can specify either the name of the file
or I can give a wild character saying
git add dot now if I run the git status
command again
it says there's no commits yet added a
file and the file which was earlier in
red now shows up in cream and it says
it's a new file master.txt all right it
also gives you something called git
remove command if at all you want to
unstage or undo your changes so what has
happened is the file which was earlier
untracked has been added into the git
index or it is ready for staging or it's
in a staged State now I can go ahead and
commit this file if at all that's what I
want to do so let me do that
I'll do a git commit minus M and I give
a message that I want I would say this
is my first get commit
all right I run the git status command
again and see it says on the branch
Master nothing to commit it's all nice
and clean so typically what happened was
I created a empty directory made it into
a git folder by doing a git in it I put
a file into it I made some changes to
the file I added that file into the
repository and I committed to the
repository if I to error I run the git
log command
it says this was the commit ID or the
commit number or the commit hashtag and
this is the author if you notice this is
the email ID and the username that we
set earlier and this was done on this
date and this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so I will touch
Master One Dot text I'll put in another
file
I'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right I save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
foreign
so what I did I modified the older file
that existed I also added a new file to
my repository now if I run the get
status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
I want to
incorporate I would say git add dot I
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and Commit This so git
commit with a message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if I do git log now it shows both the
commits the first comment is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest comment that
is there so far so good if at all you
notice I'm doing all these git commands
without really connecting it to any git
server I don't need any network
connection for doing any of these things
I can keep on doing more and more git
commands and run git commands the way I
want to
without really having any connections to
the kit server now that I have my
changes the way I wanted and I've
checked in all the code changes into my
local repository I may want to share my
repository with somebody else and work
in a collaborative way so the way to do
that is as I mentioned earlier to host
this repository or to push this
repository onto a git server I already
have a GitHub account wherein I've
registered myself using my username and
password so I log into my GitHub account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
Repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what I essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that I can link them together and
push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is his first repo
so let me copy this I would create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name so that when I pushed my repository
from my local box it will go ahead and
get created in the server so the
repository name should be the same as
what I created on my local box
description I would say this is my first
get Hub Repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up and if you notice
I can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that I'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so I choose public and I don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because I already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that I need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server so with this option with just a
name and with an optional description
and the repository being public I go
ahead and click on the create repository
button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that I would need to run in
order to create a repository and push it
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two URLs one is the HTTP s
URL and the other one is the SSH URL as
of now we do not have any SSH keys that
is set up so let me use this https URL
to connect my local repository with the
repository on this server
so I've done all these things I already
have the repositories set up all that I
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server URL
so this would be the command that I need
to copy
with essentially links or ads and origin
with the URL of the git server I just
copy this command
and run it here
get remote ad the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
URL which is nothing but the placeholder
that I've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the URL looks good I'm all set I've
got two comments in my repository I'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen U this is for
linking the Upstream
origin
master
so git push hyphen U Upstream linking
origin master link the master
a branch of my local repository with the
master branch on the server repository
and where is it going to push it is
going to push by default to An Origin
and the origin points to this URL all
right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an URL asking
me the credentials with which I need to
log into my GitHub server so let me just
copy and paste
the username and the password with which
I have registered
I would say login
okay success so I am able to create a
repository on the server and the content
seems to be pushed and it created a new
branch called Master it is linked the
master Branch from the local repository
with the master branch on the server so
let me go back to my server and refresh
this page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text fit all I see
the commits they seem to be two commits
this is my first comment this is my
second comment and if at all you notice
each of this commit comes with a hash
key or a hash ID which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was the line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
I added these lines
I made this you know one line chain that
was there I also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see
the timestamp of the Commit This is the
commit which was committed for 15
minutes ago so what does this mean is
that the commit is the timestamp when we
actually commented the code in the
client the pushing is just after we've
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happened
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein I create a repository
on the client and then I pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
Skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the SSH
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of SSH keys and ensuring
that I connect to the GitHub server
using the SSH mechanism so for doing
that I need to First create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is SSH Keygen
hyphen T I will use the RSA mechanism
for creating my keys Capital C and I
need to specify the email ID using which
I'm going to connect to all right I need
to create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should I create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a DOT SSH folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase so let me enter some
passphrase
keep in mind that I would need to
remember my passphrase because when I'm
going to authenticate myself using SSH
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase I need to enter
the right passphrase so that I get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now I would need to stick it in
on the server so that I can get myself
authenticated using SSH keys so I have
logged in to GitHub using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you would see an SSH and gpg keys
let me click on that as of now there are
no SSH key or gpg keys so I will click
on new SSH key and let me paste my
public key that I've copied and I would
say add SSH key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
I've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my SSH keys are working well
so I do SSH hyphen capital T I would say
get
at github.com
this is just to double check if my SSH
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now a check for my passphrase
let me enter my passphrase I hope I
remember it correctly
all right
triggered I have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my SSH
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase I can connect to my GitHub
server using SSH all right so for the
Second Use case what I would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that I create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server I will
create a new Repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file I would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created straight
on the git server on the GitHub server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time I am
going to choose this option the reason
being that I don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now I want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then I want a repository to be
created on the server all right I say
create a repository
So Random readme file with some content
in it gets created and I can see there
are two URLs to this repository https
and SSH so this time let me copy the SSH
URL so that I will use this URL to clone
this repository on the server
from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that I created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository the second repo that I
created on the server the command to do
that is git clone the URL of the
repository that I want to clone
oops looks like I didn't copy the URL
correctly let me copy that again
copy this URL
all right so if you notice there is no
https to it I'm just cloning the URL
that is SSH URL of the Repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so I just had first repository earlier
now I have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if I get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here I would say
Notepad
second dot text some text file I'm going
to put in here yes definitely you will
not find that file there
this is my second
file that
I will push onto the server
I'm going to put in some content out
there
and save this
and if I do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes I definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
comment for the second repo
I'm giving some particular message
and this time around since I clone my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me I don't really need
to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that I was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why I had to set
up the Upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case I have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when I clone I get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
I don't need to do anything more I'll
then push the content I'll just say get
push to be in the safer side I would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it pushed the content onto the
server let me see if the contents have
come in here okay wonderful I had only
one commit now I see my second comment
so what was added as a part of the
second comment it says a new file was
added all this line that never existed
got added this is the second file the
content exactly what I pushed onto the
server
now this completes the tutorial when I
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using SSH
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now get init is used to
initialize the repository so if at all
you are creating a local repository you
can get into any of the folder which is
not a git repository and run this
command whenever you run this command a
magical folder by name dot kits gets
created in the folder and from that time
onwards git will start tracking any
changes that happen to that particular
folder it also creates a new repository
and a branch by default the branch that
is created is called the master Branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file 10 files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen M with a
meaningful message this will commit all
the work items that you have done in
terms of the files that got changed the
more files that got added all this with
one particular message get status will
give you the status of all the files and
folders any file that got added any file
that got created any file that was
deleted all the status of the files will
be obtained using the git status command
git log will show you all the comment
history with the latest history or the
latest commit showing up on top git add
remote origin this command is used
whenever you want to link any local
repository to a server and this is when
you want to really push a repository
from the local to the server for the
first time git push hyphen U origin and
master this is the command that you
would use whenever you want to push
contents from the local repository to
the server server git clone and the URL
of the server this is the command that
you would run whenever you have an
existing repository on the server and
you want to make a fresh clone or a
fresh copy of that particular repository
onto your local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify or change some of the
files that they recently committed or
checked into the repository now from a
perspective of get this is a very very
simple activity however my perspective
of Version Control tool you will have to
be really cautious about the chain that
you're gonna do in case the changes are
pretty local none of the developers or
none of the other users who are
collaborating with you would be affected
by this change you are good to go ahead
and make this change however if your
repository has been pushed to the server
and you're trying to modify something
from history this would have a very bad
or adverse effect on all the other users
who will be using it you need to be
really cautious while running these
commands in case your repository
contents are local if you've not pushed
your changes to your repository and if
at all you made some changes to the
repository maybe to fix a defect or to
include a new feature and you missed few
things you can go ahead and modify this
with some of these commands let's say I
have this simple repository called undo
undo repo and if at all I look at the
logs of these I have the commit
histories which are like this
I have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in C1 I've added a
file in C2 I added the file in C3 I've
also added some file in C4 I made some
changes to M1 and M3 and in C5 I have
added another file called M4 now this is
my commit history now let's say I made
these two commits but possibly I want to
Club them together along with some other
changes because whatever changes I did
did not really fix things the way I
expected you to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the commit
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all I need to go back in history
and go back to this particular comment
and however I just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but I want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist I would do
command called get reset hyphen iPhone
soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two comments would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen iPhone soft
which is the snapshot that I want to get
back to if this is the commit that I
want to get back to I just copy this
and paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all I do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is 7 C2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to C5 it's gone back
to C3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of C4 and C5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of C4 was
some changes to M1 and M2 and C5 a new
file got M4 got added the photo I do a
git status
you'll see those changes still exist
however from the git history or the git
commit history C3 is the topmost comment
that exists as of now c4 and C5 have
been currently read off but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now I can make some more
changes that I want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new comment
altogether maybe I'll open up a notepad
and possibly create a new file called
m6.text
and say one new file that was missed out
I make this change I go to a get status
all these files are still there I would
send it add dot I also get
m
C4
rewriting history
and I do a git
log
pretty
there you go so C1 C2 C3 still existed
and whatever was a part of C4 and C5 the
older ones I've gotten rid of this along
with those old changes I also added a
new file I made some changes and it was
able to comment it now if you look at my
git history it's all nice and clean
however do this activity only when you
don't push your git repository to the
server one other most powerful and
useful command while undoing or
resetting the history is something
called as revert this is a safe way of
undoing some things remember what I
talked about when exactly you can do a
reset it's only when your changes are
local and is not being pushed to the
repository take this scenario wherein
let's say I have a git server
and I have the changes which are C1
C2
C3
and possibly C4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer 1 is the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so here's God C1 to
C4 on his history
I'm going to jump all these C2 and C3
and get into C4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the C3 which is a wrong thing to do
and possibly you know he could have done
a better job of fixing this in in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the C3 or C4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from C4
all of them would be affected in an
adverse way so in short never go back in
history if at all you need to undo
something go ahead and put in a new
comment to undo something
let's take this example maybe if at all
a developer one wants to get rid of C3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead say let's say C5
and what does this commit to this commit
possibly gets rid of C3 instead of going
back in history it actually is taking
your git history ahead but as a part of
this comment you're undoing some part of
the work that was done as a part of C3
in short you're removing a comment but
to remove a commit you're adding a new
commit and this is why you're doing it
because there are a bunch of other
people who are you're using this
repository collaboratively and what plan
to get ahead in terms of History they
cannot afford to go back in history and
modify something in history all right
the command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all I do a git log
pretty one nine
I have these bunch of comments
and C1 I've added a file in C2 are
another file in C3 I've added one more
file and in C4 I made some changes and
this is the latest comment and this is
the oldest commit so if at all I see the
contents of the git folder it contains
M1 m2m3 and M4 and let's see looking at
the previous use case that I mentioned I
may want to get rid of this particular
comment
I want to get rid of the C3 which is
nothing but I've added a file called M3
dot text but I added it by mistake I
need a better way of fixing it possibly
I look at it later on but for now I
don't want this particular commit and
the changes that were made as a part of
that commit to exist so the better way
to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert and the commit ID
whatever I want to revert so if I want
to revert this
I copy this particular commit ID and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
I can do one commit reward at a time I
can Club a bunch of them together and do
one commit but otherwise the revert
always works on one commit at a time so
get revert
face this
essentially what I'm trying to do I'm
trying to undo this particular commit
while I'm undoing this commit what does
git do it safely adds a new comment and
a part of this new commit It undoes
Whatever changes that were done as a
part of this command so if I say git
revert this
all right I forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me I say write and quit
all right and if I do a git log
all right if you see this C1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from C5 I see another commit
but what was there as a part of this
comment actually is getting rid of this
commit C3 so if at all I see my files
here there's only M1 M2 and M4
was added as a part of C3 now I've
gotten rid of M3 by getting rid of the
revert command for C3 so this is a
better way of undoing things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding it which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because git deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool in most of
the Version Control tools whenever you
create a new Branch a complete copy or a
subset of the whole repository is
created which in my opinion is very very
cost inefficient because it's a very
very expensive operation both in times
of time and the disk space however in
get you just create a very very
lightweight movable pointer whenever you
create a branch there is no folder or no
copy of the repository that is created
in short the branches are very very
inexpensive and great so go ahead and
create any number of branches that you
need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then I'm going to
create a new folder here
I'll create a folder called Arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right I navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here as a
repository and Dot git folder is created
without any files in it so let me create
a few files in it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
I create a name.txt within this maybe
I'll create one more file in this
Notepad
employees dot text
on
has over 3K employees
I just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if I try to get status I just see two
files in it so let me go ahead and add
these two files and let me commit my
changes it's okay
commit hyphen am or iPhone m
first comment
so if I do a gig log
I see only one commit and there are two
files here you can see those two files
that is here
all right so at this stage let me go
ahead and create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get Branch name of the branch so let
me name my branches Bangalore Branch blr
branch
in this created a branch but I don't see
any changes in the folder structure or
in the file that exists here I've just
created this Branch so if at all I do a
git branch
I see these two branches and whatever
star means I am currently in this master
Branch so let me go ahead and get into
the blr branch at this moment the number
of files that exist in this repository
is same there's absolutely no change in
any of the branches both master and
Baylor Branch point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is git checkout
plr Branch I've actually switched into
Bangalore Branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because I've
created a branch from my base branch
which is the master branch and when I
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to Bangalore branch so I
will just say Notepad
maybe I want to put down the address of
this organization specific to Bangalore
in this address dot text so I see
notepad address dot text
I'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some arteries
I would say Bangalore
that is the content of this file
and I'm creating all this new file in
this blr Branch so I'm sync it add Dot I
would say kit
commit hyphen m
angalore branch
commit
all right if you see this now I have an
address.txt which is there only in the
Bangalore branch that I am presently on
now let me switch back to my master
Branch the command to do that is git
checkout Master Branch if you remember
when I forged out or when I created a
new Branch from the master Branch I
didn't have this address dot text in it
so let me go back to git git checkout
Master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address dot text
it kind of disappeared how did that
happen it's all because of this magical
git folder so what happened is now git
knows that when you're in the master
Branch the file that was there in the
Bangalore branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if I come back let's
say I come back to git checkout
Bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears so this particular file is only
present in the branch and git is playing
around with the file system snapshot by
moving the pointers across and ensuring
that whenever I am switching to
Bangalore Branch I see this address dot
text when I go back to my master Branch
I don't say this Bangalore branch
contents which is the address dot text
all right now that I created this Branch
maybe I may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise so the name of the
folder needs to be exactly this one so
let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new Repository
all right this
is the name of the Repository
get Brands demo this is what I'm going
to put in as a description I would say
public I don't want any readme files in
it because I already have a repository I
will just say create a repository
all right let me use
the SSH URL yeah this is the SSH URL
this is good for me so let me copy this
URL
let me add it to you
I'm linking my local repository with the
server and I would let me come back to
my master branch
let me first push my master Branch so I
would say git
push hyphen U origin master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
push my master Branch it looks good it
says new Bunch Master is created so if I
go back to my server and it will
refreshed
if you see it is only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text now
let's try to push the other brands that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git Branch command now
this Branch doesn't exist on the server
and I need to push this new Branch onto
the server so the command would be
get push hyphen new origin and the name
of the brand that I want to specifically
push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if we get into this Bangalore Branch I
will see the address dot text if at all
I go back into Master Branch I would not
see this under stock text
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that I
created back into the master branch that
is what I would mean by merging I would
want the changes that is there as a part
of the bangle Branch to come back into
my master Branch so if I go to click
checkout
Bangalore Branch I see this address.tech
this is there only as a part of
Bangalore Branch now assuming that I am
done with the changes from the Bangalore
Branch I want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge so what is that you want to
merge I want to merge the Bangalore
Branch changes and where will it merge
it will merge it into the current brands
that I'm on presently I'm in the master
Branch so this command would merge the
changes from the Bangalore Branch into
your master Branch so with this if we'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
Bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened quickly and you
will see this address dot text that is
here so if you see let's check the
contents in terms of the git log
foreign
branch that we had earlier which had
only one commit right now we are at this
Bangalore Branch commit which was there
as a part of the Bangalore Branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well git push
origin master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all I do a refresh out here
okay I mean two branches the princess's
Master even if I'm in master plan I
should see this address dot text that is
there even if I'm in the Bangalore
Branch the content is all same because
we immersed these two branches now that
I've merged this Branch I don't need
this Branch anymore so I would go ahead
and delete this locally as well as push
it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete Branch locally the command is get
Branch hyphen D and the name of the
branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
I would say get brands and I'm presently
in the master Branch so I can go ahead
and delete the other Branch so git
Branch hyphen D Bangalore branch
all right this got rid of our Pandora
Branch locally
if at all I don't get Branch iPhone V it
shows there's only one branch as of now
however this Branch would still exist on
the server because Server doesn't know
anything about the changes that we have
done we need to specifically push our
changes onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iPhone delete and the name of the
branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within git and as I said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive in it go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish off your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the git branching commands
are as follows to create a new Branch
you issue a command git Branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
Branch from the existing Branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command gate to Branch new
underscore Branch it creates a new
underscore Branch from the master Branch
once you create a new branch in order to
get into this Branch you would type in
git check out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific Branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command get
push hyphen U origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new Branch are pushed
onto this server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git Branch hyphen AV assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master Branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
Branch into a master Branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch this
would automatically merge the branch
contents that you specified into the
branch on which you currently reside if
at all you are on the master branch and
if you issue a command git much new
underscore Branch this would merge the
contents of the new Branch onto the
master Branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this Branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get Branch
hyphen capital D and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this Branch from the server
the command to do that is git push
origin hyphen iPhone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
brands that you created on the server in
this session work in a deep dive into
what Jenkins is and how it improves your
devops continuous integration
environments so let's talk a little bit
about life before Jenkins let's see this
scenario I think it's something that
maybe all of you can relate to as
developers we all write code and we all
submit that code into a code repository
and we all keep working away writing our
unit tests and hopefully we're running
running our unit tests but the problem
is that the actual commits that actually
gets sent to the code repository aren't
consistent you as a developer may be
based in India you may have another
developer that's based in the
Philippines and you may have another
team lead that's based in the UK and
another development team that's based in
North America so you're all working at
different times and you have different
amounts of code going into the code
repository there's issues with the
integration and you're kind of running
into a situation that we'd like to call
development how where things just aren't
working out and there's just lots of
delays being added into the project and
the bugs just keep mounting up the
bottom line is the project is delayed
and in the past what we would have to do
is we'd have to wait until the entire
software code was built and tested and
before we could even begin checking for
errors and this just really kind of
increased the amount of problems that
you'd have in your project
the actual process of delivering
software was slow there was no way that
you could actually iterate on your
software and you just ended up with just
a big headache with teams pointing
fingers at each other and blaming each
other so let's jump into Jenkins and see
what Jenkins is and how it can address
these problems so Jenkins is a product
that comes out of the concept of
continuous integration that you may have
heard of as power developers where you'd
have two developers sitting next to each
other coding against the same piece of
information what they were able to do is
to continuously develop their code and
test their code and move on to new
sections of code Jenkins is a product
that allows you to expand on that
capacity to your entire team so you're
able to submit your codes consistently
into a source code environment so there
are two ways in which you can do
continuous delivery one is through 90
builds and one is through continuous so
the approach that you can look at
continuous delivery is modifying the
Legacy approach to building out
Solutions so what we used to do is we
would wait for nightly builds and the
way that our nightly builds would work
and operate is that as co-developers we
would all run and have a cut-off time at
the end of the day and that was
consistent around the world that we
would put our codes into a single
repository and at night all of that code
would be run and operated and tested to
see if there were any changes and a new
build would be created that would be
referred to as the nightly build with
continuous integration we're able to go
one step further we're able to not only
commit our changes into our source code
but we can actually do this continuously
there's no need to race and have a team
get all of their code in at arbitrary
time you can actually do a continuous
release because what you're doing is
you're putting your tests and your
verification Services into the build
environment so you're always running
Cycles to test against your code this is
the power that Jenkins provides in
continuous integration so let's dig
deeper into continuous integration so
the concept of continuous integration is
that as a developer you're able to pull
from a repository the code that you're
working on and then you'll be able to
then at any time submit the code that
you're working on into a continuous
integration server and the goal of that
continuous integration server is that it
actually goes ahead and validates and
passes any tests that a tester may have
created now if on the continuous
integration server a test is a pass then
that code gets sent back to the
developer and the developer can then
make their changes it allows the
developer to actually do a couple of
things it allows the developer not to
break the build and we all don't want to
break the builds that are being created
but it also allows the developer not to
actually have to run all the tests
locally on their computer write tests
particularly if you have a lot large
number of tests can take up a lot of
time so if you can push that service up
to another environment like a continuous
integration server it really improves
the productivity of your developer
what's also good is that if there are
any code errors that have come up that
may be Beyond just the standard CI test
so maybe there's a Code the way that you
write your code isn't consistent those
errors can then be passed on easily from
the tester back to the developer too the
goal from doing all this testing is that
you're able to release and deploy and
your customer is able to get new code
faster and when they get that code it's
simply just works so let's talk a little
bit about some of the tools that you may
have in your continuous integration
environment so the cool thing with
working with continuous integration
tools is that they are all open source
at least the ones that we have listed
here are open source there are some that
are private but typically you'll get
started with open source tools and it
gives you the opportunity to understand
how you can accelerate your environment
quickly so bamboo is a continuous
integration tool that specifically runs
multiple builds in parallel for faster
compilation so if you have multiple
versions of your software that runs on
multiple platforms this is a tool that
really allows you to get that up and
running super fast so that your teams
can actually test how those different
builds would work for different
environments and this has integration
with and Maven and other similar tools
so one of the tools you're going to need
is a tool that allows you to automate
the software build test and release
process and buildbot is that open source
product for you again it's an open
source tool so there's no license
associated with this so you can actually
go in and you can actually get the
environment up and running and you can
then test for and build your environment
and create your releases very quickly so
buildbot's also written in Python and it
does support parallel execution jobs
across multiple platforms if you're
working specifically on Java projects
that need to be built and test then
Apache Gump is the tool for you it makes
all of those projects really easy it
makes all the Java projects easier for
you to be able to test with API level
and functionality level testing so one
of the popular places to actually store
code and create a versioning of your
code is GitHub and it's a service that's
available on the web just recently
acquired by Microsoft if you are storing
your projects in GitHub then you'll be
able to use Travis continuous
integration or Travis CI and it's a tool
design specifically for hosted GitHub
projects and so finally we're covering
Jenkins and Jenkins is a central tool
for automation for all of your projects
now when you're working with Jenkins
sometimes you'll find there's
documentation that refers to a product
called Hudson Hudson is actually the
original version of the product that
finally became Jenkins and it was
acquired by Oracle when that acquisition
happens the team behind
um Hudson was a little concerned about
the direction that Oracle May
potentially go with Hudson and so they
created a hard Fork of Hudson that they
renamed Jenkins and Jenkins has now
become that open source product it is
one of the most popular and continuously
contributed projects that's available as
open source so you're always getting new
features being added to it it's a tool
that really becomes the center for your
CI environment so let's jump into some
of those really great features that are
available available in Jenkins so
Jenkins itself is really comprised of
five key areas around easy installation
easy configuration plugins extensibility
and distribution so as I mentioned for
the easy installation Jenkins is a
self-contained Java program and that
allows it to run on most popular
operating systems including Windows Mac
OS and Unix you even run it on Linux it
really isn't too bad to set up it used
to be much harder than it is today the
setup process has really improved the
web interface makes it really easy for
you to check for any errors in addition
you have great built-in help one of the
things that makes tools like Jenkins
really powerful for developers and
continuous integration teams in your
devops teams as a whole when you have
plugins that you can then add in to
extend the base functionality of the
product Jenkins has hundreds of plugins
and you can go and visit the update
Center and see which other plugins that
would be good for your devops
environment certainly checking out
there's just lots of stuff out there in
addition to the plugin architecture
Jenkins is also extremely extensible the
opportunity for you to be able to
configure Jenkins to fit in your
environment it's almost endless now it's
really important to remember that you
are extending Jenkins not creating a
custom version of Jenkins and that's a
great differentiation because the core
Foundation remains as the court Jenkins
product the extensibility can then be
continued with newer releases of Jenkins
so you're always having the latest
version of Jenkins and your extensions
mature with those core Foundation the
distribution and the nature of Jenkins
makes it really easy for you to be able
to have it available across your entire
network it really will become the center
of your CI environment and it's
certainly one of the easier tools and
more effective tools for devops so let's
jump into the standard Jenkins pipeline
so when you're doing development you
start off and you're coding away on your
computer the first thing you have to do
when you're working in the Jenkins
pipeline is to actually commit your code
now as a developer this is something
that you're already doing or at least
you should be doing you're committing
your code to a git server or to an SVN
server or a similar type of service so
in this instance you'll be using Jenkins
as the place for you to commit your code
Jenkins will then create a build of your
code and part of that build process is
actually going through and running
through tests and again as a developer
you're already comfortable with running
unit tests and writing those tests to
validate your code but there may be
additional tests that Jenkins is running
so for instance as a team you may have a
standard set of tests for how you
actually write out your code so that
each team member can understand the code
that's been written and those tests can
also be included in the testing process
within the Jenkins environment assuming
everything past the the tests you can
then get everything placed in a stage
and release ready environment within
Jenkins and finally getting ready to
deploy or deliver your code to a
production environment Jenkins is going
to be the tool that helps you with your
server environment to be able to deploy
your code to the production environment
and the result is that you're able to
move from a developer to production code
really quickly this whole process can be
automated rather than having to wait for
people to actually test your codes or
going through a nightly build you're
looking at being able to commit your
code and go through this testing process
and release process continuously as an
example companies Etsy will release up
to 50 different versions of their
website every single day
so let's talk about the architecture
within Jenkins it allows you to be so
effective at applying a continuous
delivery devops environment so the
server architecture really is broken up
into two sections so on the left hand
side of section you have the code the
developers are doing and submitting that
code to a source code repository and
then from then Jenkins is your
continuous integration server and it
will then pull any code that's been sent
to the source code repository and we'll
run tests against it it'll use a build
server such as MAV intro actually then
build the code and every single stage
that we have that Jenkins manages there
are constant tests so for instance if a
build fails that feedback is sent right
back to the developers so that they can
then change their code so that the build
environment can run effectively the
final stage is to actually execute
specific test scripts and these test
scripts can be written in selenium M so
it's probably good to mention here that
both mavin and selenium are plugins that
run in the Jenkins environment so before
we were talking about how Jenkins can be
extended with plugins mavin and selenium
are just two very popular examples of
how you can extend the Jenkins
environment the goal to go through this
whole process again it's an automated
process is to get your code from the
developer to the production server as
quickly as possible have it fully tested
and have no errors so it's probably
important at this point to mention uh
one piece of information around the
Jenkins environment that if you have
different code builds that need to be
managed and distributed this will
require that you need to have multiple
builds being managed Jenkins itself
doesn't allow for multiple files and
builds to be executed on a single server
you need to have a multiple server
environment with running different
versions of Jenkins for that to be able
to happen so let's talk a little bit
about the Master Slave architecture
within Jenkins so what we have here is
an overview of the Master Slave
architecture within Jenkins on the left
hand side is the remote source code
repository and that remote source code
repository could be GitHub or it could
be team Foundation services or the new
Azure devops code repository or it could
be your own git repository the Jenkins
server acts as the master environment on
the left hand side and that Master
environment can then push out to
multiple other Jenkins slave
environments to distribute the workload
so it allows you to run multiple builds
and tests and production environments
simultaneously across your entire
architecture so Jenkins slaves can be
running the different build versions of
the code for different operating systems
and the server Master is controlling how
each of those builds operate so let's
step into a quick story of a company
that has used Jenkins very successfully
so here's a use case scenario
um over the last 10 or 15 years there
has been a significant shift within the
automotive industry where manufacturers
have shifted from creating complex
Hardware to actually creating software
we've seen that with companies such as
Tesla where they are creating uh
software to manage their cars we see the
same thing with companies such as
General Motors with their OnStar program
and Ford just recently have rebranded
themselves as a technology company
rather than just a automotive company
what this means though is that the
software within these cars is becoming
more complex and requires more testing
to allow more capabilities and
enhancements to be added to the core
software so Bosch is a company that
specifically ran into this problem and
their challenge was that they wanted to
be able to streamline the increase
increasingly complex Automotive software
by adopting continuous integration and
continuous delivery best practices with
the goal of being able to delight and
exceed the customer expectations of the
end user so Bosch has actually used
Cloud bees which is the Enterprise
Jenkins environment so to be able to
reduce the number of manual steps such
as building deploying and testing Bosch
has introduced the use of cloud bees
from Jenkins and this is part of the
Enterprise Jenkins platform it has
significantly helped improve the
efficiencies throughout the whole
software developments cycle from
automation stability and transparency
because Jenkins becomes a self-auditing
environment now the results have been
tangible previously it took three days
before a build process could be done and
now it's taken that same three-day
process and reduced it to less than
three hours that is significant
large-scale deployments are now kept on
track and have expert support and there
is clear visibility and transparency
across the whole operations through
using the Jenkins tools let's get
started with Jenkins Jenkins is a web
application that is written in Java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install Jenkins I have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
Jenkins is usually installed on in any
system the topmost one is as a Windows
or a Linux Based Services so if at all
you have Windows like the way I have and
I'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so I would download a MSI installer
that is specific to Jenkins and install
this service so whenever I installed as
a service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
Jenkins and I have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of Linux as well one other
way of running Jenkins is downloading
this generic War file and as long as we
have jdk installed you can launch this
war file by the command opening up a
command prompt or shell prompt
differently on Linux box specifying Java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using Jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control C and then bring down this
prompt and your Jenkins server would be
down other older versions of Jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a Java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so Jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
Administration is all taken care of by
the Apache or the Tomcat server or the
web server on which Jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a Java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up Jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter how we're going to bring up your
Jenkins instance the way we're going to
operate Jenkins is all going to be very
very same or similar one with the subtle
changes in terms of user Administration
if at all you're launching it through
any other web server which will take
care of the user Administration
otherwise all the commands are all the
configuration or the way in which I'm
going to run this demo it is going to be
same across any of these installations
all right so the prerequisites for
running Jenkins as I mentioned earlier
Jenkins is nothing but a simple web
application that is written in Java so
all that it needs is Java preferably jdk
1.7 or 1.8 2GB Ram is the recommended
RAM for running Jenkins and also like
any other open source tool sets when you
install jdk ensure that you set in the
environment variable Java home to point
to the right directory this is something
very specific to jdk but for any other
open source tools that you've installed
there is always a preferred environment
variable that you got to set in which is
specific to that particular tool that
you're going to use this is a generic
thing that is there for you know for any
other open source projects because the
way open source projects discover
themselves is using this environment
variables so as a general practice or a
good practice always set this
environment variables accordingly so I
already have jdk 1.8 installed on my
system but in case you do not what I
would recommend is just navigate on your
browser to the Oracle home page and just
type in or search for install jdk1.heat
and navigate to The Oracle home page
you'll have to accept the license
agreement and there are a bunch of
installers that is okay that you can
pick up based upon the operating system
on which you're running so I have this
windows 64 installer that is already
installed and running on my system so I
will not get into the details of
downloading this or installing it let me
show you once I install this what I've
done with regard to my path
so if you get into environment variables
all right so I've just set in a Java
home variable
if you see this C colon program files
Java jdk1.8 this is where my my Java is
located C program files C program files
Java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what I've been I've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my Java home
alright one other thing to do is ensure
that in case you want to run Java or
Java C from a command prompt and show
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere I will see yes there you go
see colon program files Java jdk 1.8 pin
so with these two I'll ensure that my
Java installation is nice and you know
good enough so to check that to double
check that or to verify that let me just
open up a simple command prompt
and if I type in Java hyphen version
all right and Java C
yphen version
so the compiler is on the path Java is
on the path and if at all I do this
even the environment variable specific
to my Java is installed correctly so I
am good to go ahead with my Jenkins
installation
now that I have my prerequisites
all set for installing Jenkins let me
just go ahead and download Jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
Jenkins
all right LTS is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies I would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that long term support
is good enough and as I mentioned there
are so many flavors of Jenkins that is
available for download all right so what
I want is yes this is the war file which
is generic War file that I was talking
to you earlier and this is the windows
MSI installer so go ahead and download
this MSI installer I already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
Jenkins instance or other installer this
is a pretty maybe a few months old but
this is good enough for me
before you start uh Jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called Jenkins home this is
where Jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
Jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an MSI
installer all your installation gets
into SQL and program files 86 and
Jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user ID with
which you're running your War file the
Jenkins folder there's a DOT Jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
Jenkins or even Jenkins installations to
get into some specific directories go
ahead and set this Jenkins home variable
accordingly before you even begin your
installation for now I don't need to do
any of these things so I've already
downloaded the installer let me just go
ahead with the default installation all
right so this is my Jenkins MSI
installer I would just I don't want to
make any changes in into the Jenkins
configuration C colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes I'm
happy with this I don't want to change
this I would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
Jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default Jenkins Launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein I need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so I'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a Jenkins installation so as a part of
the installation it just asks you to do
this
so if that is not correct it will crib
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins what
happens is the plugins are all related
to each other so it's like the typical
RPM kind of a problem where you try to
install some plugin and it's got a
dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what Jenkins
recommends is a bunch of plugins that is
already recommended so just go ahead and
blindly click that install recommended
plugin so if you see there is a whole
lot of plugins which are bare essential
plugin that is required for Jenkins in
order to run properly so Jenkins as a
part of the installation would get all
these plugins and then install it for
you this is a good combination to kind
of begin with and mind you at this
moment Jenkins needs uh lots of
bandwidth in terms of network so in case
your you know your network is not so
good few of these plugins would kind of
fail and these plugins are all you know
all available on openly or or mirrored
sites and sometimes some of them may be
down so do not worry in case some of
these plugins kind of fail to install
you'll get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed my plugin
installation is all good there was no
failures in any of my plugins so after
that I get to create this first admin
user again this is one important point
that you got to remember
Keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it alright so I'm going to create a very
very simple username and password
something that I can remember
I will
that's my name and um an email ID is
kind of optional but it doesn't allow me
to go ahead in case I don't so I just
given an admin and I got a password I've
got I remember my password this is my
full name
all right I say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
Jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that I have my Jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
UI is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys but if at all your Java
guy you know how painful it is to write
UI in Java you will kind of appreciate
you know all the effort that has gone
into the UI bottom line you always
little hard to you know wrap your head
around it but once you start using it
possibly you'll start liking it all
right so let me get into something
called as manage Jenkins
this can be viewed like a main menu for
all Jenkins configuration so I'll get
into some of those important ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete Jenkins instance few things to
kind of look out for this is a home
directory this is a Java home where all
the configurations all the workspace
anything and everything regarding
Jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and it's possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets Jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough in case at any
point in time if there are multiple jobs
that kind of get triggered the same time
in case the number of executors are less
compared to the number of jobs that have
that woken up no need to panic because
they will all get queued up and
eventually Jenkins will get to running
those jobs just bear in mind that
whenever a new job kind of you know gets
triggered the CPU usage and the memory
usage in terms of the disk right is very
high on the Jenkins instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors two for my system is kind of
good label for my Jenkins I don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your Jenkins this is good
for me because I only have a primary uh
server that is running so I want to use
this node as much as possible quite
better each of these options I've got
some bare minimal help kind of a thing
that is that is out there by clicking on
these question marks you will get to
know as to what are these particular
configurations
all right so this all look good what I
want to show you here is there's
something triggering the docker
timestamps git plugin SVN email
notifications I don't want that what I
want the yes I want this SMTP server
configuration remember I mentioned
earlier that I would Bond Jenkins to be
sending out some emails and what I've
done here is I've just configured the
SMTP details of my personal email ID
in case you are in a in an organization
you would have some sort of an email IDs
that is set up for a Jenkins server so
you can specify the SMTP server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize Jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me I have configured my
personal email ID which is on my Gmail
for sending out notifications so the
SMTP server would be
smtp.gmail.com I'm using the SMTP
authentication I have provided my email
ID and my password I'm using the SMTP
Port which is 465 and I'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine I can
just send out an email and see if at all
this configuration works again Gmail
would not allow you to allow anybody to
send out notifications on your behalf so
you'll have to lower the security level
of your Gmail ID so that you can allow a
programmatically somebody to send out
email notifications on your behalf so
I've done already that I'm just trying
to see if I can send a test mail with
the configuration that I've set in
yes all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your you
know your Gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization SMTP server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that I'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so I come back to manage
inkins okay one other thing that I want
to kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario or look at it this
way Jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know what
kind of a code base it's going to pull
in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you would have to put in all
the tools that is required for building
the appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just give
you an example in case your source code
is a Java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and I've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because I'm a developer I am
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server without anything being
installed on it so in case I want
Jenkins to you know run a Java code I
would need to install GDK on it I need
to specify the jdk location of this out
here this way
okay since I already have the jdk
installed and I've already put in the
Java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly I don't
need to do it git if at all I want the
Jenkins server to use git a git is a you
know command Dash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
Gradle and Maven if at all you have some
mavens as well if you want to do this
any other tool that you're going to
install on your system which is your
continuous integration server you will
have to come in here and configure
something
in case you don't configure it when
Jenkins runs it will not be able to find
these tools for building your task and
it'll crib about it
that's good I don't want to save
anything
manage Jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure Global Security
all right the secret is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to Jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know Jenkins by default it uses file
system where it stores all the usernames
with hashes up these usernames and kind
of stores them
so as of now it Jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your Jenkins repository rather
Jenkins tool so you would specify your
ldap server details the root DN password
or the manager DN and the manager
password and all these details in case
you want to connect your Jenkins
instance with your ldap or ad or any of
the authentication servers that you have
in your organization
but for now since I don't have any of
these things I'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so I will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once I put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that Jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have Jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so I'm going to save
all this stuff that's good for me so
enough of all these configurations let
me put in a very very simple job all
right so job new item you know little
difficult to kind of figure out but then
that's the new item so I will just say
you know first job this is good for me I
just give a name for my job I would say
it's a freestyle project that's good
enough for me I don't want to choose any
of that so unless until you choose any
of this this particular button would not
become active so choose the freestyle
project and say okay
at a very high level you will see
General source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am I doing at the
moment I'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so I don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo purpose let me just put in a very
very simple job I'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first Jenkins job all right I don't want
to choose any of these again there are
some helps available here
I don't want to choose any of this I
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now I don't want any triggers
for now I'll come back to this in in a
while build the environment I don't want
any build environment as a part of this
build step you know I just want to you
know run few things so that I kind of
complete this particular job so since
I'm on Windows box I would say execute
Windows batch command
all right so what do you want to do I
will let me just Echo something Echo
uh hello this is my first Jenkins job
and possibly I would want the date and
the timestamp
pertaining to the job I mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right I don't want to do anything
else I want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me save this job
all right so once you save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then I need to build this job and you
would see some build history out here
nothing is there as of now because I've
just put in a job I have not run it yet
alright so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you would see a
date and a timestamp so if I click on
this you will see a console output if I
go here
okay as simple as that and where is all
the job details that is getting into if
you see this
if I navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
I was mentioning earlier regarding
Jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular Jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here all right so the workspace is
where all the jobs that I've created
whichever I'm running would you know
there will be an individual folders
specific to the jobs that has been put
up here all right so one job one quick
run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
I would say second job
I would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
I just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on Jenkins
it should be triggered automatically
remember what I said earlier about
Jenkins because at the core of Jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server all right so what I'm going to do
I will just keep everything else the
same I'm going to put in a build script
pretty much similar to
second job
that gets triggered
automatically
every minute all right let me do that
percentage date and I'll put in the time
all right so I just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what I was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time I'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger so a build can
be triggered using various triggers that
is there so we'll get into this GitHub
uh triggering uh hook or a web hook kind
of a triggering later on but for now
what I want to do I want to ensure that
this job that I'm going to put in would
be automatically triggered on its own
let's say every minute I want this job
to be run on its own
so build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you you have written cron jobs
on Linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's one two three four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that I'm
gonna put in and Jenkins got a little
worried and he's asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah I want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do I check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not I just don't do
anything I'll just wait for a minute and
if at all everything goes well Jenkins
would automatically trigger my second
job in a minute's time from now
this time around I'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see it's
automatically got triggered
if I go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42 1642 which is 442 my time that
looks good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this job would be
automatically triggered
now that I have my Jenkins up and
running a few jobs that has been put up
here on my Jenkins instance I would need
a way of controlling access to my
Jenkins server this is wherein I would
use a plugin called role based access
plugin and create few rules the rules
are something like a global Rule and a
project role Project Specific role I can
have different rules and I can have
users who have signed up or the users
who might create kind of assigned to
these roles so that each of these users
fall into some category this is my way
of kind of controlling access to my
Jenkins instance and ensuring that
people don't do something unwarranted
alright so first things first let me go
ahead and install a plugin for doing
that so getting to manage Jenkins and
manage plugin
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed and advanced as of now we
don't have the role based plugin so let
me go to available it'll take some time
for you to get refreshed all right now
these are the available plugins these
are the install plugins all right so let
me come back to available and I would
want to search for my role based access
plugin so I would say search for role
and hit enter
okay role-based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a
role-based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or notes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that I want I would want to
install it without a restart
all right looks good so far yes
go back to the top of the page yes
and remember Jenkins is running on a
Java using a Java instance so typically
many things would work the same way
understand until you want to restart
Jenkins once in a while but as a good
practice whenever you do some sort of a
big installations or big patches on your
Jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restarted otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your Jenkins instance but for
now I don't need that it looks good I've
installed the plugin so where do you see
my plugin I install the plugin that is
specific to the user control or the
access control so let me go into yes
Global Security
and I would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what I would want to enable
because I already have my own database
set up and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what I'm going
to install I mean I've already installed
a role-based strategy plugin and I'm
going to enable that strategy all right
I would say save okay now I've installed
the role based access plugin I would
need to just set it up and check that
you know I would go ahead and create
some roles and ensure that I assign
users as per these roles all right so
let me go to
manage Jenkins
configure all right let me see where is
this configure configure Global Security
is that where I create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now I've just enabled the plugin I
have enabled role based access control
and I would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular Jenkins
instance so I would say first manage
rules
so I would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are Global rules and there
are some project roles and there are
some slave rules I'll not get into
details of all of these at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a row a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so I would
create a role called developer typically
the Jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by QA
guys so QA guys would need to provide
some sort of a you know limited access
to developers so that's why I'm creating
a role called developer
and I'm adding this role at a global
role level so I would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
you can click hover over it you would
see some sort of a help on what what are
these uh you know permissions specific
to so what I want is like you know it
sounds a little you know different but I
would want to give very very little
permissions for the developer so from an
Administration perspective I would just
want him to have a read
um kind of a role credentials again I
would just want to view kind of a role I
don't want him to create any agents and
all that stuff that's looks good for me
for a job I would want him to just
possibly read I don't want him to build
I don't want him to cancel any jobs I
don't want him to configure any job I
don't even want him to create any job I
would just want him to read few things I
would not give him possibly a role to
the workspace as well I mean I don't
want him to have access to the workspace
I would just want him to read a job
I'll check you know have read only
access to the job run
um no I don't want him to give him any
any particular access which will allow
him to run any jobs view configure yeah
possibly create yeah delete I don't want
to read yes definitely and this is the
specific role so what I'm doing I'm just
creating a global role called developer
and I'm giving him very very limited
roles in the sense that I don't want
this developer to be able to run any
agents nor create jobs or build jobs or
cancel jobs or configure jobs at the max
I would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there
okay so I would save
now I've created a rule I still don't
have any users that is there on the
system so let me go ahead and create
some user on the system
that's not here I will say configure
manage and cans manage users
okay let me create a new user I would
call this user as yeah developer one
sounds good
some password
some password that I can remember
okay his name is developer One D at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which I kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that I have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so I would go to manage and gains
I would say
manage and assign rules I would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what I'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular deal I will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that I have already
configured
the role shows up here I would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular role so if
you remember the user that I created was
developer one I would add this
particular user and now this particular
user what kind of a role I want him to
have because this is the global rule
that it created so developer I would
assign this developer one to this
particular Global route and I would go
ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so there you go I have gen games but I
don't see a new item I can't trigger a
new job I can't do anything I see these
jobs however I don't think so I'll be
able to start this job I don't have the
permission set for that the maximum I
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and I added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role so that the
developers don't get to configure any of
the jobs because the Jenkins instance is
owned by a cure person he doesn't want
to give developer any administrative
rights so the rights that he set out by
creating a developer role and anybody
who is tagged any user who is tagged as
a part of this developer role would get
the same kind of permissions and these
permissions can be you know fine-grained
it can be a Project Specific permissions
as well but for now I just demonstrated
the high level permission that had set
in let me quickly log out of this user
and get back as the admin user because I
need to continue with my demo with the
developer role that was created I have
very very less privileges one of the
reasons for Jenkins being so popular as
I mentioned earlier is the bunch of
plugins that is provided by users or
Community users who don't charge any
money for these plugins but it's got
plugins for connecting anything and
everything so if you can navigate to or
if you can find Jenkins plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect Jenkins to an AWS instance or
you want to connect Jenkins to a Docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if I want to connect Jenkins
to big bucket
big bucket is one of the git servers has
so many plugins that is available okay
so bottom line Jenkins without plugins
is nothing so plugins is the heart of
Jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect Jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got Java and Maven
you would need to install Maven and GDK
on your Jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
Microsoft build you would need to have
MS build installed on your on your
Jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger Ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server-side web hooks
from GitHub you would need GitHub
specific plugins if you want to connect
Jenkins to AWS you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a Docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the URL which is
publicly reachable you just have a
Docker plugin that is installed on your
Jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect Jenkins build and build a
job on Jenkins and push it to sonar Cube
and get sonar Cube to run analysis on
that and get back the results in Jenkins
all of these works very well because of
the plugins now with that let me connect
our Jenkins instance to GitHub I already
have very very simple Java repository up
on my GitHub instance so let me connect
Jenkins to this particular GitHub
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple uh you know repository that
is there called hello Java and this is
what is there in the report there is a
hello hello to Java application that is
here or a simple class file that is
there it's got just one line of system
dot out so this is already present on
github.com at this place and this would
be the URL for this Repository
if I pick up the https URL this is my
https URL so what I would do is I would
connect my Jenkins instance to go to
GitHub provide my credentials and pull
out this repository which is on the
cloud hosted github.com and get it to my
Jenkins instance and then build this
particular Java file I'm keeping the
source code very very simple it's just
at the Java file how do I build my Java
file how do I compile my Java file I
just say Java C and the name of my class
file which is hello.java and how do I
run my Java file I would say Java and
hello
okay so remember I don't need to install
any plugins now because uh what it needs
is a git plugin so if you remember when
we were doing the installation there was
a bunch of recommended plugins so git is
already installed on my system so I
don't need to install it again so let me
put up a new job here this is a git job
let it be a freestyle project that's
good for me I would say okay
all right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some Echo kind of jobs
we did not need any integration with any
of the source code systems so now let me
connect this so I'm going to put up a
source code and git would sure because
the plugin is already there SVN perforce
any of those additional source code
management tools if at all you would
need just install those plugins and
Jenkins connects wonderfully well to all
these particular Source control tools
okay so I would copy the https URL from
here I would say this is the URL that
I'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so I'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so I would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password I just save this I say add
and then I would say you know use these
credentials to go to GitHub and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
Jenkins not able to find git or the
git.exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me I'm going to grab this URL what
am I gonna do the step would pull the
source code from the GitHub and then
what would be there as a part of my
build step
because this repository just has a Java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this I would just say
execute Windows batch command and I
would say Java C
Hello dot Java that is the way I would
build my Java core and if I have to run
it I would just say Java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from GitHub
Java that sounds good I would say save
this and let me try to run this
okay if you see there's a lot of you
know it executes git on your behalf it
goes out here it provides my credentials
and says you know it pulls all my
repository and by default it will pull
up the master branch that is there on my
repository and it kind of builds this
whole thing Java C hello to Java and it
runs this project Java hello and there
you see this is the output that is there
and if at all you want to look at the
contents of the repository if you can go
here this is my
workspace of my system hang on this is
not right
okay good job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my GitHub repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the negative repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and Jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to GitHub pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my Jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that I've integrated Jenkins
successfully with GitHub for a simple
Java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what I will do is I
have a maven-based web application that
is up there as a repository in my GitHub
so this is the repository that I'm
talking about it's called AMV and web
app it's got It's a maven-based
repository as you would know my one is a
very very simple Java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and it
can you can build a war file and even
deploy it into some other server for now
what we're going to use Maven is just
for building and creating a package out
of this particular web application it
contains a bunch of things and what is
important is just the index.jsp it just
contains an HTML file that is there as a
part of this web application so from a
perspective of requirements now I'm
going to connect Jenkins with this
particular repository git we already
have that set we only need two other
things one is Maven because Jenkins will
use Maven so in order to use Maven
Jenkins would have to have a maven
installation that is there on the
Jenkins box and in this case the link is
box is this laptop
and after I have my Maven installed I
also need a tomcat server Tomcat is a
very very simple web server that you can
freely download I'll let you know how to
quickly uh download and install the atom
CAD alright so download Maven first
at the various ways in which you can
kind of download this my one there is
zip files binary zip files and archive
files so what I've done is I've just
already downloaded Maven and if you see
I've unzipped it here so this is the
folder with which I have unzipped my
maven so as you know I'm having again is
is a one open source build tool so
you'll have to set in a few
configurations and set up the path so
mvn hyphen iPhone version if I specify
this after setting my path my one should
work and if at all I Echo M2 home which
is nothing but the variable environment
variable specific to my one it is always
set here so once you unzip my one just
set this M2 home variable to the
directory where you unzip your my one
also just set the path to this
particular directory slash bin because
that is where your Maven executables are
all found
all right so that's with Maven and you
know since I've set the path and the
environment variable Maven is running
perfectly fine on my system I've just
verified it okay next one is the Tomcat
server
download Apache Tomcat server 8.5 is
what I have on my system so I'm just
gonna show you where to download this
from
this is where you download Tomcat server
and um I already have the server
downloaded again this doesn't need any
installation I just unzip it here and it
kind of has a bin and configuration I've
made some subtle changes in the
configuration first and foremost Tomcat
server also by default runs on port 8080
since we already have our Jenkins server
running on port 8080 we cannot let
Tomcat run on the same port there will
be a port Clash so what I've done I have
configured Tomcat to use a different
port so if I go to this configuration
file here there is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 80 80. I have just
modified it to 8081 so I've changed the
port on which my Tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when Jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloy
deployment by Tomcat so for that I need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my Jenkins
instance
so I would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
I have already created a username called
deployer and the password is deployer
and I've added a role called manager
hyphen script manager hyphen script will
allow programmatic access to the Tomcat
server so this is the role that is there
so using this credentials I will enable
or I'll Empower Jenkins to get into my
Tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required let me just start my Tomcat
server first so I get into my bin folder
I open a command prompt here and there's
a startup.bat
the first it just takes a few seconds
yes there you go Tomcat server is up and
running now this is running on Port 8081
so let me just check if that looks good
so localhost
okay my Tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what I'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
I'm good to use Maven as a part of my
Jenkins so I will put up a simple job
now
I will say job
mbn
web app I call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the URL of Market repository is
this guy
https URL okay
because this URL I will use the
credentials the old credential that I
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that I'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after I get this since I said this
is a simple Maven repository I will have
some Maven targets to run
so the simple Target first is let me run
Maven package this creates a war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever I
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my War file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a word file and if
you see it all shows you what is the
location where this war file was
generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this wi-fi was successfully built
now I need to grab this particular War
file and then I would need to deploy it
into Tomcat server again I would need a
small plugin to do this because I need
to connect Tomcat with my Jenkins server
let me go ahead and install the plugin
for the container deployment so I will
go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that I would need I
would install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the Target folder
I will see this web application War file
that is already built so I would need to
configure this plugin to pull up this
war file and deploy it onto the Tomcat
server for deploying onto the Tomcat
server I will use the credentials of the
user that I've created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good I'm going to just
create a package that's all fine now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this deployment to
container now this will show up after
you install the plugin so deploy this
one to the container now what is that
you're supposed to specify you're
supposed to specify the what is the
location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot War that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the Tomcat server
I will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now I need
to specify what kind of a container that
I'm talking about all right so the
deployment would be for
the stormcat 8.5 is what I need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that I have so this
would be the URL so the credentials yes
I need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember I
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that my Tomcat server yes
configuration of this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployed
okay so let me use that credential
I would say I would say add a new
credential Jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
replyer
so I would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so this is the URL of my
Tomcat instance so take the war file
that is fine found in this particular
folder and then you know context path is
MN web app use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the Tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
I would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it built successfully built the war
file it is trying to deploy it and looks
like a deployment went ahead perfectly
well
so
the context path was in my web app so if
I type in this
all right if at all I go ahead into my
Tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the Explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the GitHub server it was built locally
on the Jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo I am running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
Tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
IP address all that you got to go and
change is the URL of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat server which is running on
some other machine that's all fine with
a different IP that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this Jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
Jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using Jenkins and my
own distributed build or Master Slave
configuration in Jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of Jenkins server up and
running all the time and also I told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the Jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the CPU utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you are heavily
reliant on the Jenkins server you don't
want your Jenkins server to go down so
that's wherein you kind of start
Distributing the load that is there on
the Jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all the
kind of jobs and what he'll do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some of the machines or some other
sleeves you know that's a wonderful
thing to have okay use case one use case
two assuming that you know if you have a
Jenkins server that is running on a
Windows box or on a Linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
Windows you know Windows based.net kind
of a project where you would need a
Windows machine to build this particular
project you also have a requirement
where you want to build Linux the next
based are systems you also have a Mac
you you support some sort of an apps or
something that is built on Mac OS you
would need to build you know Mac based
system as well so how are you going to
support all these needs so that's
wherein a beautiful concept of Master
Slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one Jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this Jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some server triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a very nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
Jenkins installation all that he got to
do is have a very very simple Runner or
sleeve that's a simple jar file that is
run as a low priority thread or a
process Within These systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the Master Slave
configuration so what I'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is I will set
up a simple slave but since I don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what I'll do is I will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so I've got the C drive and D drive my
Jenkins is on my C drive so what I do is
I would just use my e Drive and set up a
very very simple slave out there I'll
just show you how to provision a slave
and how to connect to a slave and how to
delegate a job to that slave let me go
back to my Jenkins master and configure
him to you know talk to an agent so
there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what I'm going to choose is something
called as gnlp Java Network launch
protocol so using this I would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that I need to
ensure that I kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes
agents and by default this jnlp agents
thing would be disabled so if you see
here there's a small help on this
so I'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but Java Network launch protocol
and you know I'll configure the master
and server to talk to each other using
jnlp so for that I need to enable this
guy so I enable this guy instead of
making the by default the configuration
was disabled so I make him random I make
him you know enabled and I say save this
configuration
all right so now configured or I made a
setting for the master so that the jlp
port is kind of opened up so let me go
ahead and you know create an agent
so I go to manage nodes so if you see
here there's only one master here so let
me provision a new node here so this is
the way you know in which you bring up a
new node you have to configure it on the
server and Jenkins would put in some
sort of security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular engine so that he can
connect to a Jenkins master so I would
say new node I would give a name for my
node I would say windows node because
both of these are windows only so that's
fine I just give an identifier saying
that Windows node I would say this is a
permanent agent I would say okay so if
you see the name let me just copy this
name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system I'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since I have both my
my master is running on my C drive C
drive program files 86 or hang on not
86.
C colon program files
it is indeed 86.
all right Jenkins so this is where my
master is running so I don't want the C
drive what I'll do is I'll use something
called as a drive I have another Drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so I create a
folder here called Jenkins node and this
is where I'm going to place my or I'm
going to provision my slave and I'm
going to run it from here so this is the
directory in which I am going to
provision my slave node so I'm going to
copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or sleep so I just copy it here the
label you know probably this is fine for
me
and usage how do you want to use this
guy
so I would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs I will only build jobs
with label Expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them
they're allowed to specify this
particular label so imagine this way if
I have a bunch of Windows my system I
name it as Windows star anything that
says from Windows I can give a regular
expression and say that anything that
matches Windows run this particular task
there if I have some MAC machines I name
all these Mac agents as Mac star or
something like that and I can delegate
all tasks you know saying that start
with whatever starts with Mac in this
node run the Mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there all
right so launch method you know we will
use Java web start because we're going
to
we we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory I think
nothing else is required availability
yes will keep this agent yeah online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right I'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if I click on this node I get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there I need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay I copy this whole
but then I also want to download this
alien.jar I would say yes
this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this sorry
for launching this agent is found this
agent.jar so typically I need to take
this jar file onto the other system
and then kind of run it from there so
I have this 800 jar I copy this or I cut
this I come back to my folder my Jenkins
node I paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and I need to use this whole
command Ctrl a control C and then launch
this particular agent so let me bring up
a command from right here and then
launched it so I'm saying in the same
folder where there is agent.jar I'm
going to launch this a particular agent
Java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp this is
the URL of my server in case the server
and client are on different locations or
different IPS there are specified IP
address all this anyway would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your Jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so something ran and then you know it
says it's connected very well it seems
to have connected very well so let me
come back to my Jenkins instance and see
you know if at all you see earlier this
was not connected alone Let me refresh
this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a Jenkins node and then I
copied all the credentials or the slave
dot jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of ran it from there since I don't
have another system I've just got a
separate directory in another folder
another drive and I'm launching the
agent from here as long as this
particular agent is up and running or
this command prompt is up and running
the agent would be connected so once I
close this the connection goes down
all right so successfully we've launched
this particular agent now this would be
the home directory of this Jenkins node
or the Jenkins slave so any task that
I'm going to delegate to this particular
slave would all be run here it will
create a workspace right here all right
so good so let me just come back and let
me kind of put up a new task here I will
say that you know delegate job is good I
say freestyle project I'm going to
create a very very simple job here
I don't want it kind to get or anything
like that let me just create a very very
simple
Echo
relegated to the
slave negated to I don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am I going to ensure that
this particular job runs on the agent or
on the slave that I've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular sleep we give a label right
so now I am going to put in a job that
will only match this particular label
so I'm going to say that whatever
matches this you know Windows label run
this job on that particular node so we
have only one node that's matching this
you know Windows node so this job will
be delegated around there so I save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this I just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this it ran
successfully and where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
Jenkins node it creates a new workspace
delegate a job it put in here so my old
or the my primary Master job is in SQL
program files under Jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of Master Slave configuration or
distributed built-in Jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our Jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure Hardware crash or a machine
crash we will want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up so one quick way to do
that would be or one dirty way to do
that would be just you know take a
complete backup of our SQL and program
files colon Jenkins directory because
that's where our whole Jenkins
configuration is present but we would
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage and cans
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so I would
recommend one of these plugins that I
specifically use also this is the backup
plugin so let me go ahead and install
this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin so let me come back to my
manage plugins so this plugin is there
so hang on Backup Manager so you will
see this option once you install this
plugin so first time I can you know do a
setup I would say back up this
particular I'll give a folder uh this
folder is pertaining to the folder where
I want to check against backup some data
and I would say the format should be zip
format is good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my you
know backup this is good I want it in
verbose mode I don't want to shut on my
Jenkins or should I shut it down no okay
one thing that you got to remember is
that whenever a backup happens if there
are too many jobs that is running on the
server it can kind of slow down your
Jenkins instance because it's it's in
the process of copying few of those
things and if the files are being
changed at that moment it's a little bit
problematic for Jenkins so typically you
backup your servers only when there is
very less load or typically you try to
you know bring it to a shutdown kind of
a state and then take a backup
all right so I'm going to back up all
these things you know I don't want to
exclude anything else I want the history
I want the artifacts possibly I don't
want this guy I would just say save
and then I would say back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this recording and get back
to you once the backup is complete so
there you go the backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular zip file
so at any instance if at all I kind of
Crash my system for some instance or say
hard disk failure and I bring up a new
instance of Jenkins I can kind of use
the backup plugin for restoring this
particular configurations so how do I do
that I just come back to my managing
canes
come back to backup manager and
obviously restore her son or Jenkins
configuration in this we are going to
talk about the maven here now we will be
talking about that how exactly we can
make use of Maven here in performing
various kind of operations whether it's
a burial compilation with this kind of
stuff there so let's talk about it why
exactly we use Maven here now Maven is
something which is a kind of a build
tool which is there for most of the
job-based projects here so this tool
also helps us in building up the source
code by downloading some couple of
dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that uh the project is dependent on and
he requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a jar based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the day-to-day work of a Java
developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now uh Maven also helps us in
getting the uh specific jar files for
each and every project so if you are
going you can pretty much make a jar
file bar file or your file any kind of a
package mechanism you can follow for
your Maven there so to download the
dependencies we don't have to actually
go to the official website of each and
every software you can easily get it uh
the dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh project over here so it
totally depends on how exactly you want
to download and you want to get together
a specific repository over here so mwin
repository.com is the one if you visit
you will be able to download and go
through all the jar files dependent jar
files as independencies which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is on Maven
all about so let's see on that part so
Maven is a popular open source Belt Tool
which is uh developed by the Apache
group and the primary ownership of this
tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once Maven is
written in Java and it can be used to
build projects written in c-sharp Scala
Ruby Etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is used for build
and management of any kind of a jar
based project it simplifies the
day-to-day work of a Java developer and
helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build perspective tasks
on the projects
right now Maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as in
Project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take care of all the followings here
builds dependencies reports distribution
releases mailing list so all these uh
things are being taken care as in this
particular process here and ultimately
it's in availability inside the maven
that how the overall build process needs
to be automated and standardized here so
all these particular mechanisms is can
be followed as such over here so that we
can have a good standards and the
simplifications implemented as such here
now what exactly is an Maven repository
all about
so Maven repository is something which
uh is uh kind of a directory or it's
kind of a location where we have all the
jar files packaged all together in a
single location so depending on the
software which you want to download the
dependent jar files can be downloaded
from there so the metadata refers to the
pump files relevant to each project here
this metadata is what allows Maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositives from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for our specific Maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right now the local repository will be
primary present onto your PC that's the
way that how it's present there and the
particular remote repository is
something which you can store on any
remote machine or remote server and the
central repository is something which
you can have it on till the internet so
usually the central repositories is
something in which we can actually host
our different kind of dependencies and
the jar files over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from remote repository it's
first downloaded into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and Central repository is refers to the
maven drip Community repository there
where you will be able to see each and
and every dependency present on that
repository so Maven downloads the
repositories from here in the local
repository whenever they're needed or
whenever required all these dependencies
are cached locally from where it will be
referenced in the next or you know
whenever we want to refer that we will
be able to do that particular reference
easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories are Maven
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
Maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in Maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project Palm
reference to the XML file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this XML file in this particular form
reference file as such over here the XML
file is which is there in the project
home directory so Maven is uh something
which search for the pump file in the
current directory if it's able to find
that particular pump file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise the it will hold
there itself so this powerful is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this specific XML file there and
according to that only it will function
or it will proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
jar files so the Java libraries which we
need in our into our particular project
so while working on the project we may
be having the dependency on couple of
dependencies so these dependencies we
have to actually download or we have to
actually refer and once these uh
particular information or these details
are referred so what will happen that uh
we need to download these specific
dependencies from the particular Maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then Maven will try to download it from
the central repository and cache it into
your local repository but first of all
it will look on into the local
repository and if it is not present in
local then only it will go to the remote
or the central Repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goes there so build life cycles
consists of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to performing the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugin cm then we have the build profile
so build profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven's build script
here
then with different build profiles are
added to the pump files and which
enables the different uh build as such
here so depending on these profiles we
can actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here then a build
profile helps in customizing the build
for the different environments so that
also we can perform as such while work
forming or while working on the
different components and the different
management here so a build profile is
something which you can configure you
can utilize and depending on that build
profile we will be deciding whether to
proceed further or how to decide on that
particular Factor so these are something
which we need to take here or we need to
work according to see which we can
decide that how the specific
configurations and specific automation
needs to be performed here
now usually when we go for the uh Maven
there so we have to use some couple of
Maven plugins now the goal of using
these uh specific plugins is to automate
some of the basic stuff like compilation
creating the bar file creating the jar
file so when we are using the plugins we
don't have to configure the steps or
write the steps that how these uh
specific plugins should be installed or
should be referenced it's ultimately the
internal configurations which we are
looking forward or which we are using
while working on these specific plugins
so you can download some couple of
plugins using which we will be able to
decide that how a specific goals needs
to be achieved here so Maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh we don't want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and you
can pretty much have some specific goals
executed with the help of these build
plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in Maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of Maven here so the maven executable
when it's deployed so it usually uh
reads the palm.xml file which is the
build script here now once the specific
download XML file is being read out so
it will process the components it will
uh you know download or it will process
the dependencies plugins life cycles
phases and goals and even the build
profiles and if any kind of interaction
is required so it will try to connect to
the central repository or remote
repository and according to that it will
provide the information and provide the
details as such so mu 1 repository is
something which is very important
because it's ultimately trying to
connect to the maven repository and try
to achieve the various kind of
automation here so it's very important
because ultimately it's trying to help
us to go for the complete end-to-end
build automation when we'll go for a
specific form based build automation
so um even is able to read the palm.xml
file then download the dependencies
defined into the power XML file and that
dependencies are cached locally from the
remote or the central repository now
then create and generate a remote a
report according to the requirement and
execute the life cycles phases goals
plugins
Etc so it will process the power XML
file then and whatever the plugins and
goals or the life cycles which is
configured there step by step each of
them will be executed into a sequence
here
now let's talk about the overall build
life cycle of the maven here so what
happens that uh the maven build
lifecycle is something which is a kind
of a collection of different steps there
and this is something which is followed
uh to perform a build automation for a
specific project so that they are pretty
much three steps which is being done so
first one is the default so it handles
the project deployment there second
handles the project cleaning which is a
clean there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the bevel level which
you can utilize to perform a various
kind of particular steps execution for
your project
right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during these
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific Maven here so that is something
which we need to talk about that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to take
certain benefits out of the
implementation of Maven here so for that
what happens that we have to see that
the various kind of benefits the first
one is that Apache Mi one helps manage
all the processes there such as building
documentation releasing and distribution
in project management here so the tool
simplifies the process of project
building it increases the performance of
the project and the building process all
together and the task of downloading jar
files and other dependencies is also
done automatically we don't have to
indulge in any kind of download part as
such manually over here
right and Maven provides easy access to
all the required information so Maven
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the particular or built onto this
Jenkins or any kind of build tool there
right in Maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the specific palm.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair right so let's talk
about the demo now so let's see that how
exactly we can go for this demo and we
can perform the various kind of
automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so Maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now I'm going to run a particular
command called mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
type
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will download some
of the bientists there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so couple
of a particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
which kind of version we want to follow
so I'm going to follow like five here so
I'll press five
then a group ID which is there so it's
basically a kind of a group mechanism so
I can say like com dot simply learn so
that's a value which I'm providing here
artifact ID I can make it like a sample
project or something like that I can do
so that will be the artifact uh ID which
is there so version I'm keeping the same
only so and uh yeah so package same here
so I just want to create so I'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that our
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact ID you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory so
you have to go into this directory and
see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the pound.xml
file now this palm.xm file when I open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version or group ID
you want to follow so this is a group ID
this is the artifact ID so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the J unit dependencies added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular Maven project a
power.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the Target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of Jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the Target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is the way that how we can actually go
for a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project uh preparation
with the help of mvn executable
so that's it for this demo things right
so that was the demo in which we saw
that how exactly we can go for the maven
and we can execute some build uh process
related to Maven there are you exploring
test automation are you wondering why
everyone is talking about selenium
around you do you want to know what
selenium is all about if yes this is the
video for you all right so let's get
started manual testing a definition if
you can say a manual testing involves
the physical execution of test cases
against various applications and to do
what to detect bugs and errors in your
product it is one of the Primitive
methods of testing a software this was
the only method which we knew of earlier
it is execution of test cases without
using any automation tools it does not
require the knowledge of a testing tool
obviously because everything is done
manually also you can practically test
any application since you are doing a
manual testing so let's take an example
so say we have a use case you are
testing say a a Facebook application and
in Facebook application let's let's open
the Facebook application and say create
an account this is your web page which
is under test now now as a tester what
would you do you would write multiple
test cases to test each of the
functionalities on this page you will
use multiple data sets to test each of
these fields like the first name the
surname mobile number or the new
password and you will also test multiple
links what are the different links on
this page like say forgotten account or
create a new page so these are the
multiple links available on the web
pages also you look at each and every
element of the web page like your radio
buttons like your drop down list apart
from this you would do an accessibility
testing you would do a performance
testing for this page or say a response
time after you say click on the login
button literally you can do any type of
tests manually once you have this test
cases ready what do you do you start
executing this test cases one by one you
will find bugs your developers are going
to fix them and you will need to rerun
all these test cases one by one again
until all the bugs are fixed and your
application is ready to ship now if one
has to run test cases with hundreds of
transactions or the data sets and repeat
them can you imagine the amount of
effort required in that now that brings
us to the first demerit of the manual
testing manual testing is a very time
consuming process and it is very boring
also it is very highly error prone why
because it is done annually and human
mistakes are bound to happen since it's
a manual executions tester's presence is
required all the time one is to keep
doing manual Steps step by step again
all the time he also has to create
manual reports group them format them so
that we get good looking reports also
send this reports manually to all
stakeholders then collection of logs
from various machines where you have run
your test consoliding all of them
creating repositories and maintaining
them and again since it's all is a
manual process there is a High chance of
creating manual errors there scope of
manual testing is limited for example
let's say regression testing ideally you
would want to run all the test cases
which you have written but since it's a
manual process you would not have the
luxury of time to execute all of them
and hence you will pick and choose your
test cases to execute that way you're
limiting the scope of testing also
working with large amount of data
manually is Impractical which could be
the need of your application what about
performance testing you want to collect
metrics on various performance measures
as a part of your performance testing
you want to simulate multiple loads on
application under test and hence
manually performing these kind of test
is not feasible and to top it all up say
if you are working in an agile model
where code is being churned out by
developers testers are building their
test and they are executing them as and
when the bills are available for testing
and this happens iteratively and hence
you will need to run this test multiple
times during your development cycle and
doing the this manually definitely
becomes very tedious and burning and is
this the effective way of doing it not
at all so what do we do we automate it
so this tells us why we automate one for
faster execution two to be less error
prone and three the main reason is to
help frequent execution of our test so
there are many tools available in the
market today for automation one such
tool is selenium birth of selenium much
before selenium there were various tools
in the market like say rft and qtp just
to name a few popular ones selenium was
introduced by gentleman called Jason
Huggins way back in 2004. he was an
engineer at thoughtworks and he was
working on a web application which
needed frequent testing he realized the
inefficiency in manually testing this
web application repeatedly so what he
did was he wrote a JavaScript program
that automatically controlled the
browser actions and he named it as
JavaScript test run later he made this
open source and this was renamed as the
selenium Coke and this is how selenium
came into existence and since then
selenium has become one of the most
powerful tool for testing web
applications so how does selenium help
so we saw all the demerits of manual
testing so we can say by automation of
test cases one selenium helps in Speedy
execution of test cases since manual
execution is avoided the results are
more accurate No human errors since your
test cases are automated Human Resources
require to execute automated test cases
is far less than manual testing because
of that there is a lesser investment in
human resources it saves time and you
know time is money it's cost effective
as selenium is an open source it is
available free of cost early time to
Market since you save effort and time on
manual execution your clients will be
merrier as you would be able to ship
your product pretty fast lastly since
your test cases are automated you can
rerun them any point of time and as many
times as required so if this tool offers
so many benefits we definitely want to
know more detail about what selenium is
selenium enables us to test web
applications on all kind of browsers
like Internet Explorer Chrome Firefox
Safari Edge Opera and even the Headless
browser selenium is an open source and
it is platform independent the biggest
reason why people are preferring this
tool is because it is free of cost and
the qtp and the rft which we talked
about are chargeable selenium is a set
of tools and libraries to facilitate the
automation of web application as I said
it is not a single tool it has multiple
components which we'll be seeing in
detail in some time and all these tools
together help us test the web
application you can run selenium scripts
on any platform it is platform
independent why because it is primarily
developed in JavaScript it's very common
for manual testers not to have in-depth
programming knowledge
so selenium has this record and replay
back tool called the selenium ID which
can be used to create a set of actions
as a script and you can replay the
script tag however this is mainly used
for demo purposes only because selenium
is such a powerful tool that you should
be able to take full advantage of all
its features selenium provides support
for different programming languages like
Java python c-sharp Ruby so you can
write your test scripts in any language
you like one need not know in-depth or
Advanced knowledge of these languages
also selenium supports different
operating systems it has suppose for
Windows Macs Linux even Ubuntu as well
so you can run your selenium test on any
platform of your choice and hence
selenium is the most popular and widely
used automation tools for automating
your web applications selenium set of
tools so let's go a little more deeper
into selenium as I said selenium is not
a single tool it is a suite of tools so
let's look at some of the major
components or the tools in selenium and
what they have to offer so selenium has
four major components one selenium ID
it's the most simplest tool in the suite
of selenium it is integrated development
environment earlier selenium IDE was
available only as a Firefox plugin and
it offered a simple record and Playback
functionality it is a very simple to use
tool but it's mainly used for
prototyping and not used for creating
Automation in the real-time projects
because it has its own limitations like
any other record and replay tool
selenium RC this is nothing but selenium
remote control it is used to write web
application test in different
programming language what it does it
basically interacts with the browser
with the help of something called as RC
server and how it interacts is its uses
a simple HTTP post get request for
communication this was also called as
selenium 1.0 version but it got
deprecated in selenium m2.0 version and
was completely removed in 3.0 and it was
replaced by Webdriver and we will see in
detail as why this happened selenium
Webdriver this is the most important
component in the selenium Suite it is a
programming interface to create and
execute text test cases it is obviously
the successor of the selenium RC which
we talked about because of certain
drawbacks which RC hat so what Webdriver
does is it interacts with the browsers
directly unlike RC where the RC required
a server to interact with the browser
and the last component is the selenium
grid so selenium grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time so it helps
you in achieving parallel execution
since the selenium Webdriver with you
can only do sequential execution grid is
what comes into picture where you can do
your parallel execution and wise
parallel execution important because in
real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in a
distributed environment and that is what
grid helps you to achieve so all this
together helps us to create robust web
application test Automation and we will
go in detail about each of these
components so before that let's look at
the history of selenium version so what
did selenium version comprised of it had
an IDE RC and grid and as I said earlier
there were some disadvantages of using
RC so RC was on its path of deprecation
and Webdriver was taking its path so if
you look at selenium 2 version it had an
earlier version of Webdriver and also
the RC so they coexisted from tree dot
onwards RC was completely remote and
Webdriver took its place there is also a
four dot version around the corner and
it has more features and enhancements
some some of the features which are
talked about are w3c Webdriver
standardization improved ID and improved
grid now let's look at each of the
components in the selenium Suite
selenium IDE is the most simplest tool
in the suite of selenium it is nothing
but an integrated development
environment for creating your automation
scripts it has a record and Playback
functionality and it's a very simple and
easy to use tool it is available as a
Firefox plugin and a Chrome extension so
you can use either of this browser to
record your test scripts it's a very
simple user interface using which you
can create your scripts that interact
with your browser the commands created
in the scripts are called selenis
commands and they can be exported to the
supported programming language and hence
this code can be reused however this is
mainly used for prototyping and not used
for creating automation for your
real-time projects why because of its
own limitation which any other recorded
replay tool has so a bit history of
selenium ID so earlier selenium ID was
only a Firefox extension so we saw that
IDE was available since the selenium
version one selenium ID died with the
Firefox version 55 that was ID versus
stopped supporting from 55 version
onwards and this was around 2017 time
frame however very recently all new
brand selenium ID has been launched by
apply tools and also they have made it a
cross browser so you can install the
extension on Chrome as well as as an
add-on on Firefox browser so they
completely revamped this IDE code and
now they have made it available on the
GitHub under the Apache 2.0 license and
for the demos today we'll be looking at
the new ID now with this new ID also
comes a good amount of features
reusability of test cases better
debugger and most importantly it
supports parallel test case execution so
they have introduced a utility called
selenium side Runner that allows you to
run your test cases on any browser so
you can create your automation using IDC
on Chrome or Firefox but through command
prompt using your site Runner you can
execute these test cases on any browser
thus by achieving your cross browser
testing control flow statement so
initially in the previous versions of
idea there were control flow statements
available however one had to install a
plugin to use them but now it is made
available out of box and what are these
control flow statements these are
nothing but your if else conditions the
while Loops the switch cases so on it
also has an improved locator
functionality that means it provides a
failover mechanism for locating elements
on your web page so let's look at how
this ID looks and how do we install it
and start working on that so for that
let me take you to my browser so say
let's go to the Firefox browser so on
this browser I already have the ID
installed so when you already have an ID
installed you will see an icon here
which says selenium ID and how do you
install this you simply need to go to
your Firefox add-ons here whether it
says find more extension so just type in
selenium ID and search for this
extension so in the search results you
see this selenium ID just click on that
and now since I've already installed
here it says remove otherwise for you it
is going to give you an add button here
just click on the add button it will
install this extension once it is
installed you should be able to see this
selenium ID icon here okay so now let's
go ahead and launch this ID so when I
click on that it is going to show me a
welcome page where it's going to give me
few options the first option is itself
record a new test case in a new project
so straight away if you choose this
option you can start recording a test
case in which case it's going to just
create a default project for you which
you can save it later then open an
existing project so you can open if you
already have a saved project create a
new project and close so I already have
an existing project with me for the demo
purpose so I'll go ahead and open that
so I'll say open existing project and I
have created a simple script what the
script does is it logs me into the
Facebook using a dummy user mail sorry
username and password that's all it's
very simple script with few lines and
this is what it is going to do so what
we will simply do is we'll just run the
script and see how it works for that I'm
just going to reduce the test execution
speed so that you should be able to see
every step of execution here all right
so what I'll do now here is I'll just
adjust this window and I'll just simply
say run current test all right so I'll
just get this side by side so that you
should be able to see what exactly the
script is doing okay so now you are able
to see both the windows okay so now it's
going to type in your user email here
there you go and now it will enter the
password and it has clicked on the login
button so it's going to take a while to
say login and since these are the dummy
IDs it is you are not able to log in
here and you are going to see this error
window fine that is what is the expected
output here now on the ID if you look
here after I execute the test case every
statement or every command which I have
used here is color recorded in green so
that means this particular step was
executed successfully and then here in
the log window it will give you a
complete log of this test case right
from the first step till the end and
your end result is it says FB login
which is my test case name completed
successful let's look at few components
of this ID the first one is the menu bar
so let's go to our ID all right so the
menu bar is right here on the top so
here is your project name so either you
can add a new project here or rename
your project so since we already have
this project which is named as Facebook
and then on the right you have options
to create a new project open an existing
project or save the current project and
then comes on toolbar so using the
options in this toolbar you can control
the execution of your test cases so
first one here is the recording button
so this is what you use when you start
recording your script and then on the
left you have two options here to run
your test cases the first one is run all
tests so in case you have multiple test
cases written here you can execute them
one by one sequentially by using this
run all test else what you can do is if
you just want to run your current test
this is what you would use then ID has
this debugger option which you can use
to do a step execution so say for
example now whenever I run the script
it's going to execute each and every
command here sequentially so instead if
I just select the first command and say
do step execution all right so what it
does is the moment it finishes the First
Command which is opening of Facebook
right I think which is already done here
yeah all right so once this is done it
is going to wait immediately on the
second command and it says paused
debugger so from here you can do
whatever you would like to do in case
you want to change the command here you
can do that you can pause your execution
you can resume your execution here right
you can even completely stop your test
execution or you can just select this to
run the rest of the test case so if you
say run the test case what it is going
going to do is just going to Simply go
ahead and complete the com complete the
test case now there is another option
here which is you see the timer there
which says test execution speed so to
execute your test cases in the speed you
want say whenever you're developing an
automation script right and say you want
to give a demo so you need to control
the speed sometimes so that the viewer
is able to exactly see all the steps
which is being performed and this gives
you an option to control that complete
execution right so do you see the
grading here so we have somewhere from
Fast to completely slow execution so the
previous demo which I showed was I
control the speed and then I executed it
so that we could see every command how
it has been executed all right so what's
the next this is called as an address
bar so whichever Wherever Whenever you
enter an URL here that is where you want
to conduct your test and another thing
what it does is it keeps a history of
all the URLs which I've used for running
your test then here is where your script
is recorded So each and every in
instruction is displayed here in the
order in which you have recorded the
script and then if you look here you
have something called as login reference
so now log is an area where it records
each and every step of your command as
in when they get executed right so if
you see here it says open https
facebook.com and ok so that means this
command was executed successfully and
after the complete test case is done it
gives you whether the test case passed
or filled so in case there is a failure
you'll immediately see this test case is
filled in red color also there is
something called as reference here for
example say if I click on any of this
command the reference tab what it is
going to show me is the details of this
command which I have used in the script
it gives you the details of the command
as well as what the arguments have been
used or how how is that you need to be
using this particular command okay so
now what we'll do is let's go ahead and
write a simple script using this ID so
with this you'll get an ideas how do we
actually record scripts and ID so for
that I have a use case here a very very
simple use case so what we will do is we
will open amazon.in then we'll search
simply search for say a product iPhone
and once we get that search page where
all your iPhones are displayed we will
just do an assert on the title of the
page simple all right so let's do that
so first thing what I need is an URL
okay so first let me go to my Firefox
browser here and say amazon.in so why
I'm doing this just to Simply get the
right URL absolute URL path here and so
that I don't make any mistakes while
typing in the URL okay so I got this so
let me close all this windows I don't
need any of this let's minimize this all
right so here what I will do in the
tests tab I'll say add a new test and
name this test as Amazon search done
I'll say add now I'll enter this URL
which I just copied it from my browser
okay and then I'll just say start
recording so what it did was since I
have entered the URL in this address box
it just open the amazon.in URL now let's
do the test case so in my test case what
I said was I want to search for iPhone
once I have this I'm just going to click
on my search button so now this gives me
a list of all iPhones and then I said I
want to add an assertion on the title of
this page so for me to do that what id
gives me an option is I have to just
right click anywhere on this page and
you'll see the selenium ID options here
so in this I will select a cert title
and then I will close this browser so
that kind of completes my test case so
now take a look at all the steps which
is created for me so it says open slash
because I've already provided the URL
here so either you can replace it with
your regular URL or you can just leave
it as it is so what I will do is since
this is going to be a proper script and
I might be using this to run it from a
command prompt also so I'll just replace
this target with the actual URL and then
what it is doing it is setting a window
size then there are whatever I did on
that particular URL on that website it
has recorded all the steps for me so
this is where it says type into this
particular text box which is my search
box and what did it type iPhone this was
the value which I entered now there was
one more feature which I told you in
this new ID which had which I said it
has a failover mechanism for your
locating techniques now that is what
this is now if you look here this ID is
equal to two tab search textbook this is
nothing but the search box where we
entered the text iPhone and it has
certain identification through which
this IDE identifies that web element and
that has multiple options to select that
particular search box so right now what
it has used is ID is equal to two tab
search box however if you know the
different locating techniques you will
be able to see here that it has other
techniques also which it has identified
like the name and the CSS and the XPath
so how does this help in failovers say
tomorrow if Amazon dot in website
changes the ID of this element right you
are not going to come and rewrite the
scripts again instead by using the same
script what it will do is if this
particular ID fails if it is on unable
to find the element using the first
locator which is the ID it simply moves
to the next available ones and and it
tries to search for that element until
one of this becomes true that is what
was the failure mechanism which has got
added it's a very brilliant feature
because most of our test cases break
because of element location techniques
well let's come back to this so then we
added an assert title right so what is
Assad Title Here it simply captures the
title of that particular page and it
checks this is all a very simple test
case so what we will do now is we will
stop the recording and then I've also
given a closed browser so right now what
I will do is I'll just comment this out
why because if I just run this test case
it's going to be very fast and you might
not be able to catch the exact command
execution what has happened all right so
right now I'll just disable it so that
it will just do all these test cases and
it just stays there without closing the
browser so now I'll just say run the
current test so your Amazon in is
launched okay it is typed in the iPhone
it's also clicked on the search so it is
done so now if you look here since we
are in the reference tab it is not able
to show so let's go to the log and now
let's see the log so it's going to be a
running log so if you notice here the
previous examples which we have run for
Facebook is also in the same lock so we
all have to see the log from running
Amazon search because that's our test
case so if you see here every command
line right it was executed successfully
assert title was also done and your test
case was executed successfully so it
passed now what we will do is on this
assert title I'll just modify this and
let's say just add some text I'll just
add double s here now this by
intentionally I am going to fail this
test case just to show you that whenever
there is a test case failure how does
the ID behaves and how do you get to
know the failures all right so I'll just
run the test test case again so before
that let's close the previous window all
right done and now here I'll also
uncomment the close because anyway it's
a failure which I I am going to see
which I should be able to see it in the
logs so I'll close the browser after the
execution of test case okay so let's
simply go and run the test case Okay
amazon.in is launched it should search
for iPhone now yeah there you go all
right now it should also close the
browser yes it has closed the browser
and it has failed now see here now this
is the line where our Command fit why
because the expected title was not there
and if you look in the logs it says your
assert title on amazon.in failed actual
result was something different and it
did not match with what we had asked it
for so this is how simple it is to use
your ID to create your automation
scripts so we saw all the components of
ID we saw the record button then I
showed you the toolbar I showed you the
editor box and also the test execution
log so now let's come to what are the
limitations of this ID with IDE you
cannot export your scripts your test
scripts to web driver scripts this
support is not yet added but it is in
The Works Data driven testing like using
your Excel files or reading data from
the CSV files and passing it to the
script this capability is still not
available also you cannot connect to
database for reading your test data or
perform any kind of database testing
with selenium Webdriver yes you can also
unlike selenium Webdriver you do not
have a good reporting mechanism with the
ID like say for example test NG or
report entry so that brings us to the
next component of The Suite which is
selenium RC selenium remote control so
selenium RC was developed by Paul
Hammond he refactored the code which was
developed by Json and was credited with
Json as a co-creator of selenium
selenium server is written in Java it is
used to write web application test in
different programming languages as it
supports multiple programming languages
like your Java C sharp Perl Python and
Ruby it interacts with a browser with
the help of an RC server so this RFC
server uses a simple HTTP get and post
request for communication and as I said
earlier also Selena MRC was called as
selenium 1.2 overshill but it got
deprecated in selenium 2.0 and was
completely removed in 3.0 and it got
replaced by what Webdriver and we'll see
why this happened and what was that
issue which we had with the RC server so
this is the architecture of selenium
remote control at a very high level so
when Jason Huggins introduced selenium
you know the tool was called as
JavaScript program and then that was
also called as a selenium core so every
HTML has a JavaScript statements which
are executed by web browser and there is
a JavaScript engine which helps in
executing this command now this RC had
one major issue now what was that issue
say for example you have a test script
say test dot JavaScript here which you
are trying to access a limits from
anywhere from the google.com domain so
what used to happen is every element
which is accessible are the elements
which can belong only to google.com
domain like say for example mail the
search or the drive so any elements from
this can be accessible through your test
scripts however nothing outside the
domain of say google.com in this case
was accessible say for example if your
test scripts wanted to access something
from yahoo.com this was not possible and
this is due to the security reasons
obviously now to overcome that the
testers what they had to do was they had
to install the selenium core and the web
server which contained your web
application which is under test on the
same machine and imagine if you have to
do this for every machine which is under
test this is not going to be feasible or
even effective all the time and this
issue is called as a same origin policy
now what the same origin policy issue
says is it prohibits a JavaScript from
accessing elements or interacting with
scripts from my domain different from
where it is launched and this is purely
for the security measure so if you have
written a scripts which can access your
google.com or anything related to
google.com these scripts cannot not
access any elements outside the domain
like as we said in the example yahoo.com
this was the same origin policy now to
overcome this what this gentleman did
was he created something called as
selenium remote control server to trick
the browser in believing that your
course your selenium core and your web
application under test are from the same
domain and this is what was the selenium
remote control so if you look at again a
high level architecture or how did this
actually work first you write your test
scripts which is here right in any of
the supported language like your PHP or
your Java or Python and before we start
testing we need to launch this RC server
which is a separate application so this
selenium server is responsible for
receiving the selenis commands and these
selenis commands are the ones which you
have written in your script it
interprets them and reports the result
back to your test so all that is done to
your RC server the browser interaction
which happens through RC server right
from here to your browser so this
happens through a simple HTTP post and
get request and that is how your RC
server and your browser communicate and
how exactly this communication happens
this RC server it acts like a proxy so
say your test scripts asked to launch a
browser so what happens is this commands
goes to your server and then your RC
server launches the browser it injects
the JavaScript into the browser once
this is done all the subsequent calls
from your test script right from your
test scripts to your browser goes
through your RC and now upon upon
receiving these instruction your
selenium core executes this actual
commands as JavaScript commands on the
browser and then the test results are
displayed back from your browser to your
RC to your test scripts so the same
cycle gets repeated right until the
complete test case execution is over so
for every command what you write in your
JavaScript here or your test script here
goes through a complete cycle of going
through the RC server to the browser
collecting the results again from the RC
server back to your test scripts so this
cycle gets repeated for every command
until your complete test execution is
done so RC had definitely a lot of
shortcomings and what are those so RC
server needs to be installed before
running any test scripts which we just
saw so that was an additional setup
since it acts as a mediator between your
commands which is your Cellini's
commands and your browser the
architecture of RC is complicated why
because of its intermediate RC server
which is required to communicate with
the browser the execution of commands
takes very long it is slower we know why
because every command in this takes a
full trip from the test script to your
RC server to the core engine to the
browser and then back to the same route
which makes your overall test execution
very slow lastly the AP is supported by
RC are very redundant and confusing so
RC does have a good number of APs
however it is less object oriented so
they are redundant and Confused say for
example say if you want to write into a
text box how and when to use a type key
command or just a type command is always
confusing another example is some of the
mouse commas using a click or a mouse
door both kind of you know almost
providing a similar functionality so
that is the kind of confusion which
developers use to create hence
selenium RC got deprecated and is no
more available in later selenium
versions it is obsolete now now to
overcome these shortfalls web driver was
introduced so while RC was introduced in
2004 web driver was introduced by Simon
Stewart in 2006. It's a class platform
testing platform so Webdriver can run on
any platform like say Linux Windows Mac
or even if you have a Ubuntu machine you
can run your selenium scripts on this
machine it is a programming interface to
run test cases it is not an ID and how
does this work actually so test cases
are created and executed using web
elements or objects using the object
locator and the web driver methods so
when I do a demo you will understand
what this Webdriver methods are and how
do we locate the web elements on the web
page it does not require a core engine
like RC so it is pretty fast why because
web driver interacts directly with the
browser and it does not have that
intermediate server like the RC hat so
each browser in this case what happens
is each browser has its own driver on
which the application runs and this
driver is responsible to make the
browser understand the commands which
you will be passing from the script like
say for example click of a button or you
want to enter some text so through your
script you tell which browser you want
to work with say Chrome and then the
Chrome driver is responsible for
interpreting your instructions and to
execute it on the web application
launched on the Chrome browser so like
RC Webdriver also supports multiple
programming languages in which you can
write your test Scripts
so another advantage of web driver is it
supports various Frameworks like test NG
junit and unit and Report entry so when
we talk about the limitations of
Webdriver you will appreciate how this
support for various Frameworks and tools
help in making the selenium a complete
automation solution for web application
so let's look at the architecture of
Webdriver at a high level what is in
Webdriver so web driver consists of four
major components the first one is we
have got client libraries right or what
we also call it as language bindings
so since selenium supports multiple
language and you are free to use any of
the supported languages to create your
automation script these libraries are
made available on your selenium website
which you need to download and then
write your scripts accordingly so let's
go and see from where do we download
this so if I go to my browser
so
seleniumhq.org right so if you're
working with selenium this website is
your Bible so anything and everything
you need to know about selenium right
you need to come here and use all the
stabs here in this website so right now
what we are going to look at is what are
those language binding so for that I'll
have to go to this download tab here
okay and if you scroll down here you
will see something like selenium client
and web driver language bindings and for
each of the supported language of
selenium you have a download link
right so say for example if you're
working with Java here what you need to
do is you need to download your Java
language finding so let's go back to the
presentation so this is where your
language bindings are available next so
selenium provides lots of apis for us to
interact with the browser and when we do
the demo I'll be showing you some of
this APS right and these are nothing but
the rest apis and everything whatever we
do through the script happens through
the rest course then we have a Json wire
protocol what is Json JavaScript object
notation it is nothing but a standard
for exchanging data over the web so for
example you want to say launch a web
application through your script
so what selenium does it it creates a
Json payload and posts the request to
the browser driver that is here and then
we have this browser drivers themselves
and as I said there is a specific driver
for each browser
as you know every tool has its own
limitation so does selenium so let's
look at what these limitations are and
if there are any workarounds for them
cannot test mobile applications requires
framework like APM
selenium is for automating web
application it cannot handle mobile
applications mobile applications are
little different and they need its own
set of automation tool however what
selenium provides is a support for
integrating this APM tool which is
nothing but a mobile application
automation tool and using APM and
selenium you can still achieve mobile
application automation
and when do you usually need this when
your application under test is also
supported on mobile devices you would
want a mechanism to run the same test
cases on web browser as well as your
mobile process right so this is how you
achieve it the next limitation so when
we talked about the components of
selenium I said that with Webdriver we
can achieve only sequential execution
however in real time scenario we cannot
just live with this we need to have a
mechanism to run our test cases
parallelly on multiple machines as well
as on multiple browsers so though this
is a limitation of web driver but what
selenium offers is something called as
grid which helps us achieve this and we
will see in shortly what the selenium
grid is all about also if you want to
know more details as how do we work with
the grid how do you want to install that
grid so do check out our video on simply
learn website on selenium grid third
limitations so limited reporting
capability so selenium Webdriver has a
limited reporting capability it can
create basic reports but what we
definitely need is a more
so it does support some tools like say
test engine report NG and even extend
reports which you can integrate with
selenium and generate beautiful reports
powerful isn't it also there are other
challenges with selenium like selenium
is not very good with image testing
especially for the ones which are
designed for web application automation
but then we have other tools which can
be used along with selenium like autoit
and securely so if you look at all this
selenium still provides a complete
solution for your automation needs and
that's the beauty of selenium and that
is why it makes the most popular tool of
today for automation
okay let's do a quick comparison between
the selenium RC and the web driver
so RC has a very complex architecture
you know why because of the additional
RC server whereas due to direct
interaction with the browser web driver
architecture is pretty simple execution
speed
it is slower in RC and much faster in
Webdriver why because in Webdriver we
have eliminated that complete layer of
selenium server write that the RC server
and we established a direct
communication with the browser through
browser drivers it requires an RC server
to interact with the browsers we just
talked about it and whereas Webdriver
can directly interact with the browser
so RC again we talked about this as one
of the limitations that we have lot of
redundant ABS which kept developers
guessing as which API to use for what
functionality however Webdriver offers
pretty clean apis to work with
asay did not offer any support for
headless browser whereas in Webdriver
you do have a support for using headless
browsers
let's see the web driver in action now
now for the demo we will use this
particular use case and what this use
case says is navigate to the official
simply learn website then type the
selenium in search bar and click on it
and click on the selenium 3.0 training
so we are basically searching for
selenium 3.0 training on the simply
learn website first let's do the steps
manually and then we will go ahead and
write the automation script so let's go
to my browser on my browser what I'll do
is let me first launch the simply learn
website
okay and here what my use case step says
is I need to search for selenium and
click on the search button so once I do
that it is going to give me a complete
list of all kind of selenium trainings
which is available with simpler and what
I'm interested in is the selenium 3.0
training here once I find this on the
web page I need to go and click on that
all right so this is all the steps which
we are going to perform in this use case
okay now so for writing the test cases
I'll be using an ID which is Eclipse
I've already installed my eclipse and
also I have installed selenium in this
instance of my Eclipse all right so if
you can see the reference library folder
here you will see all the jars which are
required for the selenium to work next
another prereq which is required for
selenium and that is your driver files
now every browser which you want to work
with has its own driver file to execute
your selenium scripts and since for this
demo I'll be working with the Firefox
browser I will need a driver file for
Firefox now driver file for Firefox is
the gecko driver which I have already
downloaded and placed in my folder
called drivers now where did I download
this from let's go ahead and see that so
if I go back to my browser and if you go
to your selenium HQ dot website you have
to go to this download tab here in the
download tab when you scroll down you
will see something like third party
drivers bindings and plugins in this
you'll see the list of all the browsers
which is supported by selenium and
against each of this browser you will
find a link which has the driver files
now since we'll be using the gecko
driver
this is the link where you need to go to
and depending on which operating system
which you're working on you need to
download that particular file now since
I am working on Mac this is the file
which I'm using if you are a Windows
user you need to download this ZIP file
and unzip it so once you unzip that you
would
get a file called gecko driver for your
Firefox or a chrome driver for your
Chrome browser and then what you do is
you just create a directory called
drivers under your project and just
place the driver files here so these are
the two prereqs for your selenium one is
importing your jar files like this and
then having your drivers downloaded and
keep them under a folder where you can
reference to okay so now we'll go ahead
and create a class I already have a
package created in this project so I'll
use this project and create a new class
so I'll say create new Java class and
let's call this as
search training I'll be using a public
static wordman and I'll click on finish
so let's remove this Auto generated
lines as we do not need them all right
now the first statement which you need
to write before even you start writing
the rest of your code is what you need
to do is you need to define or declare
your driver variable using your class
web driver so what I would do is I'll
say Webdriver
driver
done all right now you will see that
this ID is going to flash some errors
for you that means it is going to ask
you to import certain libraries which is
required by the web driver so simply
just go ahead and say import Webdriver
from org dot opensq.cellaneous this is
the package which we will need all right
so you have a driver created which is of
the class web driver and now after this
I'm going to create three methods all
right so first method I will have for
launching the Firefox browser okay and
then I will write a simple method for
searching selenium training and clicking
on it this is the actual use case what
we'll be doing and then third method I'm
going to write is just to close the
browser which I'm going to be opening
right so these are the different methods
which I'll be creating and from the
public static wordman I will just call
these methods one after the other okay
so let's go ahead and write the first
method now my first method is launching
the Firefox browser so I'll say public
void since my return type is null or
there is no return type for this let's
call it as launch browser okay all right
now in this for launching any browser I
need to mention two steps now the first
step is where I need to do a system.set
property okay let's do that first and
then I'll explain what this does I'll
just say system dot set property so this
accepts a key and a value pair so what
is my key here my key here is Webdriver
dot gecko dot driver and I need to
provide a value so value is nothing but
the path to the gecko driver and we know
that this gecko driver which I'm going
to use here is right here in the same
project path under the drivers folder
correct and that is what the path which
I'm going to provide here so here simply
I need to say drivers slash gecko driver
gec KO all right done and let me close
this sentence all right now since I'm a
Mac User my gecko driver installable is
just the name gecko driver if your
windows user user and if you are running
your selenium scripts on the Windows
machine you need to provide a complete
path to this including dot exe because
driver executable on your machines is
going to be gecko driver.exe all right
so just make sure that your path which
you mentioned here in the system.set
property is the correct path okay then
the next thing what we need to do is I
need to just say driver is equal to new
Firefox driver okay so this command new
Firefox driver creates an instance of
the Firefox browser now this is also
flagging me error why because again it's
going to ask me to import the packages
where the Firefox driver class is
present okay we did that now these two
lines are responsible for launching the
Firefox browser form so this is done so
what's my next step in the use case now
I need to launch the website simply
learn so for that we have a command
called driver dot get driver dot get
what it does is whatever URL you're
going to give it here in this double
quotes as an argument it is going to
launch that particular website and for
us it's a simply learned website so what
I do as a best practices instead of
typing out the URL I go to my browser
launch that URL which I want to test and
I simply copy it come back to your
eclipse and just simply paste it so this
ensures that I do not make any mistakes
in the URL okay so done so our first
method is ready where we are launching
the browser which is our Firefox browser
and then launching the simply learn
website now the next method what is my
next method in my next method I need to
give the search string to search
selenium training on this particular
website now for that we need to do few
things what are those few things let's
go to the website again all right so let
me relaunch this let's close this okay
let me remove all this and let's go to
the home page first okay this is my home
page so as you saw when I did a manual
testing of this I entered the text here
so now since I have to write a script
for this first I need to identify what
this element is for that what I am going
to do is I'm just going to say right
click here and I'll say inspect element
all right now this element let's see
what attribute it has which I can use
for finding this element so I I see that
there is an ID present so what I'm going
to do is I'm just going to Simply use
this ID and then I'll just copy this ID
from here go back to Eclipse let's write
a method first so I'll say public void
and what do we give the method name say
search training or just search all right
now in this I need to use a command
called driver dot find element by ID is
what I'm going to use as a locating
technique and in double quotes the ID
which I copied from the website is what
I'm going to paste here okay and then
what am I going to do on this element is
I need to send that text the text which
I'm going to search for which is
selenium so I'll just say send keys and
whatever text I want to send I need to
give it in double quotes So for that
selenium so this is done so now I've
entered the text here and after entering
the text I need to click on this button
so for that I need to first know what
that button is so let's inspect that
search button okay now if you look at
the search button other than the tag
which is span and the class name I do
not have anything here all right so what
I can do is I can either use the class
name or I can write an X path since this
is a demo which we have already used ID
locating technique I would go ahead and
use the X path here so for me to
construct an X path I will copy this
class first okay and then I already have
a crow path installed on my Firefox so
I'll use the crow path and first test my
X bar so I'll just say double slash
let's see what was that element it has a
span tag okay so I'll have to use pan
and at class equal to and I'll just copy
the class name here and let's see if it
can identify that element yeah so it is
able to identify so I'll just use this x
path in my code so I'll go back to
Eclipse I'll say driver dot find element
by dot X path and the X path which I
just copied from cropath is what I'm
going to paste here and what is the
action I need to do here I need to say
click done so I have reached a stage
where I have entered this selenium okay
and then I have clicked on the search
button once I do this I know that
expected result is I should be able to
find this particular link here selenium
3.0 training okay and I should be able
to click on that so for that again I
need to inspect this so let's inspect
this selenium 3.2 all right so now what
are the elements this has now this
particular element has attributes like
it has a tag H2 then it has got some
class name and some other attributes so
I would again would like to use a x path
here now this time while using the X
path I am going to make use of a text
functionality so that I can search for
this particular text so I'll simply copy
this I'll go to my Crow path the tag is
H2 so I'll say simply H2 okay and here
I'll say text equal to and this is the
text which I copied I missed all that
yes there so I'm just going to add an S
okay so let's first test here whether it
is able to identify that element yeah so
it is able to identify so can you see
your blue dotted line it is able to show
us which element it is identified so
I'll copy this x path now and let's go
to my ID Eclipse so now here what I need
to do is I'll have to again simply say
driver dot find element by dot X path
and paste the X path which we just did
and then again I have to do a click
operation done all right so technically
we have taken all the steps of the use
case and we have written the commands
for that now let's add an additional
thing here say after coming to this page
after finding this we want to uh say
print the title of this page now what is
the title of this page if you just hover
your mouse on this it says online and
classroom training for professional
certification courses simply now so what
I will do is after doing all these
operations I will just print out this
page title on our console so for that I
have to just do this try fiber dot so
let's do a sys out so I'll say sys out
system.out.println okay and here I would
say let's add a text here the page title
is and then let's append it with driver
dot get title so this is the command
which we'll be using to fetch the page
title done now what is the last method I
need to add just to close the browser
all right so let me add a method here
I'll say public void close browser and
it's a one single command which I need
to call I'll say driver dot quit Okay
and then I need to call all these
methods from my public static void main
so I let me use my class name which is
this so I'm going to create an object
obj is equal to new class name and then
using this object first is I need to
call the method launch browser and then
I'll call the method search right and
then I'll call the method close browser
that so technically our script is is
ready with all the functionality which
we wanted to cover from our use case now
there are few other tweaks which I need
to do this and I'll tell you why I need
to do this now for example after we
click here right after we click on the
search if you observed on your website
it took a little while before it listed
out all the selenium trainings for us
and usually when you are actually doing
it you wait for the selenium 3.0
training to be available and then you
click on that now same thing you also
need to tell your scripts to do that you
need to tell your scripts to wait for a
while until you start seeing the
selenium 3.0 training or it appears on
your web page there are multiple ways to
do that in your script and it is a part
of overall synchronization what we call
where we use kind of implicit and
explicit kind of events now since this
is a demo for demo purpose what I'm
going to do is I am going to use a
command curve thread.sleep and I'm just
going to give an explicit weight of say
three seconds so you can use this Main
really for the demo purposes you can use
a thread.sleep command now this
thread.sleep commands needs us to handle
some exceptions so I'm just going to
click on ADD throws declaration and say
interrupted exception now same thing
I'll have to do it in my main function
also okay so let's do that and complete
it all right so this is done so by doing
this what am I doing I'm ensuring that
before I click on the selenium 3.
training we are giving enough time for
the script to wait until the web page
shows this link to the selenium 3.0
training that's one thing I'm doing all
right and also now since you are going
to be seeing this demo through the video
recording the script when it starts
running it is going to be very fast so
you might just miss out saying how it
does the send keys and how did it click
on the search button for us to enable us
to see it properly I'll just add some
explicit weights here just for a demo
purpose so after entering the keys right
so what I'll do is I'll just give a
simple thread.sleep here now
okay so probably a three seconds or two
seconds which should be good enough okay
at three seconds weight should be good
enough here so that we should be able to
see how exactly this works on your
browser when we execute this okay now
our complete script is ready so what
I'll do is I'll just save the script and
then we will simply run the script so to
run the script I just say right click
run as Java application okay it says ask
me to select and save I have saved the
script now so let's observe how it runs
okay the simply learn.com the website is
launched so the selenium text has been
entered in the search box it has clicked
on the search okay all right so now it
did everything whatever we wanted it to
do all right so since we are closing the
browser you are unable to see whether
the selenium three dot training was
selected or not however what I have
given here is to fetch the title after
all these operations were complete and
if you see here the complete operations
was done and and we were able to see the
page title here okay so now what we'll
do since we are unable to see whether it
clicked on the selenium 3. training or
not I'll just comment out the closed
browser the command okay so we will not
call the close browser so that the
browser remains open and we get to see
whether did it really find the training
link or not okay so let me close this
window we don't need this Firefox window
close all tabs and then I'll just
re-execute the script so I'll say run as
Java application so save the file okay
simplylearn.com is launched so search
text is entered now it's going to click
on the search button yes all right so
we've got the search results it should
click on selenium 3.0 training and yes
it is successfully able to click on that
all right so now it's not going to close
the browser because we have commented on
that line however it did print us the
title here all right so this is a simple
way of using the selenium Scripts
selenium grid so grid is used to run
multiple test scripts on multiple
machines at the same time with Webdriver
you can only do sequential execution but
in real time environment you always have
the need to run test cases in
distributed environment and that is
where selenium grid comes into picture
so grid was conceptualized and developed
by Patrick the main objective is to
minimize test execution type and how by
running your test parallely so design is
in such a way that commands are
distributed on multiple machines where
you want to run tests and all these are
executed simultaneously what do you
achieve by this methodology of course
the parallel execution on different
browsers and operating system grid is
pretty flexible and can integrate with
many tools like say you want a reporting
tool integrated to pull all the reports
from the multiple machines where you're
running your test cases and you want to
present that report in a good looking
format so you have an option to
integrate such report okay so how does
this grid work so grid has as a hub and
node concept which helps in achieving
the parallel execution let's take an
example say your application supports
all browsers and most of the operating
system like as in this picture you could
say one of them is a Windows machine one
of them is a Mac machine and another one
is say a Linux machine so your
requirement is to run the test on all
supported browsers and operating systems
like the one which is depicted in this
picture so what you have to do is first
thing is you configure a Master machine
or what you also call it as a hub by
running something called a selenium
Standalone server and this Talent
Standalone server can be downloaded from
the selenium HQ website using the server
you create a hub configuration that is
this node and then you create nodes
specific to your machine requirement and
how are these nodes created you again
use the same server which is your
Standalone selenium server to create the
node configuration so I'll show you
where the selenium server can be
downloaded so if we go back to our
selenium HQ website so you can see here
right on the top it says selenium
Standalone server and this is the latest
version available so you just need to
download once you download this keep a
version of this one on your master
machine that is your Hub and this should
also be present on your node machines
and there is a certain command which you
can use to install the server as a node
and as a master depending on your
configuration so once that is done you
have your master and your master or the
Hub and the notes created your master
can control on which nodes you want to
execute test now say if this is a Mac
machine this is a Windows machine
through your master or your Hub you
control on which machine you want to
execute what tests then also you could
have a multiple combination of tests
like say for example smoke test to be
run on all these nodes that's the kind
of configuration you can create or a
certain component and test to be run on
say only Windows 10 with an edge browser
or say regression test on Mac machine so
any such things whatever configurations
you have for your node what happens is
the Hub picks the right node which
confirms to your requirements or the
configurations which you have set up and
then sends a command to the node to
execute those test cases on the Node
everything is controlled through your
master machine only here what happens on
the Node so once the node gets the
command from the master the node
actually runs all the test cases which
is it which it intends to run on the
specific browser which you have
mentioned in your configuration file so
this is a very high level architecture
and how a grid works so if you want to
know more details of how the grid works
you can refer to our video on simply
learn all right again limitations so
what limitation does is grid have now
the first one is it has relatively poor
scalability compared to many modern
applications it is pretty static each
server is configured in advance with a
subset of required browser instances
available so if you want to vary this
you'll need to reconfigure so any
configuration tomorrow on any machines
you want to change it cannot be done
automatically you need to completely
reconfigure that node and then add it
back to the grid thirdly although it is
available to run on Virtual servers it
is actually not designed as a cloud
native application and because of as a
result of this it isn't optimized to
take advantage of things like say
distributed storage or dynamic scaling
or even automatic failover so these are
some of the limitations of the grid
advantages of selenium speed and
accuracy of course since there is no
manual execution your test can run
faster and with grid it helps in
parallel execution and you can run or
execute large volumes of test within a
very short time frame let's take an
example say before just before the
release of your product say during the
last lap of your testing you find a bug
and of course it has to be fixed so the
developer fixes the bug and you want to
run all the test cases pertaining to
that area now can you imagine that if
you have to do this testing manually how
long it's going to take so by automation
you can achieve this in a very short
duration of time and it will also help
you release your product in time with
very minimal or absolutely no human
errors the second Advantage it's an open
source so it's available free of cost so
anyone can download it and start using
it it supports wide spectrum of
programming languages we have been
seeing throughout this presentation it
is not restricted to any particular
programming language so whatever
language you are comfortable with you
have an option to use that and write
your selenium scripts selenium has
support for almost all browsers and
operating system we also talked about
headless browser support So this helps
you create test cases once using any of
the browser and run them across all
browsers and all operating system thus
saving you lot of time from manual
execution and helping in achieving a
very broad test coverage and we also saw
that pretty easy to use tool right so
you can check out all our videos and you
can it's just a matter of time that you
can Master the skill of writing your
automation scripts reusability of course
like any programming language it
provides you a mechanism to reuse your
code and avoid redundancy well again
let's see an overall what are the
limitations of selenium itself now since
selenium is open source that is one of
the biggest Advantage now there is a
little disadvantage which comes with
that and what is that you do not have
much technical support because it's an
open source code however there are loads
and loads of documentations and forums
available which you can definitely refer
to and selenium as we said it is only
for automating web applications it
cannot handle the mobile applications or
even the desktop application however it
does provide support for integrating
tools like APM for mobile testing
selenium is not very good with image
testing especially designed for your web
application tools again we have tools
like autoit and securely which can be
integrated with selenium selenium web
driver has limited a limited reporting
capability but again it does provide us
support for integrating tools like test
NG report NG and extend report it does
not have test management capabilities it
need not right not one tool need not
have each and everything what is
required but there is always a way to
integrate it so selenium does provide a
way to integrate any of the test
management tools now since selenium
supports multiple programming language
the developer of test automation will
require to have some basic knowledge of
any of the programming language it
supports to write effective automation
scripts right so this you could look at
it as an advantage or as a disadvantage
so overall if you look at all this right
selenium still provides a complete
solution for our automation need and
that is why we can still say that
selenium is one of the most popular tool
used in the industry today for your web
application automation what Docker is
and how you could be using it within
your own devops environment so let's get
started so let's first we'll compare
Docker with a traditional virtual
machine so here we have the architecture
on the left and right of a traditional
Virtual Machine versus a Docker
environment and there are some things
that you'll probably see immediately
that are big differences one is that the
virtual environment has hypervisor layer
whereas the docker environment has a
Docker engine layer and then in addition
to that there are additional layers
within the virtual machine each of these
really start compounding and creating
very significant differences between a
Docker environment and a virtual machine
environment so with a virtual machine
the actual memory usage is very high
whereas with the docker environment the
memory usage is very low if we look at
performance virtual machines when you
start building out particularly more
than one virtual machine on a server the
performance starts degrading and starts
getting poorer whereas with Docker the
performance always stays really good
this is largely due to the lightweight
architecture used to construct the
docker containers themselves if we look
at portability virtual machines just are
terrible for portability they're still
dependent on the host operating system
and there's just a lot of problems that
happen when you are using virtual
machines for portability in contrast
Docker was designed for portability so
you can actually build Solutions in a
Docker container environment and have
the guarantee that the solution will
work as you have built it no matter
where it's hosted finally boot up time
the bit up time for a virtual machine is
fairly slow in comparison to the boot up
time for a Docker environment which is
almost instantaneous so we look at these
in a little bit more detail one of the
other challenges that you have with a
virtual machine is that if you have
unused memory within the environment you
cannot reallocate that memory so if you
set up an environment that has nine gigs
of memory that's being used we have six
gigs that are free you can't do anything
with it though that whole nine gig has
been allocated to that virtual machine
in contrast with Docker if you have nine
gigs and six gigs becomes free that free
memory can then be reallocated and
reused across other containers used
within that Docker environment another
challenge is running multiple virtual
machines in a single environment I can
lead to instability and performance
issues whereas Docker is designed to run
multiple containers in the same
environment and actually gets better the
more containers you run in that hosted
single Docker engine portability issues
with a virtual machine is the software
can work on one machine but then when
you move that VM to another machine
suddenly some some of the software won't
work because there are some dependencies
that haven't been inherited correctly
whereas Docker itself is designed
specifically to be able to run across
multiple environments and to be deployed
very easily across systems and again the
actual boot up time for a VM it just
takes a long time you're talking about
minutes in contrast to the milliseconds
that it takes for a Docker environment
to boot up so let's dig into what Docker
actually is and what allows for these
great performance improvements over a
traditional VM environment so Docker
itself is an OS virtualized software
platform and it allows it organizations
to really easily create deploy and run
applications as what are called Docker
containers that have all the
dependencies within that container very
easily and the container itself is
really just a very lightweight package
that has all the instructions and
dependencies such as Frameworks Library
these bins Etc all within that container
and that container itself can then be
moved from environment to environment
very easily if we to look in our devops
life cycle the place where Docker really
shines is in deployment because when
you're actually at the point of
deploying Your solution you want to be
able to guarantee that the code that has
been tested will actually work in the
production environment but in addition
to that what we often find is that when
you're actually building the code and
you're actually testing the code having
a container running the solution at
those stages is also a really good plus
because what happens is that the people
building the code and testing the code
are able to validate their work in the
same environment that would be used for
the production environment so really you
can use Docker in multiple stages within
your devops cycle but it becomes really
valuable in the deployment stage so
let's look at some of the key advances
that you have with Docker some things
that we've already covered is that you
can do rapid deployments and you can do
it really fast the environment itself is
highly portable and was designed for
that in mind the efficiencies that
you'll see will allow you to run
multiple Docker containers in a single
environment as compared to more
traditional VM environments the
configuration itself can be scripted
through a language called yaml which
allows you to be able to write out and
describe the docker environment that you
want to create this in turn allows you
to be able to scale your environment
very very quickly but with all of these
advantages probably the one that is most
critical to the type of work that we're
doing today is security you have to
ensure that the environment you are
running is a highly secure but highly
scalable environment and I'm very
pleased to say that Docker takes
security very seriously so you'll see it
as one of the key tenants for the actual
architecture of the system that you're
implementing so let's look at how Docker
actually were Works within your
environment so Docker works out there is
a what's called a Docker engine the
docker engine is really comprised of two
key elements that you have a server and
a client and the communication via the
two is via rest API the server as you
can imagine has the instructions that
are communicated out to the client and
instructs the client on what to do the
connection between the client and the
server the communication is via a rest
API on older systems you can take
advantage of the docker toolbox which
allows you to go ahead and control the
docker engine the docker machine Docker
compose and kitimatic so let's now go
into what the actual root components
though of Docker are so let's have a
look at those key components there are
four components that we're going to go
through we have the docker clients and
server we have Docker images we have the
docker registry and the docker container
we're going to step through each of
these one by one so let's look at the
soccer clients and server first so the
docker clients and server is a command
line instructed solution where you would
use terminal on your Mac or command line
on your PC or Linux system to be able to
issue commands from the docker Daemon
the communication between the docker
client and the docker host and is via a
rest API so you can do Sim communication
such as a Docker pool command which
would send an instruction to the Daemon
which would then form the interaction of
pulling in the correct components such
as an image or container or registry to
the docker client the docker Daemon
itself is actually a service which
actually performs all sorts of operating
and Performance Services and as you'd
imagine the docker Daemon is constantly
listing across the rest API to see if it
needs to perform any specific requests
if you want to trigger and start the
whole process you what you want to do is
use the command dockered within your
Docker Daemon and that will start start
all of your performances and then you
have a Docker host which actually runs
the docker Damon and registry itself so
now let's look into the actual structure
of a Docker image so a Docker image
itself is a template which contains
instructions for the docker container
and that template is written with a
language called yaml and yaml stands for
yet another markup language it's very
easy to learn the docker image itself is
built within that yaml file and then
host it as a file in the docket registry
the image is really comprised of several
key layers and you start with your base
layer which will typically have your
base image in this instance is your base
operating system such as Ubuntu and then
you then have layer of dependencies
above that this would then comprise the
instructions in a read-only file that
would become your Docker file so as you
go through and look at what one of those
sets of instructions would look like so
here we have four layers of instructions
we have a from pull run and then command
so what does that actually look like in
our layers so to break this down the
from creates a layer which is based on
Ubuntu and then what we're doing is
we're adding in files from the docker
repository onto that base command that
base layer and then what we want to be
able to do is then say okay what are the
wrong commands so we can actually then
build the container within the
environment and then we want to be able
to then have a command line that
actually executes something within that
container and in this instance the
command is to run python so one of the
things that we will see is that as we
set up multiple containers each new
container is a new layer with new images
within the docker environment each
container is completely separate from
the other containers within your doc
environment so you're able to create
your own separate read write
instructions within each layer what's
interesting is that if you delete a
layer then the layer above it will also
get deleted so what happens when you
pull in a layer but something has
changed in the the core image what's
interesting then is that the actual main
image of itself cannot be modified once
you've copied the image you can then
modify it locally but you can never
modify the actual base image itself so
here are some callouts for the
components within a Docker image so the
base layer are in read-only format the
layers can be combined in a union file
system to create a single image the
union file system saves memory space by
avoiding duplication of files and this
allows a file system to appear as a
writable but without modifying the file
which is known as a copy on right the
actual base layers themselves are read
only so to be able to get around this
structure within a Docker contain the
docker's environment itself uses what's
known as a copy and write strategy
within the images and the containers
themselves and so what this allows you
to do is you can actually copy the files
for better efficiency across your entire
container environment the copyright
strategy does make Docker super
efficient and what you're able to do all
the time is keep reducing the amount of
disk space you're using and the amount
of performance that you're taking from
the server and that's really again a key
element for Docker it's just this
constant ability to be able to keep
improving the efficiency within the
actual system itself alright so let's go
on to item number three which is the
docker registry so the docker registry
itself is the place where you would host
and distribute the different types of
images that you have created or you want
to be used within your environment the
actual repository itself is just a
collection of Docker images and those
Docker images are built on instructions
that you would write with yaml and are
very easily stored and shared and what
you can actually do is you can actually
associate specific name tags to the
actual Docker images themselves so it's
easy for people to be able to find and
share that image within the docker
registry itself one of the things you
actually see is we go through the demos
you actually see us actually using the
the tag name and you'll see how it is an
alphanumeric identifying how we actually
use it to actually create the actual
container itself one of the things you
can do to as start off how you would
manage a registry is you can actually
use the publicly accessible Docker Hub
registry which is available to anybody
but you can also create your own
registry for your own use internally the
actual registry that you create
internally can have both public and
private images that you create and this
may be for various reasons of how you'd
structure your environment the actual
commands you would use to actually
connect to the registry are both push
and pull push is to actually push a new
container environment that you've
created from your local manager node to
the remote registry and a pool allows
you to pull a new client that has been
created and has been shared so again
pull command and it pulls and retrieves
a Docker image from the docker registry
and makes it very easy for people to
share different images consistently
across teams and a push command allows
you to take a new command that you've
created a new container that you've
created and push it to the registry
whether it's Docker Hub or whether it's
your own private registry and allow it
to be shared across your teams some key
did you knows in Docker registry
deleting a repository is not a
reversible action so if you delete a
repository it's gone so let's go into
the final stage here which is the actual
Docker container itself so the docker
container itself
um is an executable package of
applications and its dependencies
bundled together so it gives all the
instructions that you would have for the
solution that you're looking to run it's
actually really lightweight and again
this is because of the redundancy that's
built into how you structure the
container and the container itself is
then inherently also extremely portable
what's really good about running a
container though is that it does run
completely in isolation so you're able
to share it very easily from group to
group and you are guaranteed that even
if you are running a container it's not
going to be impacted by any host Os
peculiarities or unique setups as you
would have in a VM or a
non-containerized environment the actual
memory that you have on a Docker
environment they can be shared across
multiple containers which is really
useful typically when you have a vamp
you would have a defined amount of
memory for each VM environment the
challenge you start running into though
is that you can't share that memory
whereas with Docker you can easily share
the memory for a single environment
across multiple containers the actual
container is built using Docker images
and the commands to actually run those
images is a run command so this can
actually go through a basic structure of
how you would run a Docker image so you
go into terminal window and you would
write a Docker run redis and then it
would run a container called redis so
we're going to go in and if you don't
have the redis image locally installed
it will then pull it from the registry
then the new Docker container redis will
be then available within your
environment so you can actually start
using it so let's look at why containers
are so light lightweight they're so
lightweight because they really have
been able to get away from some of the
additional layers that you have in
virtualization within VMS and the
biggest one is the hypervisor and the
need to run on a host operating system
those are two big big elements so you
can get rid of those then you're doing
great so let's look at some of the more
advanced advanced concepts within the
docker environment and we're going to
look at two Advanced components one is
Docker compose and the second is Docker
swarm so let's look at Docker compose
Docker compose is really designed for
running multiple containers as a single
service and it does this by running each
containing isolation but allowing the
containers to interact with each other
as was stated earlier on you would
actually write the compose environment
using yaml as the language in the files
that you would create so where would you
use something like Docker compose so an
example would be if you are running an
Apache server with my SQL database and
you need to create a additional
containers to run additional services
without the need to start each one
separately and this is where you would
write a set of files using Docker
compose to be able to help balance out
that demand so let's now look at Docker
swarm so Docker swarm is a service that
allows you to be able to control
multiple Docker environments within a
single platform so what you actually are
looking at doing is within your Docker
swarm is we're treating each node as a
Docker Daemon and we're actually having
an API that's interacting with each of
those nodes there are two types of notes
that you're going to be getting
comfortable working with one is the
manager node and the second is the
worker node and as you'd expect the
manager node is the one sending out the
instructions to all of the worker nodes
but there is a two-way communication
that is happening the communication
allows for the manager node to be able
to manage the instructions and then
listen to and receive updates from the
working node so if anything happens
within this environment the major node
can react and adjust the architecture of
the worker node so it's always in sync
it was really great for a large scaled
environments so finally let's go through
what are some of the basic commands
you'd with use within Docker and once
we've gone through all these basic
commands we'll actually show you a demo
of how you'd actually use them as well
so if we're going to go in probably the
first command is to install the docker
and so if you have yam installed you
just do yum install Docker and you'll
install docker onto your computer to
start the docker Damon as you want to do
systemctl start Docker the command to
remove a Docker image is Docker RMI and
then the image ID itself and that's not
the image name that's the actual
alphanumeric ID number that you want to
grab the command line to download a new
image is Docker pull and then the name
of the image you'd want to pull and by
default you're going to be pulling from
the docker default registry that will
then connect to your Docker demon and
download the images from that registry
calendar the command line to run an
image is Docker run and then the image
ID and then we have the if we wanted to
pull specifically from Docker Hub then
we would have a Docker pull and then the
image name and colon It's tag to pull
build an image from a Docker file you
would do Docker build Dash T and then
the image name and colon tag to shut
down the container you do dogger stop
container ID the access for running a
container is Docker exec it container ID
bash so we've gone through all the
different commands but let's actually
see how they would actually look and
we're going to go ahead and do a demo so
welcome to this demo where we're going
to go ahead and put together all of the
different commands that we have outlined
in the presentation for Docker first is
just to list all of the docker images
that we have so we do pseudo Docker
images and we enter in our password
and this will Now list out the images
that we've created already and we have
three images there
so let's go ahead and pull a Docker
image so to do that we'll we'll go ahead
and type sudo docker
and actually we don't want to do image
we want to select pull and then the name
of the image that we want to pull which
is going to be MySQL
and by default this is actually going to
go ahead and use the latest MySQL
command MySQL image that we have so it's
now going to head and pull this image
it's going to take a few minutes
depending on your internet connection
speed it's kind of a large file that has
to be downloaded so we'll just wait for
that to download
you'll see the others have completed
just waiting for this last file to
download almost there once that's done
we're going to go ahead and do is we'll
actually run the docking container and
create a new container using the image
that we just downloaded but we have to
wait for this to download First
all right so the image has been pulled
from Docker hub
and let's go ahead and create the new
Docker container so we're going to do
sudo docker
run Dash D
Ash p
0.0.0.0
[Music]
colon 80
colon 80.
and then put in MySQL
call on latest so we have the latest
version
and we have our new token
and that shows our new Docker container
has been created
now let's go ahead and see if the
container is running
and we'll do sudo docker
PS
to list all the running containers and
what we see is that the container is not
listed there which means it's probably
not running so let's go ahead and list
out all of the images that we have
within Docker so we can see whether it's
actually listed there so we'll do PS
Dash a and yes there we are we can see
that we do have our new container my SQL
latest and it was created 36 seconds ago
but it's in the exited mode so what we
have to do is we have to change that
status so it's actually running
so let's change that to running state
we'll do sudo
docker
run
Dash
it
Dash Dash
name
and we can name it
SL
ql
MySQL
slash spin slash
Dash
and that's now going to be in the root
and we'll exit out of that and now if we
list out the docking containers we
should see it is now an active container
pseudo docker
start
and then we'll just start the scene and
then
and we should now see it
there we are it's now in the running
State excellent
and we can see that it was updated six
seconds ago
we're going to go ahead and go ahead and
clear the screen
okay now what we want to do is remove
the docker container so we're going to
do is checklist of images that we have
and so sudo Docker images
here are the images that we have and we
have my sqls listed and what we want to
do is delete my SQL and to do that we're
going to type in sudo Docker RM Dash F
image MySQL
foreign
and what we'll find is
the image now there's no such image oh
okay so what we actually have to do is
we have to go and see that the image is
now gone it's been removed excellent
that's exactly what we wanted to see
and we can also delete an image by its
image ID as well
however if an image is running and
active we have to kill that image first
so I'm going to go ahead and we're going
to select the image ID we'll copy that
and it's going to
replace that it won't be able to
actually run correctly because the image
is active so what we have to do now is
stop the image and then we can kill it
so it's in the running state
so we have to
so we do sudo Docker kill
and kill SL and then we'll kill the
container
and now we'll see that the container has
gone
and now we can delete the image
and that's going to be the image gone
with image ID but boom easy peasy
okay let's go ahead on to the next
exercise which is to
oh good so here we are we've listed all
of the uh containers and they're all
gone so let's go into the next exercise
final exercise which is to actually
create a batch image and we're going to
do a batch HTTP image so let's go ahead
and write that out so it's going to be
Docker run
Dash did
dash dash name
white which is that's going to be the
name of this HTTP service Dash p
ad 8080 colon 80 Dash V
open quotes
dollar sign PWD
close quotes
colon slash USR slash local
slash
apache2 slash htdogs
httpd semicolon 2.4
let me run that
open in our password again
uh so what we see is the port is already
being used so let's go ahead and see
which ports let's go see if we can
change the port or see what supports are
running so let's do sudo images and see
which ports are being used because so
the the port or the name hasn't been put
in correctly so pseudo Docker images
PS
pseudo docker PS Dash a
and yep that's Port 80 there
to clear the screen
so we're going to change the container
name because I think we actually have
the wrong container name here so let's
go and change that and we'll paste that
in and voila there we go
now working and we'll just double check
and make sure everything's working
correctly so to do that we'll go into
our web browser and we'll type in as
soon as Firefox opens up
type in localhost
colon 8080
which was the the port that we created
and there we are it's a list of all the
files which shows that the server is up
and running
this is Anjali from Simply learn and
today we'll dive into a tutorial on the
configuration management tool Chef so if
you look at the devops approach or the
devops life cycle you will see that Chef
falls under operations and deployment
why should we use Chef well consider a
large company now this company caters to
a large number of clients and provides a
number of services or Solutions of
course to get all of this done they need
a huge number of servers and a huge
number of systems basically they will
have a huge infrastructure now this
infrastructure needs to be continuously
configured and maintained in fact when
you're dealing with an infrastructure
that size there's a good chance systems
may be failing and in the long run as
your company expands new systems may
even get added so what do you do well
you could say the company has the best
system administrator out there but all
by himself could he possibly take care
of an infrastructure that size no he
can't and that's where Chef comes in
because Chef or automates this entire
process so what does Chef provide Chef
provides continuous deployment so when
you look at the market space today you
see how products and their updates are
coming out in a matter of days so it's
very important that a company is able to
deploy the product the minute it's ready
so that once it's out it's not already
obsolete Chef also provides increased
system robustness as we saw shift can
automate the infrastructure but in spite
of this automation there's a good
possibility that errors do creep in Chef
can detect all these bugs and remove
them before deploying them into the Real
Environment not only this Chef also
adapts to the cloud we all know how
today the services tools Solutions
everything is revolving around the cloud
so Chef does really play along by making
itself easily integratable with the
cloud platform so now that you know why
to use Chef let's look at what exactly
is chef chef is an open source tool
developed by Ops Code of course there
are paid versions of Chef such as Chef
Enterprise but other than that most of
it is freely accessible Chef is written
in Ruby and erlang if you would have
gone through any previous material on
Chef I'm sure you would have come across
Ruby being related to chef but not
erlang so this is why because Ruby and
erlang are both used to build chef but
when it comes to actually writing the
codes in Chef it's just Ruby and these
are the codes that's deployed onto your
multiple servers and does the automatic
configuration and maintenance and this
is why Chef is a configuration
management tool so I've used this term
configuration management a couple of
times what exactly does this mean let's
start with the definition of
configuration management configuration
management is a collection of
engineering practices that provides a
systematic way to manage entities for
efficient deployment so let's break this
down configuration management basically
is a collection of practices and what
are these practices for these practices
are for managing your entities the
entities which are required for
efficient deployment so what are these
entities that you need for efficient
deployment they are code infrastructure
and people code is basically the core
the system administrators right for
configuring your various systems
infrastructure is the collection of your
systems and your servers and then
finally you have the teams that take
care of this infrastructure so codes
need to be updated whenever your
infrastructure needs a new configuration
or some sort of updation in the
operating system or the software
versions your code needs to be updated
at first and as the requirements of the
company change the infrastructures
configuration needs to change and
finally of course the people need
coordination so if you have a team of
system administrators and say person a
makes some change to the code person B C
D and so on need to be well aware when
the change is made as as to why it was
made what was the change made and where
exactly this change was made so there
are two types of configuration
Management on our left we have the push
configuration here the server that holds
the files with instructions to configure
your notes pushes these files onto the
loan so the complete control lies with
the server on your right side we have
the pull configuration in case of pull
configuration the nodes pull against the
server to first check if there's any
change in the configurations required if
there is the nodes themselves pull these
configuration files Chef follows pull
configuration and how it does this we'll
see further in our video another
important term often used with Chef
infrastructure as code so let's
understand what this term infrastructure
as code means through this small story
so here's dim dims system administrator
at a large company now he receives a
task he has to set up a server and he
has to install 20 software applications
over it so he begins he sets up the
server but then it hits him it would
take him the entire night to install 20
software applications wouldn't things
have been much simpler if he just had a
code to do so well of course codes do
make things much simpler codes have a
number of advantages they're easily
modifiable so if today Tim is told we
need Maya skill installed on 20 systems
Tim simply writes a code to do so and
the very next daytime is told we changed
our mind we don't need Maya skill I
think we'll just use Oracle this does
not bothered him because now he just
opens the file he makes a few
Corrections in his code and that should
work just fine code is also testable so
if Tim had to write 10 commands to do
something and at his 10th command he
realized the very first command he wrote
there was something not right there well
that would be quite tiresome wouldn't it
with codes however you can test tested
even before running it and all the bugs
can be caught and corrected codes are
also Deployable so they're easily
Deployable and they're Deployable
multiple times so now that we saw the
various advantages of having codes let's
say in what infrastructure as code
exactly is here's the definition
infrastructure as code is a type of ID
infrastructure where the operation team
manages the code rather than a manual
procedure so infrastructure as a code
allows the operations team to take care
of a code which automatically performs
various procedures rather than having to
manually do those procedures so with
this feature all your policies and your
configurations are written as code let's
now look at the various components of
Chef so our first component is the
workstation the workstation is the
system where the system administrator
sits he or she creates the codes for
configuring your nodes now these codes
which in case of Chef are written in
Ruby are called the recipes and you'll
have multiple number of recipes so a
collection of recipes is called a
cookbook now these cookbooks are only
created at the workstation but they need
to be stored at the server so the knife
is a command line tool so it's basically
a command that you will see us executing
in one of our demos that shifts these
cookbooks from the workstation over to
the server a second component is the
server so servers like the middleman it
lies between your workstation and your
notes and this is where all your
cookbooks are stored because as you saw
previously the knife sends these
cookbooks over from the workstation to
the server the server can be hosted
locally that's on your workstation
itself or it can be remote so you can
have your server at a different location
you can even have it on the cloud
platform and a final confidence the node
so nodes are the systems that require
the configuration in a chef architecture
you can have a number of nodes or high
is a service which is installed on your
node and it is responsible for
collecting all the information regarding
your current state of the node this
information is then sent over to the
server to be compared against the
configuration files and check if any new
configuration is required shift client
is another such service on your node
which is responsible for all the
communications with the server so
whenever the node has a demand for a
recipe the shift client is responsible
for communicating this demand to the
server since you have a number of nodes
in a chef architecture it's not
necessary that each node is identical so
of course every node can have a
different configuration let's now have a
look at the chef architecture so here we
have a workstation one server machine
and two nodes you can have any number of
nodes first things first the system
administrator must create a recipe so
the recipes that are mentioned in our
Chef architecture are just dummy recipes
we look into actual functioning recipes
later in our demo so you have one recipe
two recipes three recipes and a
collection of recipes forms a cookbook
so guys if you look at the recipe in
sauce you have simply learned three dot
Erb Erb is the extension for your Ruby
files so the cookbooks are only created
at the workstation they now need to be
sent over to the server where they are
stored and this is the task of the knife
knife is a command line tool which is
responsible for transferring all your
cookbooks onto the server from the
workstation here's the command for
running your knife knife upload simply
Dash DB where simply Dash DB is the name
of the cookbook we then move on to our
node machines at our nodes we run the
Ojai service the Ojai service will
collect all information regarding the
current state of your notes and send it
over to the shift light when you run the
chef client these informations are sent
over to the server and they are tested
against the cookbooks so if there is any
discrepancy between the current state of
your nodes and the cookbook that is if
one of the notes does not match the
configurations required The cookbook is
then fetched from the server and
executed at the node this sets the node
to the right State there are various
flavors of Chef we'll quickly go through
these first we have Chef solo with Chef
solo there's no separate server so your
cookbooks are located on the Node itself
now this kind of configuration is used
only when you have just a single node to
take care of the next flavor is a hosted
chef with hosted Chef you still have
your workstation and your node but your
server is now used as a service on the
cloud this really makes things simple
because you don't have to set up a
server yourself and it still performs
all the functioning of a typical Chef
this is the configuration you will
notice that we'll be using in our demo
shift line server with shift line server
you have a workstation you have server
and you have and number of nodes now
this is the traditional Chef
architecture this is the one we have
used for all the explanations previously
and finally we have private Chef private
Chef is also known as Enterprise Chef in
this case your workstation server and
node all are located within the
Enterprise infrastructure this is the
main difference between Chef client
server and private Chef in case of Chef
client server all these three machines
could be dispersed the Enterprise
version of Chef also provides the
Liberty to add extra layers of security
and other features and we reach the
final part of our video where we'll have
the Hands-On so before we dive into our
demo let me just quickly give you an
introduction to it we'll be using two
virtual boxes both sent to S7 one will
be used as workstation while the other
will be a node so we are just using one
node to make things simple the server
will be used as a service on the cloud
now these are the steps we'll be
performing during our demo we'll first
download and install the chef DK on our
workstation we then make an empty
cookbook file and we'll write a recipe
into it we need to then set up the
server so as I mentioned earlier server
will be a service on the cloud so you'll
have to create a profile but this will
be completely free we then link the
workstation to the server and we'll
upload the recipe to the server the
nodes will now download the cookbooks
from the server and configure themselves
so now that you have some idea about
what we'll be doing let's move on to the
actual demo We Begin our demo here's my
Oracle VM virtualbox manager I have two
machines here I have already created my
workstation and node both of these are
sent to S7 machines just for you to
differentiate this is my terminal and
for my workstation it's a black
background with white text and as of my
node it's a black background with green
text
the first thing you do is you go to your
workstation box and open a web browser
search for Chef DK installation
go to the first link which is your
Chef's official page and under Red Hat
Enterprise because our systems a red hat
system select the link of the version
that you are using so I'm using Centos 7
so my operating system version is 7 so
I'll take this link now this is the link
for downloading your Chef DK you copy
this link and go to your terminal guys
notice I'm in the home directory of my
root user so let's install our Chef DK
and it's getting installed now this will
take some time because it's quite a
large file
and Chef DK's downloaded next step we
need to install it
and this is the version of the chef TK
that we have downloaded
so type the same
okay so that's done so now we need to
make our recipes and the recipes will
exist within cookbooks so first let's
make a chef repository So within that
we'll have a folder for holding all our
cookbooks and within our cookbook we'll
write our recipe so we start with the
directory for Chef Repository
[Music]
move into it
create a folder called cookbooks within
which we'll store each of our cookbooks
move into this folder
okay so we'll just check the contents
here right now so we have our Chef DK we
have a chef repo folder here and let's
check the contents of the chef repo
and this has cookbooks okay so our first
cookbook that we'll be making will be
under this folder cookbooks so let's
move into cookbooks
we are in now we need to create our
first cookbook so the instruction for
creating your first cookbook is Chef
generate
cookbook and the name of your cookbook
so I'm just giving the name a sample
yeah so our cookbook sample is created
now when you create your cookbook you'll
notice that a hierarchy is also
automatically created so let's just
check the hierarchy of our cookbook
let's move into sample
and Chi is the command for checking the
hierarchy so here as you can see we have
recipes and under recipes we have
default dot RB so we'll be editing this
default.rb to create a recipe okay so
let's begin with that let's move into
our recipes folder
and open your default.rb
and here we are so now we'll type in our
code
so what's our recipe for a recipe is for
installing the httpd package on our node
and then we'll also create a small index
file where we'll just have a simple
content such as welcome or something
like that just to check if our httpd is
working fine so let's begin typing the
code here package httpd
service
httpd
do and what must be done with this
package is that once it's installed it
needs to be enabled and it needs to be
started
and so that's our first task our next
task
is creating our HTML file
so as you know all your HTML files will
follow this path name
and this is the content of your file
you have successfully
configured
your note
and that's it that's a simple code
so our recipe is now ready save it and
exit back to your terminal now what we
need to do is that we need to configure
our server so go to your browser
on the search engine type manage dot
Chef dot IO
so as I mentioned earlier we'll be using
a server as a service on the cloud
so you'll enter your login page for the
chef server most of you may not have a
profile already so you go to click here
to get started and fill in the details
it's just like creating an account on
Facebook so I already have my account
I've put in the credentials here I'll
just sign in now the first thing once
you sign in is you'll get an option to
create an organization so all you have
to do there is you gotta enter the name
of your organization and just below that
there's another box for entering a short
form of your organization now my
organization name was simply learn and
the short form was slp123 so when you
come to the administration tabs under
organization you can see this
organization name Next Step click on
this arrow and you got to download your
starter kit okay so once you click on
down start a kit you will come to this
page where there's a button for download
starter kit
so do download it
save the file
so now come back to your terminal
so you come back to your terminal and
next what you need to do is you need to
unzip your shift starter.zip so for that
first we'll move our Chef starter to the
root so it's currently present under the
downloads folder let's move it
so we have moved our chefstarter.zip now
let's unzip it
first let's just check
the contents of our root directory right
now so we have our Chef Repository
Chef repo fi uh folder that we created
the chef starter zip that we just moved
and of course the chef DK so now we can
unzip our Chef starter kit
and that's done so our next step we
gotta move the chefstarters dot zip file
into our cookbooks which lies inside the
chef repository this is done because
we'll be executing our further commands
to connect our workstation with the
server from the cookbooks because that
is where our sample cookbook is and
that's moved so now we'll run a knife
command so what knife does is that it
uploads your recipes or your cookbooks
onto the server so here's the command
for running your knife
samples the name of the cookbook that
you're uploading and uploading sample
0.1.0 and uploading sample yeah so our
cookbook is uploaded now let's just
check this at our server how we do that
is go back to your browser where you
have open your server
so there's no node here yet
because we have not configured a node
with the server but we have configured
our workstation with the server and you
see here our cookbooks uploaded sample
so a workstation and a server are
connected so now we need to connect our
node with the server so first we move on
to unknown machine
we need to take the IP address of our
node machine
so for the IP address we'll just type
ifconfig
[Music]
right so this is your IP address
192.168.2.190 note this down somewhere
guys
now that's done
go back to your workstation
I'll just keep it this way so I can see
both okay go back to your workstations
terminal
but this time to connect our server with
the node so we have taken the IP of our
node and this is where we'll be using it
192.168.2 point the username which is
Root in our case
and then enter the password
and then finally you enter your node
name
so this is the name that will appear for
this particular node on our server I'm
just giving it Chef node you can give it
whatever you like we'll just check the
command knife bootstrap the IP address
SSH user our user which is root SSH
password the password for the root and
finally the node name
and the nodes getting created
so once the node is connected to your
server we'll go back to our browser open
our server service on the cloud and
we'll check the node tab so ideally your
node name should appear there
great so our node is added also if you
notice here our Chef client service on
the Node has started running so let's
just check this with the server
go to your notes
and here we go so Chef node Ascent OS 7
platform this is our IP so it's all done
so now we need to add a cookbook to the
Run list of this node so come here click
on this Arrow
edit run list
here sample this is the cookbook that we
want to run on our node put on the
current run list and here we have the
Run button just click on that so this
should have transferred our cookbook
onto the node let's check that go to
your node machine
clear this
we need to be the root
let's run the chef client service
so we're running it once again because
after it was started we did add
something to our run list the changes in
the Run list is updated
so in one minute 56 seconds
a cookbook has run on our node so the
configuration changes should have been
made
let's check that it's pretty simple just
go to your browser
on the search engine just type localhost
and here's our HTML page that we created
on our workstation congrats you
configured your first note and I really
hope you did so that is the end of our
demo we have successfully installed the
httpd package on our node and we have
also executed a HTML file we look into
the tutorial on the configuration
management tool puppet so let's begin
why puppet so consider the scenario for
MNC the MNC puts together the small team
of system administrators they're
responsible for taking care of the
infrastructure of this organization now
this infrastructure could consist of
data centers server centers and many
such components fortunately for the MNC
they were doing extremely well so the
number of clients kept growing
consistently and with this came a boom
in the infrastructure size now here is
where the problem came in with such a
large infrastructure the small team that
they put together in no way could manage
this so what do we do the solutions is
pretty simple right just increase the
size of the team sure we'll increase the
size of team but when do you think we
can put an upper limit on the size when
do we get to stabilize the steam so here
is where puppet comes in with puppet a
small team is enough to take care of
this large infrastructure this is
because the data center server centers
all of them can be updated in a matter
of seconds with puppet entire load of
doing so has now shifted from the team
onto the tool not only this with puppet
if servers do fail and there's a very
high chance of servers failing when
you're considering an organization the
scale of an MNC puppet can instantly
roll them back to the previous working
States and if that wasn't enough puppet
also provides a capability to deploy
servers on demand and enforce Security
on them now all of this is done through
simple coding which is written in Ruby
we look at how puppet Works more so now
that we know why we should use puppet
let's have a look at what exactly is
puppet so first and foremost puppet is a
configuration management tool as I
already mentioned in the beginning of
this video so this simply means that
puppet ensures that all your systems are
maintained at a consistent state so
consider that you want to deploy a
number of servers now you require these
servers to be identical if this task is
given to a human there's a very good
chance that those systems will not be
identical or some of them may even fail
human are prone to errors you cannot
blame them so puppet ensures that all
these servers are deployed on time and
they are identical secondly puppet is
also a deployment tool this simply means
that puppet has the capability to deploy
your applications your services
softwares all of this on your notes
automatically and finally puppet
implements infrastructure as code now
this term infrastructure as code is a
very important one when when it comes to
the devops approach you would have
noticed this term being used in a
previous video on Chef 2. if not you can
always click the top right corner to
know more so what is this term
infrastructure as code mean
infrastructure score simply means that
all your policies your tasks your
instructions everything is written in
coded format so in case of puppet
specifically all of this is written in
the Ruby language so now that we know
what puppet is let's look into the
puppet architecture so puppet has a
Master Slave architecture as you can see
here on the top we have the puppet
master and Below we have the puppet
clients so the Puppet Master is a system
where your system administrator sits the
clients are those systems which require
configuration we can have n number of
clients connected to the puppet master
so don't worry we look into each of
these components in detail firstly we
have the puppet master so the Puppet
Master is where the system administrator
sits and he or she types in the codes
here so the codes are not only written
in the system but they are also stored
here and whenever the client requires
these codes for their configuration they
simply request it so manifest is the
first sub-competent of the Puppet Master
these are the actual files where the
codes are written so in case of puppet
these are Ruby files modules tie
manifest templates and files into a
single unit now these codes dictate the
instructions for performing various
tasks on your client the next component
is templates so if manifests are your
code templates are the data so let me
explain this to you with an example
consider you want to create a file
called index.html on one of your client
machines so what you do is you write the
code for creating this file in your
manifest and the content of this file is
written in your templates then you
simply link them but here's the thing
when you divide your code and data in
this way it's a very clean structure so
it's preferred to do it in this manner
files are your static contents so the
files are basically sent to your client
and they are simply downloaded at the
client there is no execution or
compilation involved with your files now
this is where files and templates are
extremely different because with
templates they are never sent over to
your client the templates are simply
read by the passer at the master itself
modules ties the Manifest templates and
files into a single unit so modules is
not a separate component as such it just
provides a very clean hierarchy this is
the most important component of the
Puppet Master CA which stands for
certificate Authority now as we will see
later in this video The Puppet Master
and the puppet client communicate
through an exchange of SSL certificates
so when the client sends over the
certificate to the master CA provides
the master the authority to sign these
certificates the minute the master signs
a certificate the master is basically
saying that yes this client is
registered stirred with me and I agree
to exchange data with this client a next
component puppet client of course these
are the systems that require to be
configured agent is a service installed
on the client the agent is solely
responsible for all the communication
between the master and the client and
finally we have Factor so factor is
responsible for collecting all the data
about the present state of our clients
and sending this data over to the Puppet
Master at the master this data is
compared against the Manifest which are
your code files and then these manifests
are sent over to the client depending
upon the results of this comparison so
now that we had a look at the various
components of puppet let's see how these
work together
so we have a master and we have three
clients now before any information can
be transferred between the master and
the client it's important that these
components recognize each other also
there needs to be an encrypted channel
of communication between each pair of
Master and client now all the data which
is transferred between the master and
the client it flows through this channel
so let's see how this entire procedure
of recognizing each other works the core
of this procedure are the SSL
certificates SSL stands for secure
socket layer secure socket layer is a
security protocol and it forms an
encrypted Channel between two components
what this encrypted Channel ensures is
that all the data that is passed through
this channel is not accessible by any
other system outside so it provides
complete Security okay so we will
consider a very general scenario we have
a master and a client here this is not
the Puppet Master the puppet client
they're just two systems and we're just
going forward with Master Slave
architect texture so the client so far
is not a client it is just a system and
we will refer to the system as system a
so system a sends over a client
certificate to the master associated
with this client certificate is the host
name of system a now Master goes through
this certificate it's easy host name and
then it decides whether it wants to form
a communication link with the system a
if it does it signs the certificate and
this signed certificate is sent back to
system a now the system a is officially
a client the minute the master signed
the client certificate it said that yes
I am willing to exchange information
with this system and I do take the
system as one of my clients so now that
the system is officially a client it can
request for data from the master and the
master will simply send over the data
now we are here to talk about puppet so
if this was a puppet master and this was
a puppet client then the first three
stages will be the same so the puppet
client sends over the certificate to the
master the master Sciences certificate
sends it back and the client request for
data now by data here of course we mean
the configuration data those are the
Manifest or even could be your files so
so what happens after this request after
this request the factor service which is
present on your clients collects all the
information regarding the present state
of your client so this information could
include the operating system that's
installed on them the various number of
software present on them the versions of
the software now all this information is
collected it's called the fact and it's
sent over to the master at the master
this information that is the facts is
compared against the Manifest so why
does the master do this the master
basically compares the facts against the
Manifest to know if what the Manifest is
about to perform is already performed on
these systems so if the Manifest has
some additional functionality they are
compiled into catalogs and then these
catalogs are sent over to the client now
remember those agent Services which
existed in your clients here's where
they come in the agents take the catalog
and execute them on the client once
executed these catalogs make the
required changes on the client and a
report is generated this report is then
sent back to the master so the master
keeps record of all the changes that's
made in the system and this comes very
handy when one of the systems fail and
it's required to be rolled back to its
previous working state so this entire
procedure can be repeated n number of
times and can be repeated at regular
intervals so if you have a scenario
where a system needs to be configured
every 30 minutes what you can do is you
can set your interval and automatically
every 30 minutes your systems will be
configured and we reach the final and
the most exciting part of our video
which is the Hands-On so today I'll be
showing you how you can use puppet to
install Apache on one of your client
machines so we'll be using two machines
here we'll have a server and we'll have
a node machine the server is essentially
your master the node is your client I'm
just using the term server and node
instead because I want to keep it very
close to as they are used in the command
now both these machines are going to be
sent to as seven machines and I have
Oracle VM virtualbox installed on my
machine so on that I've simply created
two virtual boxes both Center S7 of
course so before we move on to the
actual demo I'll just take you through
the various steps so first we'll install
the puppet server on our server or
Master machine we'll then start the
server service we then shift over to our
node or the client machine and we'll
install the puppet agent service we will
then start this service too and the
minute you start the puppet agent
service and SSL certificate is created
so this certificate will have the host
name of your node attached to it and
this is how the master or the server
will recognize this certificate and then
it'll sign this certificate so once your
master or the server signs the
certificate you can write your manifest
so the Manifest has just the codes for
configuration and once that 2 is done
you shift back to your client or the
node system and you run the Asian
service so once you run the agent
service your manifest or your catalogs
because as you know the manifests are
compiled into catalogs these are
executed on your node and this will make
the required changes so that's how this
entire process is going to work now
let's move on to the actual demo
this is my Oracle VM virtualbox manager
the last two machines you see here are
the ones we'll be using for this demo
the puppet server is your puppet master
puppet client of course it's the client
so let's just have a look at these two
machines
this is my puppet server so just so you
can differentiate guys the terminals
have been set accordingly puppet server
has a black background with white text
and puppet client here has a black
background with green text
so we'll move on to server machine or
the Master machine because that's the
one we'll be working on first so before
we begin we need to set the hostname of
our Master to puppet so this is a very
essential step in the configuration of
puppet if you missed this out there are
quite a lot of other changes you'll have
to make in certain files so let's do
this first
so that's the command to set the
hostname the last word you see there
that's the new hostname you want
okay so now we'll just check if our
hostname is set so just type host name
and yeah it's puppet
so next we will check the IP of this
machine so for that you just type if
config
enter
so this is your IP guys
under enp 0s3
in its value that is
192.168.2.183 of course the IP will
differ for you guys needless to say
so note that down somewhere because
we'll require it when we are configuring
our client
okay so now you want your puppet server
and your client to communicate so for
this we need to remove certain firewalls
so the command for this is sudo because
we want the root permission
system
CTL
top
firewall
d
and put in the password
okay so all your firewalls are removed
so the next step now we start on with a
puppet process so we download the Puppet
Labs at first now guys ensure that your
systems your virtual boxes in this case
are connected to the net also you won't
be getting an IP if it's not for the
first time
so here's the command to download the
puppet lab
okay
enter the password again
okay so the Puppet Labs is downloaded
now you need to install this
so installation guys we will be
installing the puppets server on the
Master machine or the puppet server
machine
so this may take a while
so that took a while so I just skipped
to the last part where it's completed
the installation process is over
now we need to make a small change in
our system config puppet server file so
let's just move to the file first
this file will open in VI editor
so this line here it basically allocates
memory for your puppet server now you do
not need 2GB
so we are going to reduce the size
512 MB should be enough
so guys notice here I did not type the B
okay so I just changed this to XMS
512 m
let's save that
always remember to open this file using
sudo otherwise saving the changes you
made could be quite Troublesome okay so
now we can start our puppet server
service
foreign
okay so that's done so basically a
puppet server service has started it's
running presently
so for a while we are done with the
server machine
let's move on to our client machine
okay first things first we open our Etc
host file with sudo because you need to
make a few changes and save it open this
in the vi terminal
foreign
you have to add this one line at the end
type in the IP for your puppet server
machine
puppet
Dash master
so let's save this file
now we'll move on to downloading Puppet
Labs on our puppet client so the command
is the same that we use for puppet
server
all right
so Puppet Labs is downloaded now we need
to install the puppet agent service here
again this will also take some time
puppet servers installed
let me just clear this window
now that our puppet agent service is
installed we'll start this service so
I'll just type in the command for
starting the puppet agent service
as you can see here Android changed stop
to running
so basically the service was not running
before and now it's changed to the
running state
and while we executed this command not
only did the servers start running but
an SSL certificate was also created so
this certificate should have the host
name of this machine that's a puppet
client machine attached to it so let's
just check what the host name of our
machine is
that's localhost.local domain so our
certificate should have this attached to
it so guys the first time your client
sends a certificate the name of the
certificate itself is usually the host
name of the machine so a certificate's
name should be localhost.local domain
we'll check this on our Master System
and that's where we'll sign the
certificate to
so first we list out all the
certificates in our case since we have
just one client and we just started the
client we should have technically just
one certificate and it will be so
yeah so this is a certificate localhost
dot local domain we'll now sign the
certificate
foreign
sorry about that just
need to remove these
brackets
yeah as you can see here the certificate
is signed
signed Certificate request
here
so once the certificate is signed the
request for signing the certificate is
removed that's this line
now that a certificate is signed we can
begin to write a manifest so let's move
into a manifest folder and we'll create
a placeholder file
foreign
so we'll create a file called sample.pp
This is a sample file we won't be
writing anything in this file as of now
so we are here we are just creating this
file and then we'll go to our client
machine and just check the if we can
access this file from there
so now we'll move to our client machine
[Music]
so let's test the connection
so as you can see here it says applied
catalog in 0.03 seconds so our catalog
is executed
on a client machine
now our catalog was just a placeholder
basically so the file that we created
which is sample.pp had no content and we
were just testing our client now let's
go back to our Master server put some
content into this file and see how the
execution takes place
so we'll open our filesample.pp which we
created earlier in the vi editor
let's type a code here
so node and then within the brackets we
enter the hostname of our client machine
so this ensures that our manifest is
executed on this particular machine
foreign
service package on Centos is called the
httpd
so this line that I just typed in is the
action it'll ensure that the httpd
package is installed on your client
and that's it so this is our code we'll
save it
now let's go back to our client machine
and test it
so the suckline machine
and our catalogs applied on the client
so I just cleared the screen now we'll
start the Apache service
okay so how do we see if it's running we
just need to go to our browser
and add localhost you must have the
testing page for your Apache
so we type localhost
enter
and yeah this is the testing page for
Apache so as you can see we have
successfully used puppet to install the
Apache service on a puppet client
and this is the end of our demo the
ansible is currently the most trending
and popular configuration management
tool and it's used mostly under the
devops approach so let's begin why
should you use ansible let's consider a
scenario of an organization where Sam is
a system administrator Sam is
responsible for the company's
infrastructure a company's
infrastructure basically consists of all
its systems this could include your web
servers your database servers the
various repositories and so on so as a
system administrator Sam needs to ensure
that all the systems are running the
updated versions of the software now
when you consider a handful of systems
this seems like a pretty simple task Sam
can simply go from system to system and
perform the configurations required but
that is not the case with an
organization is it an organization has a
very large infrastructure it could have
hundreds and thousands of systems so
here is where Sam's work gets really
difficult not only does it get tougher
Sam has to move from system to system
performing the same task over and over
again this makes Sam bored not just that
repeating the same task leaves no space
for Innovation and without any ideas or
innovation how does the system grow and
the worst of it all is manual labor is
prone to errors so what does Sam do well
here is where ansible comes in use with
ansible Sam can write simple codes that
are deployed onto all the systems and
configure them to the correct States so
now that we know why we should use
ansible let's look at what exactly is
ansible ansible is an I.T engine that
automates the following tasks so first
we have orchestration orchestration
basically beings bringing together of
multiple applications and ensuring an
order in which these are executed so for
example if you consider a web page that
you require to host this webpage stores
all its values that it takes from the
user into a database so the first thing
you must do is ensure that the system
has a database manager and only then do
you host your web page so this kind of
an order is very crucial to ensure that
things work right next ansible automates
configuration management so
configuration management simply means
that all the systems are maintained at a
consistent desired state are the tools
that automate configuration management
include puppet and Chef and finally
ansible automates deployment deployment
simply means the deploying of
application onto your servers of
different environments so if you have to
deploy an application on 10 systems with
different environments you don't have to
manually do this anymore because ansible
automates it for you in fact ansible can
also ensure that these applications or
the code are deployed at a certain time
or after regular intervals now that we
know what exactly ansible is let's look
at ansible's architecture ansible has
two main component you have the local
machine and you have your node or the
client machine so the local machine is
where the system administrator sits he
or she installs ansible here and on the
other end you have your node or the
client systems so in case of ansible
there's no supporting software installed
here these are just the systems that
required to be configured and they are
completely controlled by the local
machine at your local machine you also
have a module a module is a collection
of your configuration files and in case
of ansible these configuration files are
called playbooks playbooks are written
in yaml yaml stands for yaml and a
markup language and it is honestly the
easiest language to understand and learn
since it's so close to English we also
have the inventory the inventory is a
file where you have all your nodes that
require configuration mentioned and
based on the kind of configuration they
require they are also grouped together
so later in the demo we'll have a look
at how the Playbook and the inventory is
written in and that will probably make
it clearer so of course the local
machine needs to communicate with the
client and how is this done this is done
through SSH ssh is your secure shell
which basically provides a protected
Communication in an unprotected
environment
okay these components of ansible now how
does ansible exactly work you have your
local machine on one end this is where
you install ansible if you have gone
through any previous material on
ansabill you would have come across the
term agentless often being associated
with this tool so this is what agentless
means you're installing ansible only on
your local machine and there's no
supporting software or Plugin being
installed on your clients this means
that you have no agent on the other end
the local machine has complete control
and hence the term agentless another
term that you would come across with
ansible is push configuration so since a
local machine has complete control here
it pushes the playbooks onto the nodes
and thus it's called a push
configuration tool now the playbooks and
the inventory are written at the local
machine and the local machine connects
with the nodes through the SSH client
this step here is optional but it's
always recommended to do so it where the
facts are collected so facts are
basically the current state of the node
now all this is collected from the node
and sent to the local machine so when
the Playbook is executed the tasks
mentioned in the Playbook is compared
against the current status of the note
and only the changes that are required
to be made further are made and once the
playbooks are executed your notes are
configured to the desired States so as I
mentioned before ansible is currently
the most trending tool in the market
under the configuration management
umbrella so let's have a look at the
various benefits of ansible which gives
it this position well ansible is
agentless it's efficient it's flexible
simple in important and provides
automated reporting how does it do all
this let's have a look at that agentless
as I already mentioned before you
require no supporting software or Plugin
installed on your node or the client
system so the master has complete
control and automatically this means
that ansible is more efficient because
now we have more space in our client and
node systems for other resources and we
can get ansible up and running real
quick ansible is also flexible so an
infrastructure is prone to change very
often and ansible takes no amount of
time to adjust to these changes ansible
cannot get any simpler with your
playbooks written in a language such as
yaml which is as close to English as you
can possibly get
it important basically means that if you
have a Playbook which needs to be run n
number of systems it would have the same
effect on all of these systems without
any side effect and finally we have
automated reporting so in case of
ansible your playbook has a number of
tasks and all these tasks are named so
whenever you run or execute your
playbook it gives a report on which
tasks ran successfully which failed
which clients were not reachable and so
on all this information is very crucial
when you're dealing with a very large
infrastructure and finally we reach the
most exciting part of our tutorial the
Hands-On before we move on to the actual
Hands-On let me just brief you through
what exactly we'll be doing so I'll be
hosting two virtual boxes both Centos 7
Operating Systems one would be my local
machine and other my node or the client
machine so on my local machine first all
ansible we then write the inventory and
the Playbook and then simply deploy this
Playbook on the client machine in
there's just one thing that we need to
do is that we need to check if the
configurations that we mentioned in our
Playbook are made right so we'll now
begin our demo this is my Oracle virtual
box here I have my master system which
is the local machine and this is the
client machine so let's have a look at
these two machines this is my client
machine the terminal is open right now
so the client machine terminal has a
black background with white text and the
Master machine terminal has a white
background with black text just so you
can differentiate between the two so
we'll start at the Master machine the
first thing to do is we need to install
our ansible so yum install
ansible hyphen Y is the command to do so
so this might take some time
yeah so ansible is installed the next
step we go to our host file so host file
here is basically the inventory it's
where you'll specify all your nodes in
our case we just have one node
that's the path to your host file
as you'll see everything here is
commented so just type in the group for
your client notes so I'm going to name
it ansible clients
[Music]
and here we need to type the IP address
of our client machine so my client
machine's IP address is
192.168.2.127 so before you come to this
it's advice that you check the IP
address on your machine the simple
command for that is ifconfig now once
you type the IP address go to space and
here we need to mention the username and
the password for our client
so I'll be logging in as the root user
so this is the password
and then the user
which is Root in my case
that's it now you can save this file
just clear the screen
next we move on to our Playbook we need
to write the Playbook
so the extension for a Playbook is yml
which stands for yaml
and as you can see here I have already
written my playbook but I'll just
explain to you how this is done so a
yaml file always begins with three
dashes this indicates the start of your
yaml file
now the first thing is you need to give
a name to the entire Playbook
so I have named it sample book host is
basically where this would be executed
so as we saw earlier in our inventory I
mentioned client's group name as ansible
clients so we use the same name here
the remote user is the user you'll be
using at your clients so in my case
that's root and become true is basically
to indicate that you need to set your
privileges at root so that's called a
privilege escalation now A playbook
consists of tasks
so we have here three tasks the first
task I've named it to install httpd so
what we are doing here is we are
installing our httpd package which is
basically the Apache server and we are
installing the most latest version of it
hence the state value is latest the next
task is running httpd so for the service
the name is httpd because that's the
service we need to start running and the
state is started our next task is
creating content so this is the part
where we are creating our web page
so copy because this is the file that
will be created at the client
the content will be welcome and the
destination of the file will be via
www.html index.html as you know this is
like a default path that we use to store
all our HTML files now as you can see
here there's quite a lot of indentation
and when it comes to yaml although it's
very simple to write and very easy to
read
the indentation is very crucial
so the first Dash here represents the
highest stage that is the name of the
Playbook and all the dashes under tasks
are slightly shifted towards the right
so if you have two dashes at the same
location they basically mean that they
are siblings so the priority would be
the same so to ensure that all your
tasks are coming under the tasks label
make sure they are not directly under
name so yeah that's pretty much it so
when you write your yaml file the
language is pretty simple very readable
indentations absolutely necessary make
sure all your spaces are correctly
placed we can now save this file
next thing we need to check if the
syntax of a yaml file is absolutely
right because that's very crucial
so the command to check the syntax of
the yaml file is ansible
Playbook
the name of your playbook
syntax check
so we have no syntax errors which is why
the only output you receive is sample
dot yml which is the name of your
playbook so our Playbook is ready to be
executed
the command to execute the Playbook is
ansible Playbook
and the name of your playbook
so a playbooks executed as you can see
here Gathering facts that's where all
the facts of the note that the present
state of the note is collected and sent
to the local machine so it's basically
to check that if the configuration
changes that we are about to make is
already made
so it's not made we do not have the
httpd package installed on our node so
this is the first change that's made
also if it's not installed of course
it's not running that's the second
change that's made so it's put into the
running state
and a final task which is create content
is under the okay State this means that
the contents already present in the
client machine so I made it this way so
that you can at least see the different
states that's present
so over here we have okay four so four
things are all fine the facts are
gathered two things are changed and one
is already present two changes are made
zero clients are unreachable and zero
tasks have failed so this is the
documentation that I was referring to
previously that ansible provides
automatically
and is very useful as you can see
so our next step we need to just check
on a client machine if all the changes
that we desired are made so let's move
to our client
so this is my client machine so to check
this since we are installing the httpd
package and hosting a web page the best
way to do it is open your browser
and type in localhost
so there you go your Apache server is
installed and your web page is hosted
so that was very simple wasn't it
if you have any doubts about the
procedure or any other part of the
tutorial please post your doubts in the
comment section below and we'll get back
to you as soon as we see them provide
the overview of how and why you should
be using kubernetes so why kubernetes
well kubernetes is really being built
from allowing you to be able to have a
more reliable infrastructure the tool
itself is designed to manage the
containers you have within your network
it's very modular in architecture which
allows it to be very easy to be able to
maintain and to be able to scale and
meet the demands that your current
customers are offering you today the
actual ability for you to be able to
deploy and update software at scale is
really at the heart and center of
kubernetes it's really well the one of
the reasons why kubernetes was created
was to be able to scale up the
deployment of software into tens of
thousands of networks and servers within
a Data Center and then finally when you
start working with kubernetes really
what you're doing is laying the
foundation for building Cloud native
applications and part of this comes from
the architecture and history of open
Eddies which we'll get to in a little
bit but it's good to know that as you're
using kubernetes and containerized
solutions that you're really building
out an infrastructure that's designed
for cloud-centric solution delivery so
let's dig into why what kubernetes is so
the history of kubernetes is that it was
originally developed by Google Google
actually used the precursor to
kubernetes to manage and maintain the
data structured and data infrastructure
that they had within their Network they
really liked it and one of the big
benefits that kubernetes that Google
provided is that they converted their
code into an open source program that
they released as kubernetes in 2014 and
made an open source this means that any
company can use kubernetes there's no
charge for it all you have to do is know
how to use the command line to actually
get up and running the benefit of
kubernetes being open source is that
most Cloud providers now support
kubernetes so whether you're using
Microsoft azure you're using Google
cloud or AWS you'll find that you can
actually use kubernetes and kubernetes
and edit core really helped eliminate
manual processes so it allowed for
deploying and scaling your
container-based Solutions much more
effortless within a cloud environment so
let's jump into the features of
kubernetes and why you'd want to be
using it and we have a number of
features that we want to kind of Step
through again the first thing that
kubernetes is a strong benefit of is
that it eliminates those manual
processes and allows you to automate
them the benefit you have from this is
that you can then scale up your
automation across your entire network so
whether you are managing 10 nodes and
within your network or whether you're
managing 10 000 it doesn't matter you
have the ability to scale that something
you simply didn't have before kubernetes
is also will manage the actual
containers themselves including the
security and the storage and the
networking within those containers the
great benefit of working with kubernetes
is that not only is it a cloud-centric
solution but it was really built from a
core need of a secure solution so
security is at the heart and center of
all the work you're doing now which
really helps benefit any teams scaling
out containers your kubernetes
environment will be constantly monitored
so that when you have nodes that have
your containers the health of those
nodes is being constantly communicated
back to uh the kubernetes environment so
that the entire environment has always
been managed and checked so if you have
any additional hosting and launching
that needs to be done kubernetes will
help you automate those manual processes
if something does go wrong you can
actually set up your kubernetes
environment to do an automatic roll bag
again this is just allowing you to have
that confidence that when you're
deploying a solution that everything is
going to work within that environment
and then then finally kubernetes will
allow you to mount and add the storage
needed to run your apps so whether you
have storage such as a local SSD storage
device physically on the hardware or if
you're connecting to storage fire the
cloud kubernetes will allow you to
access the storage you need how you're
accessing it so let's look a little bit
into the differences between kubernetes
and Docker swarm so if we just step back
a little bit kubernetes and Docker often
get connected with each other and
largely because kubernetes manages
containers and Docker is really famous
for creating the most popular container
management solution which is called
Docker if you're a developer you're
probably already using Docker today so
one of the things that kubernetes is
really really good at is that it manages
containers at scale and just massive
volume of containers Docker swarm is
docker's alternative to kubernetes is a
tool that allows you to also manage
large number large numbers of containers
there are differences between the two of
them and right now without doubt the
most popular open source solution out
there is kubernetes from Google it just
has a massive Community behind it and
the community really have embraced
kubernetes yes the original product was
by developed by Google but Google has
been great stewards and they've allowed
the community to drive the future
evolution of the product uh Docker swarm
is actually managed and developed by
Docker there is a smaller Community but
it is also a very passionate community
and the reason being is that both
products are actually pretty good and
you just really kind of have to choose
which one you want to go with without
doubt there is more customization and
extensions built for kubernetes simply
because the community is just so much
bigger than the docker swarm community
Unity but with that said Docker swarm is
really easy to set up so if you are used
to working within the docker environment
you will be able to set up Docker swarm
very very quickly whereas kubernetes
does require some heavy lifting to get
up and running now with that said if you
are using Microsoft Azure or Google
Cloud very often those environments will
actually set up kubernetes for you so
you don't have to do it and you can
actually then focus on writing the
instructions to maintain your kubernetes
environment kubernetes has extremely
high voltage tolerance again it's
because kubernetes is has been Road
tested the foundation for kubernetes is
based on managing sites such as Gmail
google.com YouTube I mean just
incredibly robust environment compared
to Docker swarm which has lower fault
tolerance
um and this really kind of leads into
the final areas where kubernetes is does
guarantee strong cluster management just
a really reliable environment Dr swarm
however is able to take containers
deploy them into large casters very very
quickly two interesting differences is
that with kubernetes the load balancing
is still manual and be interesting to
watch how kubernetes matures that skill
set in contrast load balancing is
automatic within Docker swarm so let's
dig into the kubernetes architecture and
just kind of expose some of those key
elements um if you're interested in
actually having a very deep dive into
kubernetes architecture we have already
got another video and we should have a
link in the comments that you can select
that will take you to that video as well
and but this will provide you an
overview as well um so the way that
kubernetes runs is that it uses nodes to
actually manage all the individual
Hardware within a specific unit and so a
node is really a physical machine in a
data center or a virtual machine and
when you're setting up an environment on
a cloud environment such as Microsoft
Azure or Google cloud or AWS kubernetes
will be managing the containers within
that node so it's important to know that
kubernetes itself doesn't work with the
individual nodes but actually works with
the cluster as a whole and and why
that's important is that it's a tool to
manage your entire environment it's not
going to come down and manage the
individual node itself it's going to
imagine the entire environment the
actual control of data within a cluster
and it's very very flexible within
kubernetes you can have local storage
such as an SSD card or a traditional
local storage or you can actually
connect to the cloud and use cloud-based
storage and the benefit that cloud-based
storage offers you is that you are
increasingly Moving Your solution into
more of a hardware free environment and
cloud-based architecture where you're
not reliant on a physical piece of
Hardware within your data center and why
that's important is that it gives you
the opportunity to scale up your
Solutions much more effectively so if
you need to increase the hard drive
space you can do that very easily from
the cloud whereas local hardware is a
little bit harder to manage great news
kubernetes gives you both options to be
able to choose from and so the the next
layer down is the actual management of
the application and that's within a
container and as mentioned earlier
Docker is the most popular container
solution out there and again if you're a
developer you're probably already using
Docker as it was a natural maturity from
using a virtual machine but kubernetes
itself will actually manage the
containers that you have within your
nodes and so you have a collection of
containers working together and then you
pull those together into what's called a
pod and what's great is kubernetes will
actually manage the health of that pod
so if a container or pod fails
kubernetes will automatically deploy out
a replica so your entire environment can
stay running and being efficient and so
the pods themselves will actually be
managed by kubernetes and you really
want to let kubernetes do this because
it's allowing you to step away from the
manual management of Parts your
environment is just going to be
healthier relying on kubernetes to do
the actual management of all the pods
you have out there so you are able to
allow access to well from Services
outside of your kubernetes and this is
done through a process called Ingress
and going back earlier we talked about
how security is a key part of all the
work that goes into kubernetes and this
is a great example of where you can use
an external service but still have that
layer of security that is vital for your
solution because to be able to provide
the Ingress connection kubernetes
requires that SSR well connection which
automatically allows for a secure data
transfer absolutely fantastic so here we
have an overview of the actual
architecture on the right hand side we
have our nodes and the pods within our
nodes and within those pods are the
containers on the left hand side we have
the master architecture and the master
architecture is the actual brains behind
the work that you're doing it's actually
managing the schedules the controllers
for all of the nodes and then and the
bottom left hand side we have commands
which are written on a local workstation
and those commands are pushed up to the
master so let's kind of dig a little bit
further into the architecture of the
master so the master itself is comprised
of a number of key components again this
is the tool that's going to manage your
entire kubernetes infrastructure the key
components that you have are the
etcd control manager schedule a API
server and the key for components are
Etc or the cluster store the controller
manager the scheduler and the API server
the cluster store is the tool where all
the details of the work that you're
doing is stored now it's going to manage
the rules it's going to manage all the
instructions and this is where you're
going to post that information the
controller is actually going to then
perform the tasks that are stored in the
cluster store and as you'd expect the
schedule is the tool that actually
controls when instructions and tasks are
pushed out to all the pods and nodes
within your network and then finally you
have an API server which allows you to
be able to control all the operations
the actual operations themselves are all
the instructions written as rest
instructions and which allows you to
take advantage of the security that has
been built into rest and so you end up
with a workers slave architecture and
slaves are all the different nodes and
pods within your network and so a part
itself will have multiple one or more
multiple containers and then each
container and then each part will have a
Docker container a kublet and a
kubernetes proxy and the these are tools
to allow you to communicate back up to
the master layer so the docker is the
actual container itself and this is
going to actually run your application
and the instructions here are to pull
down the correct container from the
docker images that you have within your
library the cubelet is going to manage
your containers and your container
instructions that will be deployed to
the cubelet are going to be written in
either yaml or Json format yaml is just
graded if you haven't had a chance to
start working with yaml I certainly
encourage you to do so it's very easy to
pick up if you know any XML you'll pick
up yaml very quickly and finally the
kubernetes proxy is the tool that
interacts with the master environment
within the kubernetes network and allows
all the instructions from that are
pushed to the cubelete and to Docker to
be able to perform effectively so let's
have a look at some of the companies
using kubernetes there are a lot and if
you're doing any work today in the cloud
and even if you're just starting off and
doing some simple work in the cloud
there's a really good chance that you
are using kubernetes for some of the
companies that you would are probably
not surprised at using kubernetes are a
Spotify sap eBay and of course some of
the the big companies out there Google
with their entire network of solutions
and Microsoft with office and their
tools so let's take a step into aube now
let's have a look at a kubernetes use
case and in this example we're going to
look at the New York Times and how they
use kubernetes to solve a problem that
their IIT Department was struggling with
so when a New York Times started working
after their data centers their their
actual deployments were small and the
applications were managed across VMS but
the problem is is that as New York Times
became more visual company they started
building more digital Solutions and at
some point they realized that what they
needed to do was to embrace the cloud
and move all their solutions to the
cloud however their first step of using
the cloud and this is I think typical
for a lot of companies is that they
treated like the cloud hosted provider
in the same way as they would with a
Data Center and they at some point they
realized they had to take a change and
this is where the development team came
in and they said look how about we stop
thinking of our Solutions as a data
center even though they're being run in
Amazon and start thinking them as Cloud
first Solutions and so what they
proposed and what they ended up doing
was using Google Cloud platform with
kubernetes as servers and to provide
greater efficiency and so by using
kubernetes they had the following
advantages they're able to deliver
Solutions and a much faster speed and in
the world of digital content speed is
everything they're able to reduce the
time for deployment from minutes to
seconds and by doing this they were able
to increase the amount of time that
uptime for the actual infrastructure um
updates began to be deployed
independently and when required so you
didn't have to schedule an event when
you do the deployments it just happened
and there was more unified approach to
deployment from the engineering staff
which just made the whole solution more
portable so the fundamental end line for
the New York Times is that by leveraging
kubernetes they were able to
automatically manage their deployments
and scheduling of solutions instead of
having to do Solutions through a more
traditional ticket based system it just
really speed up the efficiency of the
New York Times website so this finally
kind of look into some of the important
terminologies before we take it our time
to do a demo so we have six terms that
we're going and look through and we'll
let you uh read through this but uh we
have a cluster which is a set of
machines physical vertical in which
applications are managed and run we have
a node that are the working machines
that run containerized applications and
other workloads there is the pod which
is within a node and there's a group of
containers that are deployed together on
the same host we have replication
controllers now replication controller
is used to define a pods life cycle
rather than to create the pods directly
we have a selector which is an
expression matched label to filter
specific resources and that labels are
key value pairs that are attached to
objects such as pods and the key value
pad or the label can be filtered
organized and perform operations on
resources replication sense Define how
many replicas of each pod will be
running and manage when you want to
either replace a pod when it dies
annotation is a label with much larger
data capacity a name is a resource as it
is identified volume is the direction
which data is accessible to a container
namespaces provide additional
qualification to a resources name and
then finally service is an abstraction
of a top-tier pods which provide a
single IEP address and DNS Name by which
the pods can be accessed so this time
what we want to do is take you through
kubernetes demo actually runs through
some of these basic controls so we're
going to take you through a video of how
to actually install kubernetes and to
use some of the basic instructions so
kubernetes is the most wildly used
platform for container management the
first step is to actually install the
necessary dependencies so let's see if
there's any updates first so the first
so to check that there's any updates
we'll use the command sudo app dash get
update we're entering our password and
this looks like it's going to take a few
minutes because we've got a few updates
that need to be running all right we're
done all right next we're going to write
sudo app get in install Dash y
apt-transport https and this will
install all of the dependencies we need
to actually start installing the
solutions needed for kubernetes all
right that was quick now we're going to
put in the docker dependency and the way
we do that is write the command sudo apt
install Docker dot IO I'll go typo
correct that quickly and put in y so vs
and we continue and it's going to take a
while because we're going to download
and install Docker off the internet and
it's quite a large installation now
would be a good time to go get a cup of
coffee because it'll take us about a
minute to get this all done once we
actually have Docker installed we'll let
you go ahead and we'll start Docker and
enable Docker using our sudo commands
all right so that's all done so let's
start enable Docker we're going to using
so we're going to use sudo systemctl
start Docker and sudo systemctl enable
Docker this will be quite quick
so the next step is to install all the
components for kubernetes and we're
going to install the curl command and
then cubilate Cube C and then cubeadm
and we're going to install all the
necessary tools we do the curl command
cubelet cubic C2 and Cube ADM and so
let's go ahead and put in the sudo
apt-get install Curl we're going to get
a prompt we can say yes for that
and then after this we'll go ahead and
install kubernetes so the first what
we're going to do is we're going to
actually put in the kubernetes key so
that's going to be pseudocal dash s and
then we have a long URL which is https
uh packages.cloud google.com apt dark
apt-key.gpg
sudo
apt-key there we go create my typo there
okay now we have to go ahead and change
permissions of a folder so we do that
with sudo chmod 777 slash Etc apt slash
sources.list.d all right we're good okay
now you want to go ahead and open up
your text editor and we're going to make
um an actual edit and we're going to
create a simple file and so what we're
going to type in is the following
command DB httbt apt dash dot kubernetes
dot IO slash kubernetes Dash xenial Main
and we're going to save this file in the
ETC folder and then look for and then a
APT which is going to be down a little
bit and there we have it and we're going
to save it in the
apt-get updates and we're going to name
this file as kubernetes dot list and
we'll save that and then we can close
out the notepad and go back to the
terminal window and let's look and see
see if there are any updates again so
we're going to go ahead and run apt-get
update and it's going to run any updates
from what we've created and we want to
check what's in the folder and so we do
cat slash X at ATT
Etc apt
sources.d kubernetes dot list and there
we are that shows what we have in that
text file and so we're going to go ahead
and we're going to install cubelet cubic
cubic 2 and Cube ADM but first we're
going to have to initialize the master
I'm going to show you what an error you
would get if you were to install cubelet
and the other files too quickly you get
a fine error
all right so we have installed cubelet
qbadm cubic tool and kubernetes CNN and
so we're going to go ahead and use sudo
swap up Dash a and now we're going to
initialize the master node and we're
going to do that with sudo Cube ADM in
it and this will take a few minutes for
it to initialize
all right so that's all done all right
so we're going to deploy the Pod to a
network and we have two commands that
we're going to use we use sudo cuboo
Cube CTL apply
and we have a long Pathway to type out
which is Dash fhqbs raw githubs
content.com Korea's final Master
documentation Cube file Dot yml
what we we have to do is we have to
actually go ahead and deploy the nodes
first so we're going to do that by
creating mktr Dash p and then we have
dollar sign home dash dot Cube and
create that new directory and sudo CP
Dash I and then the path will be
Etc
kubernetes
admin.conf and then dial sign home slash
dot Cube dot slash config
and then final one will be pseudo
c-h-o-w-n dollar sign open Prime ID Dash
U closed paren colon dollar sign a brand
ID slash Dash G close paren door sign
home slash dot Q slash config all right
now we're going to go ahead and deploy
and uh let's see and oh yeah I think I
have a typo in my command here yep oh
yeah I did have a typo and so
um I've got that incorrect now so
documentation is actually spelled with a
t not an S and then we're going to go
ahead and we're going to put in the next
line which is pseudo cubic Cube CTL
apply dash dash F and then we're just
going to change a little bit of the
actual link here and that runs great and
now we want to be able to see all of the
pods that we have in our Network and so
we're going to do that by writing the
commands sudo cubic TCL get pods Dash or
all dash dash main spaces and it should
list all of our pods we only have one
there we are there's all the content now
we're going to so there's only one note
so let's see what we have here so we're
going to use the command sudo you know
cubic TL get nodes there we are just one
node so our final step is to actually go
ahead and deploy a service and so what
we're going to go ahead is deploy the
ngi and access service and we're going
to do that with the command sudo cubic
CTL run Dash Dash image equals nginx and
we're going to put this into Port 80 so
it's going to be nginx Nash app dash
dash Port equals 80 dash dash
environment EMV equals uh open Con open
quota domain equals cluster close quotes
and we're going to write one more
command which is sudo Cube CTL expose
deployment nginx Dash app dash dash Port
equals 80 dash dash name equals nginx
Dash HTTP and once we've done this we'll
be able to then run the command to
actually see our services and there'll
be quite a few of them
and our final command is sudo docker
ps-a
and we have quite a lot of lists quite a
lot of services listed so there you are
that's the instructions on how to get
Docker up and running and uh with some
basic commands and it is worth going
through a few times to again get right
um but once you actually have
um the uh kubernetes environment up and
running and managing your document
environment and containers it's
extremely powerful in this section we're
going to talk about what is cloud
computing and how things were before AWS
and we're going to talk about what is
AWS and the benefits of AWS and the
products and services that Amazon offers
as of now and then finally we're going
to end the session with a project that
is going to help us understand how to
create Jenkins build server for
continuous integration and in this
project we will learn about how to
deploy and host Jenkins and open source
automation software predominantly used
for CI CD otherwise continuous
integration and continuous development
so what is cloud computing cloud
computing is the on demand delivery of
compute resources through a cloud
platform accessed via the Internet and
it is a it's also a pay as ego service
be it compute capacity or database or
storage in Cloud we access them through
the internet and that too on a
pay-as-you-go pricing model let's talk
about how things were before AWS existed
Expedia as we know as the people
Logistic Company or the company that
helps people move around the world with
ease has a certain problem before they
decided to migrate to AWS and migrating
to AWS was a solution to their problem
back then booking ticket was an
unpleasant experience compared to what
it is now it generally would take a long
time to book a ticket and sometimes it
would time out if there is a promotion
or if a huge sale announced and if the
environment is not scaled up to meet the
demand and sometimes it would time out
if there is a promotion or if a huge
sale announced and they could not scale
up the environment and keep up with the
speed of the promotion that's when they
got introduced to AWS and with the AWS
power to increase the capacity of the
environment on the Fly solved their
scaling issue instead of waiting on the
new hardware to arrive and wondering
what to do with the hardware when the
promotion is over with AWS we can
quickly scale up the environment when
there is a need and scale down the
environment during lull periods now that
being said let's talk about what is AWS
Amazon web services or in short AWS is a
secure cloud service platform offering
compute power database content delivery
and other functionality that you would
need to help your business scale and
grow AWS is a very secure Cloud platform
and such security Cannot Be Imagined in
on-premises without spend ending a
fortune almost any type of applications
can be created and deployed in the cloud
which includes the latest iot
applications machine learning artificial
intelligence and so on and the best part
is we can Avail the service from
anywhere as long as we have an active
internet and all this is availed on pay
as you go subscription now let's talk
about the benefits of AWS AWS Cloud
platform is very easy to use one needs
no complicated programming or compute
knowledge to access and use this
environment even with less programming
and compute knowledge one could become a
probe in accessing and maintaining the
cloud the products and services offered
are very flexible in nature and that
provides room for us to easily integrate
the service to other services in AWS and
services outside AWS cloud in general is
a very reliable service and AWS in
specific is very reliable cloud in
general is very reliable and when you
talk about AWS it's very true a
statistic says that about 95 percent of
the cloud computing in the whole world
is run on AWS due to AWS reliable nature
the services in AWS are scalable by
nature and most of the services provide
click button scaling services and AWS
are very cost effective and it becomes
very true when you start using more
services and AWS are very cost effective
and it becomes very true when you start
using more service services and AWS are
very cost effective and it becomes more
true when we start using more since when
we start using more service the per unit
price drops down even further Security
in the cloud is at its highest with
encryption and a multi-factor
authentications and being able to audit
the logs one can be sure that when one
hosts a service in AWS they are hosting
it in an environment which has been
built with Enterprise Security in mind
all right let's now talk about or talk
briefly about the different products and
so services available in the cloud some
of the products and services available
in the cloud are compute storage
database migration Services networking
and content delivery developer tools and
services available for managing the AWS
environment tools needed for machine
learning development analytic tools
needed for security and identity
compliance tools needed for mobile
application Services tools needed for
iot and gaming development are some of
the products that are available in AWS
all right let's first talk about compute
service now compute service it enables
us to develop lie run and scale our
applications and workloads on the cloud
you might agree with me that compute
service is the fundamental of any
applications and AWS provides many
options to use those compute services in
the cloud starting from ec2 which is a
VM in the cloud to Lambda which is
serverless Computing in the cloud to
compute service compute service also
includes containers services and
services that help batch processing and
deploying applications and load
balancing the request when we run our
applications on multiple servers and
services that help batch processing and
developing applications and load
balancing the request when we run our
applications in multiple servers we're
going to talk about the two compute
products in specific let's talk about
ec2 ec2 is a service with a resizable
compute capacity in the cloud that
allows business subscribers to run
application programs in the Computing
environment and the best part here is
ec2 is resizable anytime there is more
demand I can simply resize my computer
to meet the demand on the other hand
Lambda is a serverless compute service
used to execute back-end codes it really
helps us to focus on the core
competencies like application building
the code Let's Talk About Storage
service for a while AWS storage is known
for its durability and availability with
S3 being the object storage for the
internet where users or application can
directly upload and download the content
from the internet and EBS being a
durable block storage that gets attached
to the ec2 instance and Glacier being
the archival solution in the cloud and
storage Gateway being the Gateway for
storing data locally and having a backup
in the cloud in case of disaster let's
talk about two important storage service
products in the cloud which is S3 now S3
is an web-based cloud storage service
it's designed for online backup And
archiving of data and the best part
about S3 is that it provides 11 9
durability which means once we store the
data in S3 the chances of losing the
data is nearly zero EBS on the other
hand provides persistent and resizable
and migratable storage to the VMS or EC
tools that we can run in the cloud now
let's talk about the database offerings
in the cloud beginning with RDS for SQL
and dynamodb for nosql well and elastic
cache for web caching services and
Amazon redshift for petabyte scale data
warehousing services AWS database
service provides all the database
service needs we might have let's talk
about two database services in specific
RDS RDS is an web service that is
designed to simplify the setup operation
and scaling of the relational database
in the cloud and dynamodb is an fast and
flexible nosql database service which is
well known for its low latency and
scalability performance Network and
content delivery service contributes to
the infrastructure as a service side of
the cloud it provides a secure Cloud
infrastructure and connects our physical
Network to our private virtual network
with low latency and high transfer
speeds and under networking and content
delivery services VPC is virtual private
Cloud networking in the cloud Route 53
is the DNS service in the cloud and
Direct Connect is a service that
connects our on-premises with AWS
environment through point-to-point
cables and cloudfront is content
delivery Network or caching service
throughout the world let's talk about
the VPC for a while VPC it enables us to
launch AWS resources into a virtual
Network that we Define in the cloud VPC
resembles very similar to our office
network with the subnets firewalls
private zones public or DMZ zones and
lot more we can also create a VPN
connection between on-premises and Cloud
environment through this VPC and Route
53 it is a scalable and highly available
domain name system web service that
helps to Route the end users to the
internet application now AWS is a domain
registrar as well and here we can buy
domain names for our organization and
use them to mask the IP addresses behind
it and by the way if you didn't know
already DNS is the one that translates
human readable names like
www.xyz.com into the numeric IP address
let's talk about developer tool services
now developer tool services in Amazon
provides services where developers can
store an application source code and
automatically build test and deploy
applications on AWS out of which AWS
codestar enables us to quickly develop
build and deploy applications in AWS and
code build is a fully managed build
service that compiles source code runs
test and produces software packages that
are ready to deploy and code Deploy on
the other hand is a service that
automatic that automates is a service
that automates software developments to
a variety of compute services including
Amazon ec2 Amazon Lambda and even
instances running on premises and AWS
code pipeline is a continuous
integration and continuous delivery
service for fast and reliable
application and infrastructure updates
let's talk about code star code star is
a service designed for developers where
they can quickly deploy build and
develop applications on AWS AWS code
star provides a unified user interface
enabling us to easily manage our
software development activities in one
place with AWS code star we can set up
our entire continuous delivery tool
chain in minutes allowing us to start
releasing codes faster and not only that
AWS code star makes it easy for you or
your a whole team to work together
securely allowing you to easily manage
access and add owners contributors and
viewers to our project and not only that
AWS code star project comes with a
project management dashboard including
an integrated issue tracking
capabilities provided by Ajira software
with the AWS code star project dashboard
we can easily track progress across our
entire software development process from
our backlog of work items to teams
recent code deployments so on and so
forth AWS code build on the other hand
is an cloud service that enables an IT
developer to build and test code with
continuous scaling now here you pay only
for the build time that you have used
now code built is a fully managed
service that helps compiling a source
codes and run tests and produce software
packages that are ready to deploy AWS
with AWS code build we there is no need
for us to provision manage and scale our
own build servers code build scales
continuously and process and processes
multiple bills concurrently so our bills
are not left waiting in the queue
because it's processed concurrently
let's talk about security identity and
compliance services available in Amazon
in general the security identity and
complaint services is in Amazon helps us
to maintain a secure environment in
Amazon by providing services for user
authentication for limiting the access
to certain set of users on the AWS
environment out of which IAM or identity
and access management it's a product
that enables us to manage access to AWS
services and resources that enables us
to manage access to AWS resources and
services in a secure fashion using IAM
we can create and manage AWS users and
groups and use permissions to allow and
deny their access to AWS resources on
the other hand KMS or Key Management
Service is a managed service that makes
it easy for us to create and control the
encryption Keys used to encrypt our data
and Cognito it lets us to add user sign
up sign in and access control to our web
and mobile apps quickly and easily and
Waf or web application firewall helps us
to protect our web applications from
common web exploits that could affect
application availability that could
compromise security or consume excessive
resources and wow it gives us good
control over which traffic to allow or
block to our applications by sort of
defining customizable web security rules
we can use Waf to create custom rules
that block common attack patterns such
as SQL injections or cross-site
scripting and we can also create rules
that are designed for our specific
application out of all the four identity
and access management it helps us to
control access to AWS services and
resources for our users with the
identity and access management I can
restrict user access or I can give a
user complete access to the environment
if it's an admin I can assign complete
access and if it is a user I can provide
some privileged access or less or
degraded or no access depending on the
role that the user plays in the
organization and KMS is a service that
helps us to create and control the
encryption Keys used to encrypt the data
and also we can use Hardware security
model HSM to protect the security of our
data in the cloud also we can use
Hardware security model to protect the
security of the key itself and let's
talk about the management tools and
services available in Amazon management
tools and services it helps us to manage
Monitor and automate all the resources
running in the AWS infrastructure
beginning with the cloud watch a service
which monitors the environment by
receiving logs and creating a dashboard
and sending alerts as needed and cloud
formation a service that a service
through which we can deploy new
environments using just templates and
auto scaling a product that lets us to
handle the dynamic traffic with ease by
dynamically scaling up and scaling down
the environment as needed and cloudtrail
is another product or another monitoring
tool that helps us to monitor or collect
the logs of all the APA calls to our
environment and provides a searchable
tool based on keywords and timestamps
let's talk about Cloud watch a bit more
detail now cloudwatch is a monitoring
service for AWS with Cloud watch we can
collect we can track the metrics we can
collect and monitor log files we can
also enable Cloud watch to set alarms
and automatically react to changes in
the AWS environment cloudwatch can also
monitor AWS resources such as ec2
instances dynamodb tables Amazon RDS
instances as well as custom metrics
generated by your application and
services and any log files or
applications would generate now we can
use cloudwatch to get a system-wide
visibility into resource utilization
application performance and operational
Health we can use these insights to
react and keep your applications running
smoothly and cloud formation on the
other hand provides a Common Language
for us to describe and provision all the
infrastructure resources in our Cloud
environment now cloud formation allows
us to set up and model all our AWS
resources so that we can spend less time
in managing those resources and more
time on our application our cloud
formation is really an infrastructure as
a code service where I can build an
infrastructure based on the portable
template I might be carrying all right
in this demo session we'll talk about
how to install Jenkins on Amazon Linux
ec2 instance and before that let's talk
about what is Jenkins and what is the
purpose of it why it is used and all
that stuff now what is Jenkins now
Jenkins is an open source automation
server and it provides lot of inbuilt
plugins for deploying and automating any
project in short you know it's and
continuous integration server and it is
used for many purposes used for tasks
that take care of continuous deployment
and delivery and it provides these
advantages like the developer now will
not have to focus on fixing errors
because errors are automatically handled
by Jenkins and because of that it leads
to faster development environment all
right so how do we go about doing it
let's get started the first thing is to
go to our console and launch an ec2
instance actually let me walk you
through the steps through the PPT and
then I'll show it in the console so let
me first walk you through the steps in
installing a Jenkins server in this lab
we're going to launch an VM or a virtual
application server to host our Jenkins
installation and then we are going to
deploy Jenkins on top of it and then
configure it as an build server and for
this we will need an AWS account to
begin with and then a bit of experience
in Jenkins and then some familiarity on
ec2 and how ec2 gets connected to VPC
stuff like that so when we're all done
this is how the architect is going to
look like you know users they get
connected to ec2 instance which is a
Jenkins server and then there are slaves
build slaves that can be monitored that
can be used in deployment by the Jenkins
server so let's see how it is done all
right so let's first launch a server let
it be in Amazon Linux instance I'm going
to pick T2 micro because of the free
eligibility and because this is a lab
that should be more than enough and I'm
going to keep this as default you know
I'm going to stick with the default VPC
and I'm going to keep all the settings
as defaults and then I'm not going to
add a storage I'm going to keep the
storage limited with the root volume and
then for Security Group because we're
going to access it through the internet
I would like port 80. in fact since this
is a lab environment and since I'll be
tearing it down right after the lap is
over we're going to use all IP or we're
going to use anywhere all traffic
anywhere View and launch and I already
have a keypad that I have created if
you're not familiar with creating keypad
launching ec2 instance you might need to
spend some time watching the AWS ec2
video that would help so I already have
a key pair that's attached to this
account in this region so I'm using that
keypair to launch the instance
all right then that's my Jenkins server
all right so once that is installed
let's log into it since this being an
Linux instance I'm going to use putty to
log in and then use the key pair that we
have downloaded to log in
and the key pair was
right here
all right now I'm connected to it as
first thing we will have to install the
Java environment I'm going to show some
commands towards end so if you're
planning to do Labs yourself you can use
those commands they will be very handy
in fact I can show it right now as we
speak
so these commands are to install Java
environment
and it has two versions as we speak and
I've chosen the latest version so I've
typed two and I've chosen the latest
version in installing Java environment
the second is to install Apache Maven
let me show you some commands that's
used to install Apache Maven and these
commands vary from you know Linux
version to Linux version so if you're
using a different Linux version just be
sure that you're using commands which
are respective to that particular
version all right let's install Apache
maven
looks like some of them are already
installed and it's showing error for
some but anyway it's an it's it's
considered unsuccessful installation and
then let's install Jenkins
and the commands to install Jenkins is
right here so these are to install
Jenkins and I mean to download the
software and install it and then start
the Jenkins and make sure the Jenkins
stays running even after a reboot so
let's run these commands
all right now Jenkins should be ready or
the Jenkins server is installed in our
ec2 instance and it is ready for us to
access and the default Port is port 8080
so let me go to the URL or IP so let me
go to that and then try accessing it
using port 8080.
there you go so at the moment it's
locked it requires admin password to log
in and the admin password is present in
this particular folder and this
particular file in the Linux instance
so let me get that
okay one moment looks like the admin
password is not present just give me one
quick moment
okay it's just a permission issue
let me check the password in that folder
again with the elevated permissions
there you go that's my password
all right once we're logged in we can
install all the suggested plugins
now that's going to take some time to
run and install all the selected all the
default plugins needed to run a Jenkins
server
all right it's done
now as next thing it's going to ask for
the admin username and password you can
choose as an existing administrator or
you can also create an another admin
user in this case I'm going to create
another admin user
all right so the Jenkins server is
installed we can use this similar but
slightly different procedure on the
Jenkins nodes or the slave servers to
make them Jenkins slave and respond to
the bills that we push or receive the
bills or receive the jobs that we push
through this Jenkins server so we have
built this Jenkins server on Amazon ec2
a similar and slightly different
procedures can be followed to build
Jenkins build servers that can contact
Jenkins server to receive jobs and you
know start working if you're looking for
a video that talks and walks you through
all the services in Azure then this
could be one of the best video you could
find in the internet everybody likes
story is it so let's get started with
the story in a city not so far away as
CEO had plans to expand his company
globally and called one of his ID
Personnel for an I.T opinion and this
guy has been in the company for a long
time and is very seasoned with the
companies the infra and he nicely
answered the questions with what he
foresaw and he said I have a good news
and a bad news for us to go Global and
he starts with the good news he said sir
we're well on our way to become one of
the world's largest shipping company and
the bad news is however our data centers
have almost run out of space and setting
up new ones around the world would be
too expensive and very time consuming
now the IT personnel let's call him Mike
now he explains the situation from how
he saw it but the CEO had done some
homework about how he was going to do it
and he answered Mike saying don't worry
about that Mike I've come up with a
solution for a problem and it's called
Microsoft Azure well Mike is an
hard-working and honest ID professional
working for that company but he did not
spend time on learning the latest
Technologies and he asked this question
very honestly oh how does it solve a
problem and the CEO begins to explain
Azure to Mike and he starts with what is
cloud computing and then he goes on and
talks about Azure and the service is
offered by Azure and why Azure is better
than the other Cloud providers and what
are the great companies that uses Azure
and how they got benefited out of it and
then he winds it all up with the use
cases of azure so he begins his
explanation saying Microsoft Azure is
known as the cloud service provider and
it works on the basis of cloud computing
now Microsoft Azure is formerly known as
Windows Azure and it's a Microsoft's
public cloud computing platform it also
provides a range of cloud services
including some of them are compute
analytics storage and networking we can
always pick and choose from these
services to develop and scale our
applications or even plan on running
existing applications in the public
Cloud Microsoft Azure is both a platform
as a service and infrastructure as a
service let's now fit their conversation
out and let's talk about what is cloud
computing Azure services offered by
Azure how is azure leading when compared
to other cloud service providers and
what are the companies that are using
Azure let's talk about that in simple
terms cloud computing is being able to
access compute services like servers
storage database networking software
analytics intelligence and lot more over
the Internet which is the cloud with the
flexibility of the resources that we use
like anytime I want a resource I can use
one and it becomes available immediately
and anytime if I want to retirement
results I can simply retire at resource
and not pay for it and we also typically
pay only for the services that we use
and this helps greatly with our
operating cost to run our infrastructure
more efficiently and scale our
environment up or down depending on the
business needs and changes and all the
servers and storages and databases and
networking all that are accessed through
the network of remote systems or remote
computers hosted in the internet
typically in the provider's data center
which is azure in this case now we don't
use any physical server or an
on-premises server here well we still
use physical servers and VMS you know
hosted on a hardware or a physical
server but they're all in the provider's
environment and none of them sit on
premises or in our data center we only
access them remotely it looks and feels
the same except for the fact that they
are in a remote location we access them
remotely do all the work remotely and
when we're done we can shut it down and
not pay for them so some of the use
cases some of the use cases of cloud
computing are creating applications and
services the other use cases are storing
or using Cloud for storage alone if
there is one thing that ever grows in
our organization is the storage every
new day there is a new storage
requirement and it's very Dynamic it's
very hard to predict and if we go out
and buy a big storage capacity up front
until we use the storage capacity fully
the empty storages you know we're
wasting money on them so instead I can
go for a storage with scales dynamically
that's in the Cloud put storage or put
data in the cloud and pay only for what
you are storing and for the next month
if you have deleted or flushed out some
files or data pay less for it so it's a
very Dynamic storage in the cloud and a
lot of companies are getting benefited
from storing data in the cloud because
of its dynamic in nature and the cost
that comes along with it the cheap cost
that comes along with it and also they
give a lot of the providers like Azure
they give a data application for free
they promise an SLA along with the data
we store in the cloud so there's an SLA
attached to it and they also provide
data recoveries as well if in case
something goes wrong with the physical
disk where our data is stored Azure
automatically makes our data available
from the Redundant or other places where
it had stored our data because of the
SLA they wanted to keep the other use
case for Azure is hosting websites and
running blogs using the compute service
be it storing music and letting your
users stream the music Azure is a good
place to store music and stream the
music with the benefit of CDN content
delivery Network which allows us to
stream a video or audio files with great
speed you know with that with Azure are
audio or video application works
seamlessly because they are provided to
the client with very low latency and
that improves the customer experience
for our application Azure compute
service is a good place for delivering
software on demand there are a lot of
softwares embedded softwares that we can
buy using Azure and everything on a pay
as you go service model so anytime we
need software we can go out and
immediately buy the software for the
next one hour or two hour let's say and
use them and then return it back we're
not bound to any yearly licensing cost
by that Azure Computing Services has
analytic available for us with which we
can analyze get a good visualization of
what's going on in a network be it logs
be it the performance be the metrics you
know instead of looking at logs and
searching logs and trying to do manual
things over the heaps and heaps of logs
that we have saved Azure analytics
Services helps us to get a good visual
of what's going on in the network where
have we dropped where have we increased
or what's causing what's the major
driver what is the top 10 errors that we
get in the server in the application
stuff like that those can be easily get
gathered from the Azure analytic
Services now cloud is really a very cool
term for the internet a good analogy
would be looking back anytime we look at
a diagram when we do not know how things
are transferred we simply draw a cloud
right for example a mail gets sent from
a person in one country to a person in
the other country a lot of things
happening in between from the time you
hit the send button and the time the
other person hits the read button right
and we let the simple and the easiest
way of putting it in a picture is simply
draw a cloud and on the one end one
person will be sending the email and on
the other end the other person will be
reading the email so a cloud is a really
cool term for the internet now that's
some Basics about cloud computing now
that we've understood about cloud
computing in general let's talk about
Microsoft Azure as a cloud service now
Microsoft Azure is a set of cloud
services to build manage and deploy
applications on a network with the help
of Microsoft azure's Frameworks now
Microsoft Azure is a Computing service
created by Microsoft basically for
building testing deploying and managing
applications and services through a
Global Network of Microsoft managed data
centers now Microsoft Azure provides SAS
which is software as a service and pass
which is platform as a service and IAS
infrastructure as a service and they
support many different programming
languages tools and framework and those
tools and framework include both
Microsoft specific and third-party
software now let me pick and talk about
a specific service for example
management Azure automation provides a
way for us to automate the manual long
running and frequently repeated tasks
that are commonly performed tasks both
in cloud and Enterprise environment it
saves a lot of time and increases the
reliability and it kind of gives a good
administrative control and even
schedules the task automatically to be
performed on a regular basis
to give you a quick history of Microsoft
Azure it was launched on 1st February
2010 and it was awarded or it was called
an industry leader for infrastructure
and platform as a service by Gartner now
Gartner is the world's leading research
and advisory company this Microsoft
Azure supports a number of programming
languages like c-sharp Java and python
all these School Services we get to use
and pay only for how much we use for
example if we use for an R we only get
to pay for an R even the cost list
system available if you use them for an
R we only pay for that particular R and
then we done no more billing on the
resource that we have used a Microsoft
Azure has spread itself more than 50
regions around the world so it's quite
easy for us to pick a region and you
know Start program positioning and
running our applications probably from
day one because the infrastructure and
the tools and Technologies needed to run
our application are already available
all that we have to do is comment the
code in that particular region or build
an application or launch it in that
particular region and they become live
starting day one now because we have 50
regions around the world we can very
carefully design our environment to
provide low latency services to our
customers all right instead of In
traditional data center let's say you
know customers will have to or their
requests will have to travel all the way
around the globe to reach a data center
which lives in the other side of the
planet and this adds more latency to it
and it is really not feasible to build a
data center near each customer location
because of the cost involved but with
Azure it's possible Azure already has
data centers around the world and all
that we have to do is just pick a data
center build an environment there
they're available starting day one
number one and also the cost is
considerably saved because we are using
a public Cloud instead of an physical
infrastructure to serve those customers
from a very local location and these
services that Azure is offering is ever
increasing as of now as we speak we have
like 200 plus services offered and they
span through different domain or
different platform or different
Technologies available within the Azure
console portal now we're going to talk
about that later in this section so hold
your breath till we talk about it but
for now just know that we have like 200
plus services offered by azure let's now
talk about different services in Azure
starting with artificial intelligence
plus machine learning where we have a
lot of tools and Technologies
so the wider variety of services
available in Azure includes artificial
intelligence plus machine learning plus
analytic services to get and or to give
us a good visual of how the data or how
the application is performing or the
type of the category of data stored and
to read from the logs and variety of
compute Services different VMS with
different size and different operating
systems different containers available
different type of databases available a
lot of developer tools that are
available for us and identity service to
manage our users in the Azure cloud and
those users can be integrated or
Federated with let's say Google Facebook
you know LinkedIn so they are some
external Federation Services they can be
used to integrate with our identity
system iot's iot Services iot tools and
Technologies available level and
management tools to manage the users you
know creating identities one and then
managing them on top of it is a totally
different thing and we have tools
Technologies to manage the users cool
services for a data migration data
migration is now made simple tools and
Technologies available for mobile
application a development and I can plan
my own network in the cloud with the
networking Services I can Implement my
own security both Azure provided and
third-party Security Services on Azure
Cloud that's now possible and a lot of
storage options available in the cloud
so these are just a glimpse of the big
list of services available in Azure
Cloud so that was a glimpse of what's
available in the cloud let's talk about
the services in a specific let's say
compute for example you know whenever
we're building a new new application or
deploying existing ones the Azure
compute service provides the
infrastructure we need to run and
maintain our application we can easily
tap in the capacity that Azure cloud
service has and we can scale our compute
requirement on demand we can also
containerize our application we have the
option of choosing windows or Linux via
machine and take the advantage of the
flexible options Azure provides for us
to migrate our VMS to Azure and lot more
and these compute Services also include
a full-fledged identity solution meaning
integration with active directory in the
cloud or an on-premises and lot more
let's look at some of the services that
this compute domain provides
some of the services the compute domain
provides are virtual machines and this
Azure virtual machines gives us the
ability to develop and manage a virtual
computer environment or a virtualized
environment inside azure's Cloud
environment that too in a virtual
private Network now we will talk about
virtual private Network at a later point
but as of now just know that there are a
lot of services available in Azure
compute service that we can get
benefited from we can always choose from
a very wide range of compute options for
example you know we have an option to
choose the operating system we have the
option to choose whether the system
should be in on premises or in the cloud
or do we want to maintain the
environment both in on-premises and in
the cloud we have the option of choosing
the operating system whether we want to
use our own operating system with some
soft were attached to it or do we want
to go and buy the operating system from
the cloud from Azure Marketplace and
these are just a few of the options
available for us when we want to buy the
compute environment and these complete
environments are easily scalable meaning
we can easily scale our VM instances
from one instance to thousands of
virtual machines in a matter of minutes
or simply put in a couple of button
clicks and all these services are
available on a pair for what we use
model meaning there is no upfront cost
we use the service and then pay for the
services that we have used there's no
literal or long term commitment when it
comes to using virtual machines in the
cloud and these most of the services are
built on a paper minute billing basis
all right and at no point because of the
paper minute bill selling model at no
point we will be overpaying for any of
the services that's that's attractive
isn't it now let's talk about batch
service now bat service is always
independent regardless of whether you
choose windows or Linux it's going to
run fairly well and with bad service we
can take advantage of the environment's
unique features and not only that in
short the batch service helps us to
manage the whole batch environment and
also it helps to schedule the jobs now
this Azure batch service is actually
runs on a large scale parallel and high
performance Computing because of that
batch jobs are highly efficient in Azure
and when we run batch services this
Azure batch creates a pool of computer
nodes and installs the needed
applications that we want to run and
then it schedules jobs to those
individual nodes in those pools as a
customer there is no need for us to
install a cluster or there is no need
for us to install a software that
actually can use the jobs or even to
manage or even to scale those
infrastructure or the software because
everything is managed by Azure and this
batch service is a platform as a service
there is no additional charge for using
this batch service except for I mean the
only charges that we'll be paying is for
the virtual machines that the service
uses and the storage that we will be
using of course and the networking
services that we will be using for this
batch service let's summarize this bad
service we have a choice of operating
system that we can pick and use and it
scales by itself now the alternative for
the batch would be cues but in queues
we'll have to pre-provision and pay for
the infrastructure even if we're not
using it but with a batch we only pay
for what we use and this bad service
helps us to manage the application and
manage the scheduling as a whole as if
they are just one thing as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about this
fabric service now this fabric service
is actually a distributed system
platform that helps us to package deploy
and manage a scalable and a very
reliable microservice and containers and
what does it help this Azure fabric
service helps us or it helps the
developers and administrators so they
can avoid the complex infrastructure
problems and they can focus only on
implementing workloads or taking care of
their development taking care of their
application instead of spending time on
infrastructure so what service fabric
service fabric it provides runtime
capabilities and life cycle management
two applications that are composed of
microservices no infrastructure
management at all and with service
fabric we can easily scale the
application to tens or hundreds or even
to thousands of machines here machines
represent containers as next thing in
compute domain let's talk about virtual
machine scale set now this virtual
machine scale set it lets us to create a
group of identical load balanced VMS I
just want to mention it again it helps
us to manage a group identical and load
balanced VMS the number of instances or
the number of VM instances in an in a
scale set can increase or decrease in
response to the demand or in response to
a schedule that we Define you know the
resources needed on a Monday morning is
not the same as that would be required
on a Saturday or a Sunday morning all
right and even within the day the
resources that would be needed in the
beginning of the business hour is not
the resources that would be needed at
noon or you know after eight or nine in
the evening so the demands could
actually vary in environment and this
skill set helps us to take care of the
varying demand or take care of the
different infrastructure requirement at
a different schedule throughout the day
throughout the week throughout the month
or could be throughout the year as well
the skill set also allows us to provide
High availability to our applications
and it helps us to centrally manage
configure and update a large number of
VMS as if they they are just one thing
now you might ask well virtual machines
are enough why would we need a virtual
machine skill set just like I said this
virtual machine skill set helps us with
a greater redundancy and improved
performance for our applications and
those applications can be accessed
through a load balancer that actually
distributes other requests to the
application instances so in a nutshell
this virtual machine scale set it helps
us to create a large number of identical
virtual machines number one and with
scale set we can increase or decrease
the virtual machine with virtual machine
scale said we can centrally manage and
configure and update a big group of VMS
and it's a great use case when it comes
to Big Data or container workloads as
next thing in compute domain let's talk
about cloud services now this Azure
cloud service is actually a platform as
a service and it's very friendly in fact
it is designed for applications that
support scalability or an application
that requires scalability or reliability
and and on top of it you want them to be
very inexpensive to operate so Azure
cloud service provides all these so
where would this cloud service run well
it runs on a VM but it's a platform as a
service VMS are infrastructure as a
service and when we run applications on
VM through cloud service it becomes
platform as a service so here is how you
got to be thinking with infrastructure
as a service like VMS we first create
and configure the environment and then
we run applications on top of it let's
go the responsibility the responsibility
for us in VM is that we manage
everything end to end like uh you know
deploying new patches picking the
versions of the operating system and
making sure they are intact and all that
stuff it's all managed by us but on the
contrary with platform as a service it's
I mean it's as if the environment is
already ready all that you have to do is
deploy your application in it and manage
the platform I mean manage the platform
not as an administrator because all the
administration is taken care by Azure
like you know deploying new versions of
the operating system it's all handled by
the Azure so we deploy the application
and we manage the application that's it
infrastructure management is handled by
Azure so what does cloud service provide
this cloud service provides a platform
where we can write the application code
and we don't have to worry about
Hardware simply hand over the code and
cloud service takes care of it so no
worry on the hardware at all so
responsibilities like patching what do
we do if something crashes how do I
update the infrastructure how do I
manage the maintenance or the downtime
in the underlying infrastructure all
that is handled by Azure it also
provides a good testing environment for
us you know we can simply run the code
test it before it's actually released to
the production I want to expand a bit on
these testing applications so this Azure
cloud service it actually gives us an
staging environment for testing a new
release without it affecting the
existing release which actually reduces
the customer downtime so we can run the
application test it and anytime that's
ready for production all that's needed
for us to do to move it to production is
simply to swap the staging environment
into the production environment and the
old production environment will now
become the new staging envelope
government where we can add more to it
and then swap it back at a later point
so it kind of gives us in swappable
environment for testing our applications
and not only that it gives us Health
monitoring alerts it helps us to monitor
the health and availability of our
application and there is a dashboard we
can benefit from when we use Azure cloud
services and that shows the key
statistics all in one place and we can
also set up real-time alerts to one when
a service availability or a certain
metrics that we are concerned about
degrades as next thing in compute domain
let's talk about functions now functions
are serverless Computing you know many
times if you heard about Azure being
serverless a lot of time they are
referencing or the person who's talking
to you is referencing to serverless
Computing or Azure functions which is a
serverless Computing service hosted on
Microsoft Azure the main motive of a
function is to accelerate and simplify
application development functions helps
us to run code on demand without we need
to pre-provision or manage any Azure
infrastructure so Azure functions are
script or a piece of code that gets run
in response to an event that you want to
handle so in short we can just write a
code that you need for a problem at hand
without actually worrying about the
whole application or the infrastructure
that will be running that code and the
best of all the best is when we use
functions we only pay for the time that
our code runs so what does functions
provide or what is azure functions
provide Azure functions allow users to
build applications using serverless a
simple functions with a programming
language of our choice so the current
programming languages that are supported
is C Sharp F sharp node.js the Java and
PHP so here we really don't have to
worry about provisioning or maintaining
in service if a code requires more
resource yes Azure functions handles or
it provides the additional resources
needed by the court and the best part is
we only pay for the amount of time the
functions are running not the resources
but the amount of time the function is
running as next thing and moving to the
new domain let's talk about the
container domain in Azure now the
container domain or the container
service it allows us to quickly deploy a
production ready kubernetes or a Docker
swarm cluster now what's a container a
container is a standard unit of software
that packages of code and all its
dependencies so the applications run
quickly and reliably from one Computing
environment to another it could be a
testing to staging to developing
development environment to staging to
production or from one production to
another production or on premises to
cloud or One Cloud to another Cloud vice
versa now imagine we had an option not
to worry about the VM and just focus on
the application well that's exactly what
containers helps us achieve so these
container instances enable us to focus
on applications and not worrying about
managing VMS or not worrying about the
learning the new tools required to
manage the VMS or even the deployment
and our applications that we create they
run in a container running in a
container is what helps us to achieve
all these not being able to manage or
not needing to manage the virtual
machines so these containers they can be
deployed into the cloud using a single
command if you're using command line
interface and a couple of button clicks
if we are using the Azure portal and
these containers are kept lightweight
but they are equally secure as virtual
machines let's talk about container
service as next thing the container
service or or sometimes called as Azure
kubernetes service it helps us to manage
the containers containers one thing and
a service that's used to manage the
container is another thing now this
kubernetes service or ACS it helps us to
manage the containers so let's expand on
this a bit so this Azure container
service or ACS it actually provides a
way to simplify the creation
configuration and management of a
cluster of virtual machines that are
pre-configured to run containerized
applications on top of them now
deploying them deploying these
containers might take like 15 to 20
minutes or deploying the virtual
machines that run containers in it might
take 15 to 20 minutes and once they are
provisioned we can actually manage them
by using simple SSH tunnel into them and
this ACS when it runs application it
runs applications from Docker images
what does that mean a Docker images
makes sure that at the applications the
container runs are fully portable images
are portable and ACS also helps us to
orchestrate the container environment
not only that it also helps us to ensure
that these applications that we run in
containers can be scaled to thousands or
even tens of thousands of containers so
in a nutshell managing an existing
application into a container and running
it using AKs or ACS is really easy or
that's what it is all about to make the
application management or migration easy
now managing the container based
architecture and we discussed that a
containers could be tens or even tens of
thousands of containers so managing them
is Made Simple using this container
services and even training of model
using a large data set in a complex and
resource intensive environment this AKs
helps us to simplify that environment
all right as next thing in contain in a
domain let's talk about container
registry we spoke about registry a
little bit when we spoke about Docker
images so container registry is a single
place where we can store our images
which are Docker images when we use when
we use containers it's it's Docker
images that we use for our image
purposes so these container images are a
central registry that can be used to
ease container development by easing the
storage and management of container
images so there we can store all kind of
images like Docker swarm are the images
used in Docker swarm or in kubernetes
everything can be stored in container
registry in Azure now anytime we store a
container image it provides us an option
for geo replication what that means is
that we can efficiently manage a single
registry replicated across multiple
regions now these Geo replication and it
actually enables us to manage Global
deployments assuming we are having an
environment that requires a global
deployment so it helps us to manage
Global deployments as one entity because
we are Geo replicating we would be
updating we would be editing one image
and that image gets replicated
throughout the global replication
centers we would have set up and so just
one editing would have actually edited
the global images and those global
images will have provisioned the global
application so one edit replication and
then posting of the applications Global
wide and this replication also helps us
to helps us Network latency because you
know anytime an application needs to
deploy it does not have to rely on a
single source which which can be reached
only through high latency Network
because we have Global replications
around the world anytime the application
wants to check back it would check back
uh the application which is in a very
nearby location for the application
itself Global replication means that we
are managing it as a single entity
that's being replicated across the
multiple regions in the globe has next
thing in a learning let's talk about
Azure databases now this Azure databases
are a rational in fact they have many
flavors in them we're going to look at
different uh flavors or SQL nosql cache
type of database that Azure offers so
we're going to learn one at a time or
we're going to learn one by one so this
Azure SQL database is a rational
database in fact it's a rational
database as a service it's managed by
Azure we don't get to do a lot of
management in it so it's a rational
database as a service based on Microsoft
SQL Server database engine and this
database is a high performance database
it's very Bible and it's very secure as
well and this High reliability high
performance and for this high security
we really don't have to do anything it
comes along with it and it's managed by
Azure and there are two things that I
definitely need to mention about Azure
SQL database that is it's an intelligent
service number one it's fully managed by
Azure and it also has this one good
thing which is it has built-in
intelligence that learns app patterns
and adapts to maximize performance and
reliability and data protection of the
application that's something that's not
found in many of the other Cloud
providers that I'm aware of so I thought
I'll mention it so it uses built-in
intelligence to learn about the user's
database patterns and helps improve
performance and protection and migration
or importing data is very easy when it
comes to Azure SQL database so it can be
readily or immediately used for analytic
reporting and intelligent applications
in Azure as next thing let's talk about
Azure Cosmo DB now Azure Cosmo DB is a
database service that is for nosql type
and it's it's created to provide low
latency and an application that scales
dynamically or that scales rapidly now
this Azure cosmodb is an a globally
distributed service
and it's a multi-modal database this can
be provisioned in a click of a button
that's all we got to do if we need to
provision and Azure Cosmo DB in the
Azure it helps with scaling the database
now we can elastically and independently
scale throughput and storage across this
database and in any of the Azure
geographic regions it provides a good
throughput it provides good latency it
provides good availability and it
provides our Azure promises a
comprehensive SLA that no other database
can offer that's the best part about
cosmodb so this Cosmo DB was built with
a global distribution in mind and it's
built with the horizontal scale in mind
and all this we can use by only paying
for what we have used and remember the
difference between Azure Cosmo DB and
the SQL database is that Azure Cosmo DB
supports nosql whereas SQL doesn't all
right few other things about Azure Cosmo
DB is it allows users to use key value
graph column family and document data it
also gives users a number of AP options
like SQL JavaScript mongodb and and few
others that you might want to check in
the document at the time of reading and
the best part here is that all that we
mentioned we get to use only by paying
for the amount of storage and throughput
that are required and the storage and
the throughput can be elastically scaled
based on the requirement of that Arc all
right let's talk about redis cache
discussion about Azure database won't be
complete without we talking about
released cache now redis cache is a
secure data cache it's also called it's
also sometimes called as messaging
broker that provides high throughput and
low latency access to data for the
applications now redis cache is based on
an popular open source caching product
which is redis sometimes called as there
is cash now what's the use case it's
typically used to Cache to improve the
performance and scalability of a system
that rely heavily on back-end data
stores now performance when we use redis
cache is improved by temporarily copying
the frequently accessed data to a fast
storage located very close to the
application now with redis cache this
fast storage is located in memory with
redis cache instead of being loaded from
the actual disk in the database itself
now this redis Cache can also be used as
an in-memory data structure store not
only that it can be used as a
distributed non-relational database and
a message broker so there are variety of
use cases for this various cache and by
using various cache the application
performance is improved by taking
advantage of the low latency and the
height throughput performance that this
redis cache engine provides so to
summarize this redis cache when we use
redis cache data is stored in the memory
instead of the disk to ensure that there
is high throughput and low latency when
the application needs to read the data
it provides various levels of scaling
without any downtime or interference now
this various cache is actually backed by
Redux server and it supports a string
hashes linked list and various other
data structures now let's talk about
security and identity Services now
identity management in specific is a
process of authenticating first and then
authorizing using security principles
now not only that identity management
involves controlling information about
those principal identities you might ask
now what's a principal identity now
Identity or principal identity are
Services applications users groups and a
lot more the specialty about this
identity management is that it not only
helps authenticate and authorize
principles in Cloud it also helps
authenticate and authorize principles or
resources on premises especially when
you run an hybrid Cloud environment so
all these services and features that
this identity management helps us to get
additional level of validation like
identity management can provide
multi-factor authentication it can
provide access policies based on
condition a permit or deny based on
condition it can also monitor suspicious
activity and not only that it can also
report it it can also help generate
alerts for potential security issues and
in a way to mitigate it can send us an
alert so we can get involved and prevent
and security accident from happening so
let's talk more about identity
management so some of the services under
security and identity G management or
Azure security center now this Azure
security Center provides Security
Management and threat protection across
the workloads in both cloud and in the
hybrid environment it helps control user
access and application control to stop
any malicious activity if present it
helps us to find and fix vulnerabilities
before they can be even exploited it
integrates very well with analytic
methods that helps us to identify or it
gives us the intelligent to identify or
deduct attacks and prevent them before
it can actually happen and it also works
seamlessly with hybrid environments so
you don't have to have one policy for
on-premises and one policy for the cloud
it's now a Unified Service both for
on-premises and the cloud the next
service in security and identity would
be keyboard now a key vault is a service
or a feature that help Safeguard the
cryptographic keys and any other Secrets
used by the cloud applications and the
services in other words this Azure key
vault is a tool for securely storing and
accessing the secrets of the environment
I mean the secret Keys now a secret is
anything that you really want to have a
very tight control access like the
certificates like the passwords stuff
like that now if I tell you what keyword
actually solves that would actually
explain what keyword is now key vault is
used in Secrets management it's helped
in securely storing The Tokens The
passwords the certificates it helps in
Key Management and it really helps in
creating and controlling the encryption
keys that we would use to encrypt data
it helps in certificate management
talking about the certification
management it helps us to easily
provision manage and deploy pop public
and private SSL TLS certificates in
Azure and lot more so in a nutshell this
key wall it provides users the ability
to provision new walls and keys in just
a matter of minutes all that in a single
command or all that in a couple of
button clicks it also helps users to
centrally manage their Keys Secrets and
policies next in the list let's talk
about Azure active directory now Azure
active directory it helps us to create
intelligent driven access policies to
limit resource usage and manage user
identities but what does that mean now
this Azure active directory is a
cloud-based active directory and
identity management service now Azure
active directory combines and it's
actually a combination of the core
directory Services Plus application
access management plus identity
protection and and one good thing about
this Azure in fact there are a lot of
good things but especially when you're
running hybrid environments you might
wonder well how does Azure active
directory is going to behave now this
Azure active directory is built to work
on on-premises and Cloud environment as
well not only that it also works
seamlessly with mobile applications as
well so in a nutshell this Azure active
directory it acts as an central point of
identity and access management for our
Cloud environment it also provides good
Security Solutions that protect against
unauthorized access of our app and the
data now that we have discussed about
security and identity let's talk about
the management tools that Azure has to
offer Azure provides built-in management
and account governance tools that helps
administrators and developers that helps
them to keep their resources secure and
very compliant and again it helps both
in on-premises and in the cloud
environment and these management tools
help us to monitor the infrastructure
monitor the applications it also helps
in provisioning and configuring
resources it also helps in updating apps
it helps in analyzing threats taking
backup of the resources build a disaster
recoveries it also helps in applying
policies and conditions to automate our
environment we use Azure management
tools and it's also used in cost control
methods so this Azure management plays a
wide role across the Azure services and
in the management tools first comes the
Azure advisor now this Azure advisor it
acts as a guide to educate us about
Azure best practices it throws
recommendations that we can select on
the basis of the category of service and
it also provides the impact it can have
or the impact that will happen in our
environment if we follow the
recommendations given and
recommendations or first one is the
recommendations are kind of templatized
and it throws the templatized
recommendations not only that it also
provides customized recommendations on
the basis of the configuration on the
basis of our usage patterns and these
recommendations are not Parts it's not
like something that it recommends and
then just leaves us hanging there these
recommendations provided are very easy
to follow very easy to implement and see
results you can think of azure advisor
as an a Very personalized Cloud
consultant that helps you to follow best
practices to optimize our deployments it
kind of analyzes our resources our
configurations our usage and then it
recommends a solution for us that really
helps in improving the cost
Effectiveness improving the performance
improving High availability and
improving Security in our Azure
environment so with this Azure advisor
we can get a proactive actionable and
personalized best practice
recommendations now you don't have to be
an expert just follow the Azure advisor
and your environment is going to be good
it also helps in improve the performance
security High availability of our
environment and also it helps in
bringing down the overall Azure spend
and the best part is it's a free service
that analyzes our Azure use message and
provides recommendations how we can
optimize our Azure resource to reduce
cost and reduce cost at the same time
boost the performance helps in
strengthening the security and improve
the overall reliability of our
environment and next in the list would
be Network Watcher now this network
Watcher helps users identify and gain
insights in the overall Network
performance and the health of the
overall environment now these Azure
Watchers provides enough tools to
monitor to diagnose to view the metrics
and to enable or disable logs which
means it will generate and collect the
logs for resources in the Azure virtual
Network so with network Watcher can
monitor and diagnose issues in
networking without even logging into the
virtual machines with just the logs
which are real time we can actually come
to a conclusion what could be wrong in a
certain resource in a VM or in a
database you know but just looking at
the logs and not only that it's used for
analytic or to gain some intelligence of
what's happening in our Network we can
again a lot of insight to the current
Network traffic pattern using the
security group flow logs that this
network Watcher offers it also helps in
investigating VPN connectivity issues
using detailed logs now you might or
might not know that you know VPN
troubleshooting requires both parties or
it involves two parties another person
the network administrator on this side
and the network administrator on the
other side and they will have to check
logs in their end and we'll have to
check logs and over and stuff like that
but with the network Watcher it kind of
takes it to the next level the logs
itself we could easily identify which
side is having the issue and suggest an
appropriate fix and the next in the list
would be Microsoft Azure portal now this
Microsoft Azure portal it provides a
single unified console to perform
various number of activities like
building not only building managing and
monitoring the web applications that we
build now this portal can be used to
organize our environment or the
appearance of the environment or the
visual of the environment based on our
work style and using Azure portal users
can control who gets to manage or access
the resources all from the Azure portal
and this Azure portal gives a very good
visibility on the spends that happen on
each resource right and if we can
customize it we can also identify spends
based on teams spends based on days
spends based on Department stuff like
that so it kind of gives us a good
visual offer where the money is spending
or whereas the bill consumed within the
Azure environment next in the list would
be Azure a resource manager now Azure
resource manager enables us to manage
the usage of the application resources
now we use resource manager to deploy
Monitor and manage solution resources as
a group as if it's one single entity now
the infrastructure of our application is
typically made of various components
which includes virtual machine storage
virtual Network web app database servers
some other third-party services that we
might use in our environment and they
are by nature separate services but with
Azure resource manager we don't see them
as different components or different
entities instead we see them as related
services in a group that supports an
application now we kind of get the
relation between them instead of you
know letting them spread Azure results
manager identifies the relation between
them and helps us to visually see them
all as one or single entity not only
that Azure resource manager helps or it
ensures that the resources that we
provision or deploy at a constant rate
along with the other application it also
helps users to visually see their
resources and how they are connected and
that helps in managing the resources a
lot better resource Group also is used
to control who can access the resources
within the user's organization kind of
gives you the fine grained control over
who gets to access and who does not get
access and the last one in the
management tools would be Automation and
this automation gives us the ability to
automate configure and install upgrades
across hybrid environments it provides a
cloud-based Automation and configuration
service not only that this can be
applied for non-azure environments as
well which is on-premises so some of the
automation we could do is process
automation update management automation
configuration features automation stuff
like that and this Azure automation
provides complete control during the
deployment operation and also during the
decommissioning of the workloads and
resources with automation we can
actually automate a time consuming or
mundane or any task that's error prone
because of human errors those things can
be automated so irrespective of how many
times you run it it's going to run the
same way and that really helps in
reducing the overall time and also the
overhead cost because a lot of the
things are automated which means it's
human error-free which means the
application is not going to break and
keep running for a longer time with
automation we can actually build a good
inventory of operating system resources
and configuration items all in one place
with ease and this really helps in
tracking the changes and investigating
the issue let's say something happened
because we have automation because it's
logging the configuration changes it's
easy to track easy to identify easy to
identify what has changed lately that
has broken the environment go back and
fix it or kind of roll it back that
solves the problem and that actually
summarizes the Azure management tools or
Management Services now let's talk about
the networking tools or the networking
services available in Azure there are
variety of services especially
networking services that Azure offers
and I'm sure it's going to be an
interesting one let's begin our
discussion with content delivery Network
now the content delivery Network in
short CDN it allows us to perform secure
and a very reliable content delivery not
only that it also helps in accelerating
the delivery time or in other words
reducing the delivery time also called
as low times it also helps in Saving
bandwidth and increases in
responsiveness to the application so
let's expand on this the content
delivery network is actually a
distributed network of servers that can
efficiently deliver web content to users
now cdns are we going to use the word
CDN here cdns store cached content on
global Edge servers also called as pops
point of presence locations that are
very close to the end users so the
latency is minimized it's like taking a
copy of the data or taking multiple copy
of the data and storing it in different
parts of the world and whoever is
requesting it the data gets delivered to
them from a server which is very locally
to them so this CDN offers developers a
global solution for rapidly delivering
high bandwidth content to users by
caching the content in a strategically
placed location which is very near to
them so these content delivery networks
it really helps in handling that's one
advantage you get for Content delivery
Network that's we can handle spikes and
heavy loads very efficiently and we can
also run analytic against the logs that
gets generated in content delivery
Network which helps in gaining good
Insight on the workflow and what would
be the future business need for that
application and this just like a lot of
other services this is on a pay as you
go type so you use the results first and
then you only pay for what you have used
the next one in networking would be
expressed route now express route is
actually circuit or a link that provides
an a direct private connection to Azure
and because it's direct it gives low
latency link to Azure it gives good
speed and reliability for the Azure data
transfer it could be on premises to
Azure so it gives very good speed it
gives increased reliability and low
latency for that connection let's expand
on this a bit now this express route is
in service that actually provides a
private connection between Microsoft
Data Center and infrastructure in our
premises or in a different co-location
facility that we might have now these
Express routes do not go over the public
internet and because they don't go over
the public internet they offer a high
security reliability and speed and low
latency compared to the connections
which are in the the internet because
it's fast because it's reliable because
it has low latency it can be used as an
extension of our existing data center
you know users are not going to feel the
difference whether they are accessing
services from an on-premises or in the
cloud environment because latency is
minimized as much as possible users are
really not going to see the difference
and because it's a private line and not
an public internet line it can be used
to build hybrid applications without
compromising a privacy or at the
performance now these virtual private
Cloud these expressed routes can be used
for taking backups if assume a backup
going through the internet that would be
a nightmare if you use express route for
backups that's going to be fast and
imagine recovering a data through the
internet from the cloud through the
internet to the on-premises in a time of
disaster that would be the worst
nightmare so these Express routes can be
used not only to backup but also recover
the data because it provides good speed
low latency recurring the data is going
to be a lot sooner the next product or
service or we're going to discuss in
networking is azure DNS now Azure DNS
allows us to host domain name in Azure
and these domain names come with an
exceptional performance and availability
now Azure DNS is used to set up and
manage DNS zones and records for our
domain name in the cloud now this Azure
DNS is a service for DNS just like the
name says and it provides name
resolution by using azure's
infrastructure and by using this domain
we can actually manage the DNS our cells
through the Azure portal with the same
credential imagine having a DNS provider
which does not even belong in RIT
imagine that environment you know we
would have a separate portal to manage
the DNS environment now those are gone
and now we can actually manage the DNS
in the very same Azure portal where we
use the rest of the other services and
this Azure DNS very much integrates with
other DNA service providers it uses a
Global Network of name servers to
provide fast response to DNS queries and
these domains are having additional
availability compared to the other
domain service providers availability
promises these are going to have more
availability than the rest because most
of the servers are maintained by a
Microsoft and it helps resolve sooner it
helps resyncing let's say a server fails
it kind of helps resyncing with the rest
of the servers so all the Microsoft's
environment all the Microsoft's Global
Network of name servers kind of ensures
that our domain names are resolved
properly not only properly but also are
available most of the time right next in
the list in networking Services is
virtual Network I'm sure this is going
to be very interesting and I'm sure
you're gonna like it so this networking
or virtual networking in Azure it
actually allows us to set up our own
private cloud in the public Cloud it
gives us an isolated and highly secure
environment for our application let's
expand on this then this Azure virtual
Network helps us to provision Azure
virtual machines and it helps us to
securely communicate with other
on-premises and internet networks it
also helps in controlling the traffic
that flows through or Flows In and Out
of This virtual Network to other virtual
networks and to the internet now this
Azure virtual Network sometimes called
as v-net is actually a representation of
our own network in the cloud it's
actually a logical isolation of the
Azure Cloud dedicated to our
subscription all our environments are
provisioned in a v-net that is separate
from another customer's witness that way
we have that logical separation there so
this virtual Network can also be used to
provision our vpns in the cloud so we
can connect the cloud and the
on-premises infrastructure and lot more
especially in a environment where we
have hybrid environment surely we will
be using virtual Network because that's
going to require a VPN for secure data
transfer in and out of the cloud and in
and out of the on-premises environment
alright so it kind of gives us an
boundary for all the resources so all
the traffic between the Azure resources
the kind of logically stay in between or
logically stay within the Azure virtual
Network and here we can design the
network is given over to us you know you
can pick the IP you can pick the routing
you can pick the subnet and a lot of
freedom is given or I would say a lot of
control on how the network is designed
it's not like something that's already
cooked and we only get to use it no we
can actually build the network from the
scratch we can pick the IP address that
we like we can pick you know which
subnet needs to communicate with the
other subnets stuff like that and like I
said if you are using hybrid environment
you definitely would be requiring a
virtual Network because it helps connect
the on-premises and the cloud in a
secure fashion using VPN the last
product we're going to discuss and
networking is a load balancer this load
balancer actually provides application a
good availability and a good Network
performance so how does it work it
actually works by load balancing the
traffic to and from the virtual machine
and the cloud resources not only that it
also load balances between cloud and
cross premises virtual networks with
Azure load balancer we can actually
scale our application and create high
availability for our services which
means Our obligation will be available
most of the time if any of the server
goes dead the server does not get
traffic what happens if the server gets
traffic user is going to experience
downtime what happens if the server does
not get traffic user won't experience
any downtime the connection is shifted
to an healthy service so the user
experiences uptime all the time so this
load balancer supports inbound and
outbound scenarios and it provides low
latency it gives high throughput of the
data transfer and we can actually scale
up the flow of the TCP and UDP
connections from hundreds to thousands
to even Millions because we have a load
balancer now in between the user and the
application so how does it operate this
load balancer actually receives the
traffic and it load balances the traffic
to the back end pool of instances
connected to it according to the rule
and the health probe that we set that's
how it maintains High availability so
what does load balancer help it helps in
creation of high available scalable
application in the cloud in minutes it
can be used to automatically scale the
environment with the increasing
application traffic and one feature of
load balancer is to check the health of
the user's application instance and it
removes or it stops sending the request
to the unhealthy instance and kind of
shifts that connection to the healthy
instance that way a user or a connection
does not get stuck with an instance
That's not healthy that's all that you
need to know about the networking
Services now let's talk about the
storage services or the storage domain
in Azure now Azure storage in general is
a Microsoft manage service providing
cloud storage which basically is highly
available secure durable scalable and
redundant because it's all managed by
Azure we don't get to manage a lot of it
and these Azure storages are a group of
storage Services they cater different
needs and the storage products include
Azure blobs which is actually an object
storage it includes Azure data Lake it
includes Azure files as you see it it
includes Azure queues it includes Azure
tables and lot more but let's start our
discussion with Azure store simple Azure
store simple is an hybrid cloud storage
solution that actually lowers the cost
of storage to nearly 60 percent of how
much you would be actually spending
without using it so Azure simple storage
or store simple is an integrated storage
solution that manages the storage task
between on-premises and the cloud
storage what I really like about Azure
is that it's built around the hybrid
environment in mind there are a lot of
other Cloud providers that are there
where running and hybrid environment is
a big challenge you know it has some
compatibility you won't be able to find
an hybrid or a on-premises and Cloud
solution for your need stuff like that
but with Azure especially when it comes
to storage a lot of the things that
we're going to see it clearly is
designed with hybrid environment in mind
all right so let's come back and talk
about store simple so store simple is an
very efficient cost effective and a very
easily manageable sand storage area
networking solution in the cloud I
thought I'll throw in this information
the reason why it got store simple is
really because it uses store simple 8000
series devices which are used in Azure
Data Center and this store simple or
simple storage it comes along with
storage sharing to manage the stored
data across the various storage media so
the current the very current data is
actually stored in on-premises on solid
state drives and data that is used less
frequently is stored in hdds or hard
disk drives and the data that requires
archived or that needs to be archived
very old data let's say less frequently
use data candidate for archive they are
actually pushed to the cloud so you see
how this storage tearing automatically
happens in store simple and one another
cool feature of store simple is that it
enables us to create an on-demand and
scheduled backups of data and and then
store the data locally or in the cloud
and these backups are actually taken in
the form of of incremental snapshot
which means that they can be created and
restored quickly it's not a complete
backup it's an incremental backup and
these Cloud snapshots they can be
critically important when there is a
disaster and when there is a disaster
recovery scenario because these
snapshots can be called in and they can
be put on storage systems and then they
become the actual data so recovering is
faster if you have proper scheduled
backups or if you have frequent backups
and this storage simple it really helps
in easing our backup mechanism which
means it kind of easers our Disaster
Recovery steps or procedures as well so
the store simple it can be used to
automate data management data migration
data movement data Turing across the
Enterprise both in cloud and on-premises
it actually improves the compliance and
accelerates the disaster recovery for
our environment and if there is one
thing that's increasing every new day in
our environment that will be storage and
this stores simple addresses that need
and we really don't have to pre-plan or
think in deep or having a proper storage
because now we have a simple storage
available in the cloud and moreover it's
on a pay-as-you-go type so not much free
planning on storage is needed yes there
will be a need but not as much as I
would without the cloud or without the
simple storage and the next service
under storage that we would like to
discuss is the data Lake store this data
Lake store or storage it's a cost
effective solution for big data
analytics in specific so let's expand
this so this is data Lake storage is an
enterprise-wide repository for big data
analytic workload now that's the major
service that's dependent on this data
Lake store and this data Lake enables us
to capture data of any size of any type
and of any injection speed and it kind
of collects them in one single space or
in one single place for operational
efficiency I mean operational efficiency
and for analytic purpose Hadoop in Azure
is very dependent on this data Lake
storage and this data Lake store is
designed with performance for analytics
in mind so anytime you think of or
anytime you're using analytic in the
cloud or anytime you're using Hadoop in
the cloud in Azure we are definitely
using or we will be to the most part or
the normal procedure or the Right
Storage to pick would be data Lake store
in Azure it's designed with security in
mind so anytime we use Azure storage we
can be rest assured that we are using
storage from within a data center which
has or which was built with security in
mind so this data store also uses Azure
blob storage behind the scenes for for
global scale durability and for
performance let's talk about blob
storage now blob storage provides large
amount of storage and scalability now
this blob storage is the object storage
solution for Azure Cloud let's expand a
bit on blob storage Azure blob storage
is Microsoft offering for object storage
now this blob storage is optimized for
storing massive amount of unstructured
data which could be text or binary data
it's designed and it's optimized for
Rapid reads if I explain to you on what
scenarios we would be using blob storage
that might help you get a good
understanding of what blob storage is so
it's help or its design as of now it's
being used in many ID environments to
serve images or documents directly to
the browser it helps in storing files
for distributed access a lot of Fetchers
can fetch data from Azure blob storage
and it currently helping users stream
video and audio it's currently being
used for writing log files it's
currently being used to store data as
backup and restore at a later point in
times of Disaster Recovery it also is
used as an archiving storage in a lot of
cloud ID environments it's widely used
in storing analytic data not only
storing but also running analytic query
against the data stored in it so that's
a wide use case for blob storage not
only that in addition to all that we
mentioned it also supports versioning so
anytime somebody updates an data a new
version gets created which means at any
point I can roll back as and when needed
and it provides a lot of flexibility on
optimizing the user's storage need it
also supports tearing of the data So
based on need when I actually explore I
would find a lot of options I can pick
from that you know know suits to my
unique storage environment or unique
storage need and like I said it stores
unstructured data and this unstructured
data is available for customers through
rest based object storage environment
the next product and storage service
would be queue storage now queue storage
provides durable queues for large volume
cloud services it's a very simple and a
cost effective durable messaging queue
for large workers let's expand this
queue storage for a moment now this
queue storage is a service for storing
large amount of messages that can be
accessed from anywhere in the world
through HTTP and https calls a single
queue or a single Cube message can be up
to like 24 KB in size and a single queue
can contain millions of such 24 KB in
size messages and how much can it hold
it can hold up to the total capacity of
the storage account itself so that's
kind of easy to translate How much would
it hold and this Azure Q storage it
provides an messaging solution between
applications and components in the cloud
what does it help it helps in designing
an application for scale it helps in
decoupling in the application so you
know it's not very dependent or
sometimes it's not at all dependent on
the other application because now we
have a queue in between which kind of
translates or which kind of connects or
which kind of decouples both the
environment now we have a queue in
between both the environment can scale
up or scale down independently the next
in the storage service would be file
storage let's talk about file storage
now these Azure files provide secure
simple and managed Cloud file shares now
with file share in the cloud it actually
extends the user servers on-premises
performance and capacity and lot of
familiar tools for the cloud file share
management can be used along with the
file storage that we're talking about so
let's expand a bit on file storage now
this Azure files or Azure file storage
offers a fully managed file shares in
the cloud that can be accessed via the
SMB protocol server message block
protocol now this Azure file shares can
be mounted concurrently by cloud or in
on-premises deployments a lot of
operating systems are compatible with it
windows are compatible Linux is
compatible Mac OS is compatible in an
addition to all this being able to run
on on-premises and on the cloud or being
able to access from on-premises and on
the cloud it can also offer cash for
caching the data and keeping it locally
so it's immediately available when
needed so that's some additional feature
I would say that some Advanced feature
that it offers compared to the other
file shares available in the market
let's talk about table storage let's
talk about table storage now table
storage is a nosql key value pair
storage for quick deployments with the
large semi-structured data sets the
difference between one important thing
to note with table storage is that it
has a flexible data schema and also it's
highly available let's expand a bit on
table storage so anytime you want to
pick a schema less a nosql type table
storage is the one we'll end up picking
it provides an key pair attribute
storage with a schema less design this
table storage is very fast and very cost
effective for many of the applications
and for the same amount of data it's a
lot cheaper when you compare it with the
traditional SQL data or data storage so
some of the things that we can store in
the table storage are are of course
they're going to be flexible data sheets
such as user data for web application
address books device information and
other types of metadata for our service
requirements and it can have any number
of tables up to the capacity limit of
the storage account now this is not
possible with SQL this is only possible
with nosql especially with table storage
in Azure explanation of storage really
concluded the length and breadth of the
explanation this CEO was giving his ID
personal but this ID personal is not
done with it yet he still has a question
even after this lengthy discussion and
his question was well there are a lot of
other Cloud providers available what
made you specifically choose Azure I
mean from the kind of question that he
asked we can say that he is very curious
and he definitely had asked and very
thoughtful question so his CEO went on
and started to explain about the other
capabilities of azure or how it kind of
outruns the rest of the cloud providers
so he started or he again started his
discussion but from a different angle
now so he started to explain what are
the capabilities or how Azure is better
than the competitor so he started with
explaining the platform as a service
capabilities and I'm going to tell you
what the CEO told his ID person so this
platform as a service or in platform as
a service the infrastructure management
is completely taken care by Microsoft
allowing users to focus completely on
the innovation no more infrastructure
management responsibilities go and focus
on Innovation that's that's a fancy way
of saying it when we buy platform as a
service that's what we get we can
contribute our time on Innovation and
not just maintaining the infrastructure
and azure especially is dotnet friendly
Azure supports the dotnet programming
language and it has or it is built or
designed or it is optimized to work with
old and the new applications deployed
using.net programming framework so if
your application is dot net most of the
time you would end up picking Azure I
mean if you try to compare most of the
time you would end up picking Azure as
your cloud service provider and the
security offerings that Azure offers is
it's designed based on the security
development life cycle which is an
industry leading Assurance process when
we buy services from Azure it assures
that the environment is designed based
on security development life cycle and
like I mentioned many times in the past
and I would like to mention it again
Azure has well thought about the hybrid
environments which a lot of other Cloud
providers have failed so it's very easy
to set up an hybrid environment to
migrate the data or not to migrate the
data and still run a hybrid environment
they work seamlessly with the Azure
because Azure provides seamless
connection across on-premises data
centers and the public Cloud it also has
a very gentle learning curve if you look
at the documentation it's picture rich
and the documentations are neat and
clear with really it would encourage you
to learn more it will encourage you to
think and imagine and try easily get a
grasp of how Services work so it has a
very gentle learning curve Azure allows
the utilization of technologies that
several business have used for years so
there is a big history behind it it has
a very gentle learning curve the
certifications the documentations the
stage by stage certification levels it's
all very gentle learning curve which is
generally missing in other clouds
service providers now this would really
impress the ctOS or people working in
finance and budgeting if an organization
is already using Microsoft software they
can definitely go and Avail or be bold
and ask for a discount that can reduce
the overall Azure spending in other
words overall a pricing of the Azure so
that's what helped or they are the
information that helped the CEO pick
Azure as his cloud service provider and
then the CEO goes on and talks about the
different companies that are currently
using Azure and they are definitely
using Azure for a reason like Pixar
Boeing Samsung EasyJet Xerox BMW 3M they
are major multinational multi-billion
companies they rely run operate their ID
in Azure and this CEO has a thought that
his it person is still not very
convinced unless and until he shows him
a visual of how easy things are in Azure
so he goes on and explains about a
practical application of azure which is
what exactly I'm going to show you as
well all right a quick project on
building an Azure app using or building
a dotnet application in Azure web app
and making it connect to an SQL database
will solidify all the knowledge that we
have gained so far so this is what we're
gonna do I have an Azure account open as
you see logged in and everything is
fresh here let me go to Resource Group
there's nothing in there it's it's kind
of fresh all right I'm logged in and
this is what we're gonna do so we're
going to create an application like this
which is nothing but an to-do
application a to-do list application
we're just going to run from the web app
get information from us and save it in
the database that's connected to it so
you can already see it's a two-tier
application web and DB all right so let
me go back to my Azure account the first
thing is to create and Resource Group
let's give it an a meaningful name let's
call it Azure simply learn all right and
it's going to be a free trial and the
location pick one that's nearest to you
or you know wherever you want to launch
your application now for this use case
I'm going to pick Central us and create
it's going to take a while to get
created there you go it's created it's
called Azure simply learn now what do we
need we need an web app and and a
separate SQL database let's first get
our web app running so go to app
services and then click on ADD it's not
the web app plus SQL that we want we
want web app alone for this example so
let's create a web app give it a quick
name let's call it azure
simply learn
the subscription is free trial and I'm
going to use my existing Resource Group
a resource Group that we created some
time back it's going to run out of
Windows and we're going to publish the
code all set we can create it all right
while this is running let me create my
database
right SQL database create a database
give it a name let's call it Azure
simply learn DB
put it in our existing Resource Group
that we created it's going to be a blank
database all right and it's going to
require some settings like the name of
the server and the admin login the
password that goes along and in which
location this is going to be created the
server name is going to be Azure simply
learn DB that's the server name and the
admin login can be what can be the admin
login name let's see
so let's call it simply learn that's my
admin login name
and let me pick a password
click on create so what have we done so
far we have created an web app and we
have created an a database in the
resource Group that we have created so
if I go to Resource Group it's going to
take some time before things show up so
if I go to my Resource Group I only have
one Resource Group as of now Azure
simply learn and there I have a bunch of
resources being created and I'll still
being created all right in the meantime
I have my application right here that's
running out of uh or that's in Visual
Studio as of now right so once the
infrastructure is set and ready in the
Azure console we're gonna go back to
visual studio feed these inputs in the
visual studio so the code knows what the
database is the the credentials to log
into the database stuff like that so
we're going to feed those information in
Visual Studio by that we're actually
feeding it into the application and then
we're going to run it from there
deploying this application takes quite a
while we really got to be patient all
right now we have all the resources that
we need for the application to run here
is my database and here is my app
service there's one more thing we need
to do that is create and firewall
exception rule so one more thing needed
is to create a firewall exception rule
right so the application is going to run
from my local desktop and it's going to
connect to the database right so let's
add an exception rule by simply adding
the client IP it's going to pick my IP
the ipf laptop I'm using as of now and
it's going to create an exception to
access the database so that's done now
we can go back to our Visual Studio I
already have a couple of
apps running or couple of configurations
pushed from a visual studio I'm going to
clean that up if you're doing it for the
first time you you may not need to do
this
all right so let's start from the
scratch
this is very similar to how you would be
doing in your environment all right so
we're gonna select an existing Azure app
service now before that I have logged in
as you can see I have logged in uh with
my credentials so it's going to pull few
things automatically from my Azure
account so in this case I'm gonna use an
existing Azure app so select existing
and then click on publish
all right if you recall these are the
very same resources that we created a
while back
all right we have clicked on Save and
it's running kind of validating the code
and it's going to come up with an URL
now initially the URL is not going to
work because we haven't mapped the
application to the database so that
would be the next thing
all right so the app has been published
and it's running from my web app as of
now
it's going to throw an error like you
see it's throwing an error that's
because we haven't mapped the app and
the DB together so let's do that
all right let's do that so let's go to
server Explorer this is where we're
going to see our
databases that we have created now let's
quickly verify that
go back to
the resource Group right appropriate
Resource Group
which is right here
and here I have my database azure
simply learn database
all right it has some issues connecting
to my database give me a quick moment
let's fix it
all right so we'll have to map the
database into this application
right so let's go to the solution
Explorer click on publish
and a page like this gets shown and from
here we can go to configure
here is our web app all right with all
its credentials let's validate the
connection number one
all right and then click on next
this is my DB connection string right
which the app is going to use to connect
to my DB now if you recall rdb was uh
Azure simply learned DB and that's not
being shown here so let's fix that
right so let's fix that
click on configure and here let's put
our DB servers URL now before that let's
change this to SQL Server
all right and then in here put the DBS
URL so go back to azure
here is my DB or server's name
put that here
all right
the username to connect to the server
that's right here
put that in
and the password
to connect to the server let's put that
in
all right it's trying to connect to our
azure
portal or the Azure infrastructure and
here is my database if you recall it's
azure
sldb that's the name of the database
Let's test the connection
connection is good click on OK
so now it's showing up correctly Azure
simply learn DB that's the name of the
database that we created now it's
configured
all right let's modify the data
connections
right let's map it to the appropriate
database again all right so our name of
the database is azure simply learn DB
and then it's going to be
SQL Server that's the data source
the
username is simply learn
and the password is
what we have given in the beginning
all right let's validate the connection
it's good click ok
now we're all set
and ready to publish our application
again now the application knows how to
connect to the database we have educated
it with the uh the correct connection
strings the DNS name the username and
the password for the application to
connect to the database
so visual studio is building this
project and once it is up and running
will be prompted with an URL to connect
and anytime we put or we give inputs to
the URL that's going to receive the
input and save it in the database
all right so here is my to-do list app
and I can start creating to-do list for
myself all right so I have the items
already listed I can create an entry and
these entries get stored in the in the
database I can create another entry
and I'll take the dog for a walk that's
gonna get stored I can create another
entry uh book tickets for a scientific
exhibition
and that's going to receive and put that
in the database and that concludes our
session so through this session we saw
how I can use Azure services to create a
web app and connect that to the DB
instance and how those two Services
which are decoupled by default which are
separate by default how I can you know
use the connection strings to make
connection between the app server and
the database and be able to create an
working app so what is Google Cloud
platform it is a set of Cloud Computing
Services provided by Google that runs on
the same infrastructure that Google uses
to and for its end user products like
YouTube Gmail and so on
let's learn about benefits of Google
Cloud platform
such as high productivity
working from anywhere quick
collaboration high security
fewer data stored on vulnerable devices
reliable resources which can be used
across organization across geographical
regions across countries
very flexible which allows organizations
to scale up and down as the demand Rises
or as the demand declines and cost
effective solutions for various use
cases these are some of the benefits and
if we look into different Services which
Google Cloud platform offers
we could look into detailed benefits
which each service offers in a different
use case which basically helps
organizations working in different
domains handling different kind of small
mid or larger businesses and with
different business goals
when we talk about Google Cloud platform
Services here is a list of services or I
could say high level domains or
categories of services so you have
compute related Services you have
storage and database you have networking
Big Data developer tools identity and
Security Management Internet of Things
Cloud AI management tools and also data
transfer Solutions
when we talk about Google's
infrastructure Google has one of the
most powerful infrastructure in the
world the infrastructure is available in
two levels the physical and the abstract
layers you have physical infrastructure
and then you have the abstract
infrastructure
physical infrastructure consists of data
centers extensive development of high
efficiency back-end data centers
you have a very strong backbone Network
which is used by Google itself and also
offered as services to customers via gcp
platform services so you have Global
messed redundant backbone Network points
of presence when we talk about Google it
has 110 plus Edge points of presence in
more than 200 countries and when we talk
about Edge caching Edge caching platform
at periphery of their Network so this is
what defines the physical infrastructure
of Google now there is much more to it
rather than just these four points when
we talk about abstract infrastructure
that is divided in global regions and
zones when we talk about Zone a zone is
roughly equivalent to a data center
and a single point of failure so you
could have your compute engine which is
within a zone or you could say computer
engine is a zonal resource you have
regions which are geographical areas
which contain multiple zones
so you would have a region for U.S
Central or Europe Central Europe West
and so on and within a region you would
have one or multiple zones and zones
basically would allow High availability
of resources
so you have Cloud load balancer as an
example which is regional resource then
you have global resources and they are
available and shared across the planet
so you have various global resources
such as Network which could be even your
IP addresses and so on
now let's do a quick comparison of AWS
West Azure West gcp and let's look at
what each cloud provider offers later we
will also look into different services
in detail when it comes to Google Cloud
platform what each service does
what you can benefit from which service
should you use in what case we will
learn about those in later slides
if I compare your different Cloud
providers
when we talk about Amazon
and its Cloud offerings that is Amazon
web services or AWS as we will know it
Amazon web services has 69 availability
zones within 22 geographical locations
and soon it will have 12 more in future
so this number keeps growing based on
the spread of the services which a
particular cloud provider offers here we
are talking about availability Zone
specific information when we talk about
Microsoft's Azure it has 54 regions
worldwide and is available in 140
countries across the globe
when we talk about Google Cloud Google
Cloud platform is available in 200 plus
countries across the globe
when we talk about virtual servers
Amazon's ec2 that is elastic compute
Cloud it is a web service which
basically helps to resize your compute
capacity where you can run your
application programs on a virtual
machine so using ec2 service you could
launch virtual instances that would have
any distribution of Linux Windows you
could have different specifications when
it comes to Ram or CPU cores or disk you
could also decide on what kind of
storage a particular instance should use
whether the storage should be local to
the instance or whether that should be a
elastic file system or even an object
storage
when it comes to Azure or Microsoft's
offering as your virtual machine that is
infrastructure as a service gives a user
the ability to deploy and manage a
virtual environment inside a virtual
Network on the cloud
and this virtual Network on the cloud
would be managed by cloud provider
Google cloud or the offerings from
Google Cloud platform that is gcp VM
instances enables users to build deploy
and manage virtual machines in order to
run different kind of workloads on the
cloud now when we talk about compute
engine here it would be good to discuss
a little bit more about compute engine
and what are the different options which
Google Cloud offers so when you talk
about your compute engine
you have scalable high performance
virtual machines
compute engine delivers configurable
virtual machines which run in Google's
data center with access to high
performance networking infrastructure
and block storage and you could select
VMS for your needs that could be general
purpose or workload optimized and when
we talk about workload optimized you
have predefined machines or you have
custom machine sizes you can integrate
compute with other Google cloud services
such as AI or ML and go for your data
analytics you have when we talk about
your gcp VM instances just to expand on
that you have general purpose instances
which we call as N2
which provide a balance between price
and performance and they are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web servers and
databases
Google Cloud also offers compute
optimized instances which we call as C2
instances which offer consistent
high-end virtual CPU performance which
are good for AAA gaming Eda HPC and
other applications now when we talk
about compute optimize your general
purpose how would we leave memory
optimized instances those are M2
machines which Google offers so these
offer highest amount of memory these VMS
are well suited for in-memory databases
such as sap Hana real-time analytics and
in-memory caches so if I would summarize
this when we talk about different
instances AWS
also offers different kind of instances
which are memory or compute or disk
optimized you have general purpose and
each category of machines has a
different pricing model you can always
go to an AWS website look for the
pricing models and that will give you an
idea of on-demand instances or dedicated
instances reserved instances and so on
similarly if you talk about Google Cloud
Google Cloud also has instances with
various options which become the key
features of why customers would choose
Google Cloud platform such as live
migration for VMS so compute engine
within your gcp can live migrate between
host systems and when I say live migrate
it basically means without rebooting
which keeps your application running
even when the underlying host systems
require maintenance you also have
preemptable virtual machines wherein you
can run bad jobs and fault tolerant
workloads on preemptable VMS to reduce
your virtual CPU and memory cost by up
to 80 percent while getting the same
performance so these are your preemptive
or preemptable virtual machines the only
demonet is these can give you a really
cost efficient resource usage however
can be taken off the shelf anytime and
that's why we call them preemptable
virtual machines you also have soul
tenant nodes which are physical compute
engine servers dedicated explicitly or
exclusively for
users use case and when we talk about
Soul tenant nodes these are usually good
when you are dealing with or when you're
working with your applications which we
call as bring your own license
applications so Soul tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and
virtual machine config options as
regular compute instances
so there are different options which
Google Cloud offers when it comes to
these instances which we are talking
about and it takes care of different use
cases in comparison to other Cloud
providers which are also offering these
services such as you can have predefined
machine types you can have custom
machine types preemptable VMS as I said
live migration of VMS you can use
persistent disks which could give you
durable high performance block storage
you have local ssds you also have GPU
accelerators which can be added to
accelerate computational intensive
workloads such as machine learning
simulation medical analysis and so on
and you have features such as Global
load balancing which makes Google Cloud
a unique choice
when we talk about platform as a service
Amazon has platform as a service
offering which we call as elastic
Beanstalk among one of its services it's
an orchestration service for deploying
applications and helping in maintaining
these applications
Azure cloud service provides a platform
to write the user application code
without worrying about the hardware
resources
Google app engine is a service used by
Developers for building and hosting
applications on Google's data centers
when we talk about serverless computing
so Amazon's AWS Lambda is a serverless
compute service it is used to execute
back-end code and scales automatically
when required when we talk about Azure
you have something called as functions
which allow users to build applications
using serverless simple functions with a
programming language of their choice
when we talk about Google cloud gcp has
Cloud functions which is easiest way to
run your code in the cloud and it is
highly available and fault tolerant so
in these days when we are talking about
micro Services architecture which
organizations are preferring when we are
talking about organizations which can
scale which can dynamically change their
underlying architecture organizations
would be interested in serverless
Computing where they do not have to have
a infrastructure setup a planned in
advance before going for their use case
and this is where monolithic
applications are really not a Preferred
Choice
a lot of organizations are decomposing
their applications into microservices
based on business capability or
decomposing based on subdomains we can
learn about microservices architecture
later but just to know that serverless
Computing which basically helps any
organization if for example if you have
a web application that receives
non-linear traffic and you cannot keep
an eye on your server always it would be
good to have someone to Auto scale your
application serverless is basically a
Computing model where cloud service
provider is responsible for managing the
piece of code without the developer
having to bother about infrastructure
setup management maintenance and so on
now when we talk about applications
being serverless or benefiting from
serverless Computing one of the key
things would be zero Administration so
deploying application without any
provisioning and management Auto scaling
capability that is let the service
provider worry about scaling the
application up and down you have
pay-per-use model which any customer
would want to benefit from that is pay
only for the resources that you have
used or that you are continuing to use
right shorten the time between idea
implementation and employment and this
is something which any organization
would want that you would want a faster
bring to the market solution timeline in
comparison to getting entangled with
deployment management and maintenance of
your underlying infrastructure when your
applications are facing a high demand so
when we talk about serverless
it is a function as a service
because each part of your application is
divided as functions and can be hosted
over multiple service providers you have
serverless apps which are usually
divided as separate units or functions
based on functionalities or domains and
so on so serverless Computing is getting
quite popularity these days in
comparison to the traditional three-tier
architecture where you had a
presentation layer you had an
application layer you have a database
layer now that kind of infrastructure is
not really preferred in today's modern
times when organizations are working on
different kind of newer applications
when we talk about object storage Amazon
has simple storage service that is S3 it
provides object storage which is built
for storing and recovering information
or data from anywhere over the internet
as your comes up with blob storage that
is binary large objects storage offers
large amount of storage and scalability
it stores the object in the tiers and
depending on how often the data is being
accessed now same thing applies to even
S3 which is from Amazon so S3 also has
different kind of storage classes which
can be selected when a user or
organization intends to use a storage
service and when I speak about storage
classes it basically means having a
frequent access storage or a infrequent
access storage or what we call as just
an archival solution
Google cloud has cloud storage and it
provides unified object storage for live
or archive data the service is used to
store and access data on gcp
infrastructure
when it comes to advantages Amazon web
services has Enterprise friendly
Services easy access to resources
increase in Speed and Agility and that
too on demand and takes care of your
security and reliability of resources
which are offered when it comes to sgr
it has better development operations
strong security profile provides a lot
of cost effective Solutions and
operation execution friendly
when we talk about Google Cloud one of
the key features here is better pricing
than competitors live migration of
virtual machines which really interests
a lot of organizations would want to
modernize their infrastructure without
having any kind of disruption in their
existing Services improved performance
redundant backups and so on
when it comes to disadvantages in AWS
you have limitations when it comes to
ec2 service well there are different
options in the kind of machines which
you can choose which you can work on you
have a technical support fee which is
incurred network connectivity and then
also downtime which might be in case
when you are migrating Azure it has
different code base for cloud and
premise platform is a service ecosystem
is not really as efficient as
infrastructure as a service poor
management of GUI and tools integrated
backup
when we talk about Google Cloud support
fee is quite Hefty it depends on what
kind of solution or support you would or
organization would be interested in it
has a complex pricing schema although it
has different use cases for which any
user or any organization can benefit
from downloading data from Google cloud
services is an expensive option storage
might not be however uploading data or
downloading data would be an expensive
option
when we talk about Domino's Pizza use
case now while we were discussing about
these features I would really want to
spend more time in discussing each of
these features or services in detail
such as you have compute engine you have
storage you have big table you have data
proc and so on so there are huge list of
services now before we get into your
Domino's Pizza use case let me show you
this page on Google Cloud where you can
look at different services so if you go
to cloud.google.com and if you look at
get started option under docs so here
you can find build Solutions look at
different use cases learn from basics of
what is your Google Cloud what are Cloud
Basics then you can look at different
Cloud products so here you have products
in different categories such as Ai and
machine learning API management compute
containers data analytics databases
developer tools and so on and you can
always click on
any one of these to look into different
solutions which are being offered what
are the different use cases what are the
best practices when it comes to
migrating VMS to compute engine or
operating containers or building
containers and so on you can always look
at featured products and that gives you
a quick snapshot of what are the
different products such as you have
compute engine you have Cloud run
bigquery which is a data warehouse you
have Cloud SQL which is a managed MySQL
or postgres you have cloud storage to
basically push in any kind of data there
you have security key enforcement Ai and
machine learning and so on so you have
different feature products now if you
scroll down
to the lower end of this page
you can again look at different
solutions and that would be really
interesting to read and learn from so
you have infrastructure modernization
you have application modernization you
have data management and so on so if I
look at infrastructure modernization you
could basically look at the solutions
which Google Cloud offers and what it
does when it comes to having your
infrastructure modernized or benefiting
by integrating with cloud and having
immediate benefits of infrastructure
modernization you can look at different
use cases what they are doing how Google
Cloud really helps when it comes to
migrating the workloads to a cloud and
how your different Cloud Solutions such
as VM migration you have sap on Google
Cloud VMware as a service and so on and
you could learn from these different
solutions which are offered you can also
look at application modernization so not
only infrastructure modernization but
organizations would also be interested
in re-looking at their applications
really looking at how these applications
could be moved from monolithic to
microservices architecture or how
applications can benefit from
modernization and cloud computing
offerings so you have again different
use cases here
which talks about different ways in
which Google Cloud can help how you can
modernize your applications how you can
use different solutions which Google
cloud is offering now when we talk about
Cloud Computing Services you can always
go into
cloud.google.com if you have created a
free account then you can just log in
and every user by default gets a 300
free credit so when they can try out
different products where they can use
different services so here if I click on
Console where I'm already logged in with
my Gmail account or my Google Cloud
account wherein I have 300 free credit
out of which some is being used you have
a Google Cloud console and here from the
hamburger menu you can click and you can
look at different services within
different domains so you have compute
domain which has different services such
as app you have compute engine and that
basically allows you to use your VM
instances which we were talking about
previous slides different instance
groups create your templates use Soul
tenant notes create snapshots or backup
of your data use different zones you can
go for kubernetes which is containerized
based engine you have Cloud functions
you have Cloud run and then you have
storage related different options such
as big table you have data store
firestore file store storage and so on
and for each of these Services you can
read about from the Google's
documentation or anyways I will be
explaining that later
you can also look at networking related
operation related and other tools which
are offered by Google Cloud so these are
huge list of services which Google Cloud
platform offers in different ways for
different use cases
now let's look at this Domino's Pizza
use case and see what it helps us learn
about so you can always access this page
by going to this link which talks about
customers and then which shows you
different use cases
so Dominos increasing monthly Revenue by
six percent with Google analytics
premium Google tag manager and Google
bigquery
so this is basically when dominoes
started using gcp and what was the
result of that
now let's look further into this
so we all know that Domino is most
popular pizza delivery chain operating
across the globe but how was that
possible let's take a look so the
challenges were they wanted to integrate
marketing measurement across various
devices
connecting CRM and Digital Data to
create a clear view of customer Behavior
to make cross-channel marketing
performance analysis easy and efficient
now for these challenges which Domino's
was facing the solution was using Google
analytics premium
Google tag manager and bigquery which
were used to integrate Digital Data
sources and CRM data
reporting was made easier and more
efficient by implementing Google
analytics premium because it had the
ability to access a single Google
analytics account to evaluate web and
app performance
by using the new Google tag manager
implementation dominance were able to
act fast they were able to connect CRM
data with digital analytics which
basically provided Domino with greater
visibility on customer Behavior what was
the result there was an immediate six
percent increase in monthly Revenue 80
percent of costs in ad serving and
operations were saved
increases agility with streamline tag
management
they obtained easy access to powerful
reporting and customized dashboards now
that was just one simple use case before
we go on to Hands-On we can also talk a
little bit back about these Services
which Google Cloud offers as we
discussed and some of these Services
which can really make you think
why not Google Cloud platform so when we
talk about your different Cloud platform
Services let's learn about some of these
services in brief in what each service
is what it does and how it can help us
in handling our use cases or working
with different products so let's learn
briefly about different Services which
Google Cloud platform offers now one of
the domains is compute and then let's
look at the compute Services which gcp
offers now here I can log into the
console and this hamburger menu on the
top left corner I can click on this one
and go into the compute engine section
so this is the compute domain which has
app engine kubernetes engine Cloud fact
functions and Cloud run so these are
your different Services which are
offered within the compute domain and
here we can get into compute engine by
clicking on this one and then basically
going to VM instances so before we see
how we can use this compute engine let's
understand about some of the features of
compute engine which basically offers
scalable high performance virtual
machines which are configurable and
which runs in Google's data center with
access to high performance networking
infrastructure and block storage so from
here you can select VM for your needs
for your general purpose or workload
optimized predefined or custom machines
now here you can integrate compute with
other Google cloud services such as AI
ML and other data analytics Services you
have different machines which are
offered here such as general purpose
which provide a balance between price
and performance which are well suited
for most workloads including line of
business applications web services and
databases you also have compute optimize
machines which offer consistent high-end
virtual CPU core performance and which
are mainly good for gaming Eda High
process Computing and other such
applications apart from general purpose
compute optimized you also have memory
optimized machines which offer highest
amount of memory and these VMS are
basically well suited for in-memory
databases such as sap Hana real-time
analytics and in-memory cache now we can
see these options here you can click on
VM instances while you are logged in
into your Google Cloud console here you
can even create an instance template
which can be used to spin up instances
for example if I click on new VM
instance from a template there are some
templates which I have already created
for my usage now here I can basically
use one of these templates or what I can
do is I can go back I can can go into
instance templates and this basically
allows me to create a template so you
can click on create instance template
which basically allows you to create
templates which can be used to spin up
different instances we can give a name
to the template for example we can say
template instance now here I can choose
machine configurations and this is where
you have different options so you have
general purpose as I mentioned which
provide a balance between price and
performance you have memory optimized
which are large memory machine types for
memory intensive workloads you also have
compute optimized which basically give
you high performance machine types for
compute intensive workloads so you can
choose any machine configuration which
is available here based on your
requirements now if you click on general
purpose that has different options here
so you look into the series where you
have N1 series you have E2 which is CPU
platform select action based on
availability you have N2 and n2d so
let's just have N1 selected now you also
have here which talks about machine
types and here we can choose the
configuration which we are interested in
depending on the applications which will
run within the machines we can choose a
machine so by default it shows one
virtual CPU core and 3.5 gigabyte of
memory or Ram you could choose a higher
end machine so as of now I'll just say
N1 standard now that basically allows me
to choose these machines so there are
different features which your compute
offers such as you have live migration
for VMS you have preemptable virtual
machines you have sold tenant nodes and
all those options can be seen here now
in this machine for my boot disk I can
select a distribution which I would be
interested in for example I could be
going for public images and I can choose
for example Ubuntu and then I can choose
a version so it shows me 16.04 and you
also have latest version such as Ubuntu
20. you can choose one of these and here
it asks you to choose the boot disk type
so that could be standard persistent
disk which is hdds which are low in
performance and you can say low in cost
in comparison to ssds so ssds give you
better performance but then they are
little expensive than using standard
persistent disk we can choose this and
we can give a disk size for example 20
gigabyte and I can click on select
before clicking on select I can click on
custom images and that shows me if you
have any other images created in your
project you could use those you could
also learn about images by clicking on
this link so we'll click on public
images we have chosen this distribution
let's do a select and now here you have
identity and API access management so
let this be default you you can say
allow default access and what you need
is depending on the services we can
choose it allows HTTP and https traffic
now we would also need some way to
connect to these machines so when you
set up an instance by default you can do
SSH into it using the Google Cloud
console or from cloud shell you can also
give a private and a public key so here
you have the option where you can give
all these details so when it comes to
management it tells you would you want
to go for reservations and you can say
automatically use created reservation
you could also say no you would not want
to use a reservation you can also set up
or provide a startup script which you
would want to give whenever your
machines come up and here you have the
options of preemptability so compute
offers preemptable virtual machines so
that is mainly when you would want to
run bad jobs and fault tolerant workload
on these machines and you can benefit
with a reduced cost for your virtual CPU
and memory by 80 percent so these are
virtual machines which would be lasting
less than 24 hours now by default this
is off and it purely depends on your
workload what you would want to run on
these instances I could just go ahead
and select preemptable being on that and
use this feature of compute you also
have on host maintenance which talks
about what would be happening with this
compute engine instance so when compute
engine performs periodic infrastructure
maintenance it can migrate your VM
instances to other hardware and this is
one of the features which compute engine
offers which we call as live migration
for VMS here your compute engine can
live migrate between host systems that
is the underlying systems on which these
VM instances are based on without
rebooting which will keep your
application running even when host
system require maintenance and here it
says migrate VM instance recommended and
let that be as it is you can also say
that if there is a maintenance happening
you can terminate the VM instance now it
also talks about automatic restart which
is on which basically means compute
engine can automatically restart VM
instances if they are terminated from
non-user initiated reasons so these are
all the settings which are available in
management and it also tells us the
different features which we have there
is also a feature called Soul tenancy
which basically means sold tenant sold
tenant nodes which can be chosen so you
can have physical compute engine servers
dedicated exclusively for your use and
this is usually good when you are
talking about bring your own license
applications so Soul tenant nodes give
you access to same machine types and VM
configuration options as a regular
compute instances however these might be
a little expensive we can choose this
one we can also look into networking
which basically shows the default setup
which goes for auto subnet you can also
choose a particular IP if that is
required but that would cost more you
can click on disks which talk about what
do you want to do with the boot disk
when the instance is deleted what is the
encryption mechanism you would want to
use and here finally you have security
so basically as I said you can SSH into
instance using the cloud console option
and you can also provide a public SSH
key so one way of doing that if you
intend to use an external SSH client
such as putty to connect you can create
a key so for example I can go into
puttygen and here I can say generate
just move my cursor over here and that
will create a key I can give a name to
this one so I'll say sdu will be
username I'll give a simple password
which I will used to login to this
machine and then I can save this private
key which will get saved so let's say
hdu new key and this gets saved in a DOT
PPK file which is usually used when you
use an external SSH client to connect so
save this one and that saves a PPK file
on your desktop what you can also do is
you can copy this public key content
from here and this is what we would want
to give in our instance here so so that
the public key gets stored on the
instance and private key is what we will
use to connect so once I paste it here
it resolves the name to htu and we have
given the public key now in certain
cases you may want to use a software
which uses SSH to connect to the machine
and that software might not be such as
your putty so in that case you may want
a Pim file or a private key which is
saved as a DOT pem file so you can also
do that by going to conversions and do a
export openssh key and then save it so
I'll say hdu new key but then this one
will be saved as a pem file on my
machine so you have PPK file which
allows you to use putty to connect to
the instance you have a pen in case a
software needs directly SSH to these
machines you also have the public key
which we have already provided in the
machine now once this is done I can
close puttygen I can go back to this
page where I'm creating an instance
template and then I can just click on
create so this has created a instance
template which I can use to spin up my
instances any number of instances using
the same template only thing which I
would have to do is change the region
where I would want the instance to run
so now that we have created instance and
that's my this one the third option I
can go back to VM instances now I can
click on Create and here I can either
create an instance from scratch by
giving all the details again or I can
just use my template so I can click on
new VM instance from a template choose
my template click on continue and once
this is done I can give my instance name
so let's say C1 I can choose the region
so I will choose Frankfurt and then rest
everything is auto populated based on
the template what you have given and you
click on create now this basically
allows you to spin up an instance and
you can create any number of instances
using your template you could have
already created a new instance right
from scratch now once the instance is
created this has a public IP and a
private IP private IP will not change
unless you would want to set up a new
machine but public IP will change every
time you stop and start the machine now
this is what we need to connect to this
machine I can also do a SSH from here by
doing this in open in a browser window
let's click on this so this is an
internal way of connecting to your
instance using SSH let's wait because it
would be transferring the SSH keys to
the VM it establishes a connection and I
am connected to my machine what we can
easily do is to confirm if we are in the
right machine we can just do a LS to
look at the file system what we can also
do is we can basically log in as root by
doing a sudo Su and that allows you to
get into the machine as root and from
here I can switch to hdu user which will
have a DOT SSH directory in home and
that basically has authorized keys and
if we would want to see if this one
contains my public key I can just do a
cat dot SSH and then look into
authorized keys and this shows me the
public key which we had initially added
to our instance so this confirms that we
are logged into the machine which we
created now I can close this and what I
can also do is I can copy this public IP
so let's do a copy to clipboard now go
to putty and here I will say hostname
where I'll say hdu give my public key
I'll click on SSH and in SSH I'll go to
authentication now here we need to give
our PPK file so the PPK file was sdu new
key select this one come back here come
to the session give it a name for
example C1 save it and then you can just
say open and say yes and you are logged
in to your machine now once you are
logged in you can always do a minus SSH
and that shows you the file so this is
how you have just used the compute
engine to spin up an instance but we
used a template which basically allowed
me to create this instance and then I
can connect to this instance and then I
can start working on this so when we
talk about features of compute engine it
has predefined machine types as we saw
so compute engine offers different
predefined virtual machines and this
they have configurations for every need
from small general purpose instances to
large memory optimized instances with up
to 11.5 terabytes of ram you can have
fast compute instances optimized up to
60 virtual CPU cores you also have
custom machine types so you can create a
VM that best fits your workload and by
tailoring a custom machine type to your
specific need you can realize
significant savings there are
preemptable VMS which we saw there is
also a facility which allows you to take
the benefit of live migration for VMS
you have durable high performance block
storage for virtual machine instances in
the form of persistent disks where data
is stored redundantly for integrity
flexibility and to size storage without
interruption and you could be choosing
sdds or sdds for your instances now you
also have options such as GPU
accelerators so for example if I just
click on create instance and I can look
into that so here let the instance name
be instance 1 and what I would be
interested in looking at this one which
says CPU platform and GPU so CPU
platform configuration is permanent you
can also do add GPU so gpus can be added
to accelerate computationally intensive
workloads like machine learning
simulation medical analysis and virtual
workstation applications so you can add
and remove gpus to a VM when your
workload changes and pay for GPU only
while using so these are some of the
features which basically compute engine
offers and we already know that Google
bills in second level increments so we
only pay for the compute time now there
are different savings which are possible
so you have commitment savings which
basically means you can save up to 57
with a upfront cost per instance type
lock in you have container support so
you can basically run manage and
orchestrate Docker containers or compute
engine instances so here when we are
setting up our instances there is an
option which basically allows you to use
or deploy Docker images now that can be
done you can also benefit from sustained
use savings that is sustained use
discounts which are automatic discounts
for running compute engine resources for
significant portion of the billing month
you can create a reservation for VM
instance in a specific Zone which is
basically seen under your management
section here and you can ensure your
project has resources for future
increases in demand and if no longer
needed did delete the reservation so
these are some of the features of
compute engine what we have done is we
have created compute engine using the
console now you can go back you can also
do that using Cloud shell and you can
click on this one which activates Cloud
shell you could also have the cloud SDK
support on setup on your machine which
can be used now I can just open this in
a new window and from here I can start
giving commands if I would be interested
in setting up an instance from my
command line so here you have different
options now to begin with you can just
do a g cloud and just hit enter and that
will show you different options which
are available which can be used so you
have gcloud compute here which shows an
option to create and manipulate compute
engine resources now I can just do a
queue to quit I can do gcloud compute
and that basically will again show me
different options which are available if
you would be interested in setting up
instances from the command line so here
I can say G Cloud compute and then go
for instances and if you do not know the
commands you can just hit enter that
will show you all the different options
which we have so here we have different
options such as list or create or start
or update for example I can just do a
list here to see what instances I have
and the instance which we just created
shows up here it says that status is
running I can just stop this instance I
can delete this instance I can even
create an instance by using a create
command here and you can just do a
create help which will show you what are
the different options you can give so it
says instance name is what you need you
can choose an accelerator you can choose
the boot disk and various other options
so I can just say create and then I can
give a name for example C2 and once I
click on this one it says did you mean
Europe West 4 zone so it is asking me
for the region and the zone and I can
say yes and these settings are coming
from my default profile I can always
change those by changing the metadata so
now we have created an instance it says
running if we do a list again to see we
see two instances created one was in
Europe West 3 one was on Europe yes West
four both of them have internal and
external eyepiece now you can do a
describe to look at the different
options here so G Cloud basically allows
you different commands which you can use
to work with your instance to create
instances to change the metadata if you
would want to change the region if you
would want to add a startup script all
those options are possible from the
command line which we can learn in
detail in later sessions so this is your
compute engine as a service now that we
have learned about the compute domain
and the compute Services which is
offered by gcp let's also learn about
storage and databases that's again
within the storage domain and the
services which are offered by Google
Cloud platform now you can go back to
console and here you can click on this
one and here you can just scroll down to
see what are the different options in
storage so you have options such as
bigtable you have data store firestore
file store you have SQL Based Services
you have storage which is object storage
and then you have other options which
are available so Google Cloud platform
offers different storage Based Services
out of which storage which is your
object storage is quite popular one
click on store storage and that
basically shows you an option which
talks about storage browser so this is
your Google Cloud's object storage so
when we talk about object storage it is
basically a storage where you could
store any kind of data and when we talk
about object storage it is a bunch of
bytes which we address wherein every
object will have a unique key these
unique keys are in the form of URL which
allows you to access the object so cloud
storage is comprised of what we call as
buckets which are used to store and hold
your storage objects the storage objects
are immutable and every change creates a
new version now you can also have
control access via IAM that is identity
access management or via Access Control
list so there is also an option called
object versioning which basically says
if it is on every time you try to store
the same object in new version of the
object would be created otherwise newer
options will override old one as we
cannot archive the old version so let's
see how we work with this object storage
so here you can click on create bucket
now once you click on create bucket it
needs a name so let's say test bucket
and here I can just give say number one
so that says this is the name of my
bucket now I can directly click on
continue or it would be good to look at
different options which are available
here so when you click on choose where
to store your data so it already gives
me an option it says the bucket name is
already taken so let me give it a unique
name so let's say test buck and let's
call it AUA so that should be unique now
here it says choose where to store your
data so this one gives you location type
so you can have region specific buckets
which give you lowest latency that is
fastest response time within a single
region however it does not make your
storage highly available you can make a
dual region which is basically allowing
your bucket or storage to be accessible
across regions you can also make it
multi-region which is highest
availability offered as of now we can
choose region specific and now it asks
you to choose a location now as always I
will choose
Frankfurt now I can click on continue
and rest all the rest let all the
storage options be default or you can
click on a default storage class now
that tells you based on your storage
class there are variant costs when it
comes to storing retrieving or doing any
kind of operations so you have a
standard option which says best for
short-term storage and frequently Access
Data you can also go for Cold Storage
such as nearline which is best for
backups and data access less than once a
month you can go for freezing storage
such as cold line best for disaster
recovery and data accessed less than
once a quarter or you can go for
archiving where the data is accessed
less than once a year let's go for
standard as of now and now you can
choose how to control access to objects
so you have fine grained or uniform let
it be fine grained wherein you can give
additional permissions at Bucket Level
using IAM or object level permissions
using access control list in advanced
settings you can choose the encryption
and you can also choose a retention
policy so a retention policy to specify
the minimum duration that this buckets
objects must be protected from deletion
or modification after they are uploaded
you can always learn about this more by
clicking here now once I have chosen all
the relevant options I can click on
Create and that basically will create a
bucket by the name I have given I can
click on overview to basically see brief
details about my bucket such as region
what is the default storage class and it
also shows you the link URL which can be
used to access your bucket it also gives
you the link for GS util now GS util is
a command which can be used in your
Cloud shell to basically work with your
buckets you can click on permissions to
basically see what kind of permissions
are already in place and you can then
make changes you can basically add
members you can view by different roles
so for example here by default it shows
other services such as data proc or your
bucket owner or bucket reader related
permissions which have been already
granted it now once I have looked at my
bucket I can start using it I can drag
and drop and push in files here so as of
now there are no live objects in my
object storage that is in my bucket what
I can do is I can click on upload files
and then I can choose a location from my
machine for example I'll go into data
sets and what I can do is I can choose
some of the files here in any format
let's choose CSV or text and just to
open so this one will basically upload
my data sets here now once I've uploaded
the files I can basically close this one
I can look into options here which says
edit permissions and edit metadata if
you would want to download it if you
would want to copy move or rename it if
you would want to export to a different
service called Cloud Pub sub which is
Pub publish subscribing messaging system
you can scan the data now you can click
on a particular file and that basically
shows you the URL which basically allows
you to access this file you can try
copying this you can click on download
and download this file you can even try
accessing this from public and that
basically shows you the content of this
file based on the permissions so this is
basically your object storage which is
one of the service which is offered what
you can also do is you can create
folders and within folders you can then
upload your data so this is your Google
Cloud
storage option which is for your object
storage that is you can add different
items you can give different permissions
and you can use this Google Cloud
platforms storage service offering now
you also have other options such as big
table and we can go into that by
clicking here and click on big table so
big table is one of the service which
kickstarted nosql databases today in
Market we see different nosql databases
such as Cassandra hbase mongodb couchdb
neo4j and many others so you can
basically use bigtable which was the
Pioneer when it comes to your no SQL
databases or not only SQL databases so
the problem initially faced by Google
was that the web indexes behind search
engine were taking too long to build so
company wanted to build database that
would provide avoid real-time access to
petabytes of data and that's where
bigtable began so big table powers
different other Google services such as
Gmail Google Maps and other services and
in 2015 it was launched as a service for
customers so when it comes to
scalability with use of bigtable you can
increase your machine count without any
downtime and you can handle admin tasks
like upgrades restarts and so on which
are basically taken care by the cloud
provider data present in cloud bigtable
is encrypted and you can use IM roles to
specify access so data written to or
from bigtable is through data service
layers such as managed virtual machines
edgebase res servers Java Services hbase
client and so on here if I would want to
use bigtable I can click on create
instance and that basically tells me
Cloud bigtable instance is a container
for your clusters now here you can give
an instance name so for example I will
say a u a and then say for example test
and let's say big table so that will be
the name of instance this will be
permanent you can choose the storage
type again you can go for lower latency
more rows red per second typically used
for real-time serving use cases or you
can go for sdds which have higher
latency for random reads good
performance on scans and typically used
for batch analytics so let's go for ssds
as of now here you have cluster ID which
is auto populated you can choose a
region so let's go for our favorite one
here where I can say Europe West 3 I can
choose a Zone here and I can then choose
how many nodes would I want to use for
my big table so when you talk about big
table service it will have a cluster
underlying which will have various nodes
which will Contour your data throughput
storage and rows read per second so as
of now let it be just one node and
that's enough for our demo when we talk
about performance it basically tells you
based on the current node and storage
type it tells you how many reads can
happen at milliseconds so it says 10 000
rows per second at six millisecond you
have rights which are 10 000 rows per
second or you have scans which are 220
megabytes per second storage which is
taken care here would be 2.5 terabytes
and I can then basically click on create
now there is also some option called
replication guidance which basically
says replication for cloud table big
table copies your data across multiple
regions enabling you to isolate workload
and increase the availability and
durability of your data depending on
your use case you can have big table
which can be used to have your data
across region
now you can click on create with all
your specifications Chosen and that's
going to set up a cluster or you can say
a fully managed nosql database which
will give you low latency and
replication for high availability now
once we have a new instance you can
connect to it with the CBT command line
tool and for instructions you can click
on learn more here you can just click on
this instance ID to see the details
again if you would want to look into
your big table setup so it tells me here
that we have one instance what is the
CPU utilization time how many rows for
read or written what is the throughput
and this is auto populated based on your
usage you can click on monitoring and
that basically will give you different
widgets which will display information
for your CPU utilization what is your
hottest node depending on how many nodes
you have system errors automatic
failover words story utilization and so
on you can click on key visualizer which
will allow you to look into your table
if you have already created some data
here and you can click on tables to see
how many tables you have added here so
that's in brief about your big tables
which is one thing which we need to
remember is it's not good for all use
cases so should be used for low latency
access that is fast access and good if
at least data is greater than one
terabyte for smaller amount of data the
overhead is too high so big tables
performance will suffer if you store
individual elements larger than 10
megabytes if you want to store bigger
objects such as images video files then
go for object storage and that would be
a better option so always remember
bigtable is not a relational database
it's a nosql database and when you to
talk about multi-row transactions or
online transaction processing bigtable
is not the right choice so it can be
used for wide range of applications
especially when you talk about your olap
that is online analytical processing so
it is designed to store key value Pairs
and there can be different use cases so
for example if you are using something
like cloud data flow or cloud data proc
where you would want mapreduce kind of
operations bigtable can act as a good
storage because it has very high
throughput and scalability and the best
thing is that it supports hbase API thus
allowing easy integration with Apache
Hadoop and Spark clusters which you can
bring up using one more service which
Google Cloud platform offers which is
called cloud data proc so bigtable is
good for real-time analytics it's
commonly seen in financial services iot
and others and if you are thinking of
running interactive SQL then bigtable
would not be the right choice but the
other choice would be bigquery you
should also remember that this has a
cluster running and you would be charged
if this cluster kept on running so you
have to be very careful in your free
account when you are using such Services
now we have clicked on this one so I can
select this one and basically I can look
at the permissions I can look at the
labels I can look at inherited
permissions here I can also click on my
instance
which we created and either you can edit
or you can just do a delete so as of now
we will just delete this which needs you
to given the name so we'll say AUA test
b t and then click on delete so whenever
you are trying out different Services
the first approach should be setting up
these different Services seeing how they
work basically trying connecting to them
and once you are satisfied with the
initial test then you can plan your
actions and come back and use the
service for a longer duration now that's
your big table which is one of the
offerings we can go back into storage
and here you have other options which
are available so for example we were in
big table you also have an option such
as cloud data store now that's one more
service which is offered by Google Cloud
platform when it comes to storage domain
so Google added software on top of big
table which supports more more than
simple key value pairs when you talk
about secondary indexes instead of just
having one primary index when you talk
about asset properties for Reliable
transactions such as SQL query like
language so these features or these
Services were added to or on top of your
big table which gave birth to a new
service which was released as cloud data
store so this is where you have cloud
data store and you can select a cloud
firestore mode so you can go for a
native mode enable all Cloud firestore's
features with offline support or you can
go for clouds data store system on top
of clouds firestore so these are
different options here and here we look
at the API or scalability engine support
how many rights it supports and so on
you can choose one of these and then you
can choose where to store your data so
for example if I click on this one then
it shows asks me to choose a location so
it says the location of your database
effect its cost availability and
durability choose a regional location
lower right latency lower cost or
multi-region location here I can
basically choose for example Europe
and then I can go ahead and create a
database so it says initializing cloud
firestore in data store mode services in
eu3 this usually takes a few minutes
you'll be redirected to your database
once it is ready so if we compare the
pricing structure between cloud data
store and Cloud bigtable always remember
cloud data store you pay for monthly
storage which is also in the case of
bigtable however here you are paying for
monthly storage for reads and writes but
in case of big table you are paying for
cluster when it is running so cloud data
store is a good option for small data
infrequent access and it acts cheaper
when you talk about large amount of data
or big data and frequent access then you
are talking about Cloud bigtable so
bigtable is cheaper when you talk about
larger amount of data so here it says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to cloud firestore in
Native mode to get more features you
could do that you could learn you could
say query by gql
as of now we don't have any data here
let's look at the dashboard which says
since your database is empty you can
still switch to Cloud file store in
Native mode to get more features so this
is your cloud data store and it has many
features which help you to work with
your data however some features or
important features of rdbmss were still
missing and that's where Google created
yet another big table based service
called Cloud spanner now we can continue
working on cloud data store which
basically gives you one option to work
with your data
you can create an entity here by
clicking on create entity and that
basically gives you options such as
default namespace you can give a kind
you can give numeric ID and you can
start adding properties but to learn
more about datastore we will learn about
this in further session so as of now I
am going to click on cancel I am going
to go back to my data store and this
basically let's go to data store option
or I can go into admin here which
basically says if you have entities you
can import or export them so let's go
back and let's again look into storage
options so as of now we were in data
store let's click on this one so as I
mentioned your cloud data store which
basically gives you some additional
features on top of your big table but
what Google also did was it realized
that there was a need for rdbms feature
support that is there were a lot of
features now here we have created a data
store and it says your database is ready
to go just add data you can create
entity start putting in data and then
you can go ahead and query this so if
you would want to learn more about your
data store you can just click on this
one and that takes you to the complete
documentation of native mode and data
store mode what is firestore in Native
mode what is in data store mode what are
pricing and locations how you choose a
database mode what are the feature
comparisons what you can do what you are
allowed to do here what programming
languages can be used different regions
pricing and so on as of now we'll click
on this one and let's look at one
Advanced service which Google Cloud came
up with when it comes to your additional
features of rdbms so Google created yet
another big table based service called
Cloud spanner now that you might not see
here but if you scroll down you should
be able to see your Cloud spanner in the
options here or did we miss it on the
top so let's again look here here so it
is here and you can click on spanner so
Cloud spanner was released in 2017 it
basically supports relational schema so
it offers strong consistency for all
queries which can be SQL based you can
have multi-region deployment now when it
comes to massive scalability requirement
and strong consistency Cloud spanner is
a good option so it says Cloud spanner
is a managed Mission critical globally
consistent and scalable relational
database so if you would want to use
this then you will have to enable this
API which shows you an option here it
says try this API so it's a managed
service so it is one of the Google's
most expensive database Services there
is also one more database service which
is cloud SQL which can be used so when
we talk about your cloud spanner it is
fully managed relational database
service it is massively distributed you
can have millions of machines across
hundreds of data centers which support
automatic sharding and synchronous
replication it gives you low latency and
schema updates without down time making
data High availability and reliability
so we learn about Cloud spanner with
more details later in other sessions now
we can also go back to storage and we
can look at the different options which
we have here so you have object storage
you have spanner you also have your SQL
based service which is yet another
manage service offered by cloud or
Google Cloud I would say so that's
called Cloud SQL so this is basically a
service which allows you to have fully
managed relational MySQL postgres and
SQL Server databases Google handles
replication patch management database
management and other things which are
related to this managed or fully managed
database service it can allow you to
handle terabytes of storage capacity
with 40 000 iops with huge amount of ram
per instance so you can click on create
instance here and then you can choose
one of the database which you would want
to use so Cloud SQL is a managed service
you can choose one of your MySQL or
postgres and SQL Server say for example
I choose MySQL now that basically tells
me what is the instance ID it sets up a
password you can always change the
password you can change the region you
can choose your database version and
then you can also look at other
configuration options which talk about
machine type which will be used what is
about your backup and Recovery
maintenance and all that and if you
click on create this will basically
create a fully managed SQL service which
can allow you to straight away start
using MySQL on cloud thus allowing you
to store your relational data when we
talk about storage options how can we
not talk about a data warehouse solution
or basically an option which allows you
to run your queries by directly updating
data so you can use a data warehouse
service which Google Cloud platform
offers and that's called bigquery so
basically you can be looking into the
Big Data section here and here you have
an option called bigquery so this
basically brings ease of implementation
and speed so building your own data
warehouse can be expensive time
consuming and difficult to scale so with
bigquery you just load data and pay only
for what you use so it when it comes to
Features you have features such as
capability to process billion of rows in
seconds and if you would want to do
real-time analysis of streaming data
that is also possible here so here we
have clicked on bigquery which basically
shows you the option where you can start
typing your query and test your data
access for example if I have uploaded
some data so it shows me there are some
queries which are saved here now I can
schedule your query I can basically
choose the format of a particular query
by clicking on this more here I have an
option which says add data so I can pin
it to a particular project I can explore
public data sets I can create a
connection so if I click on explore
public data sets then it takes me to a
page from where you can get different
kind of data sets which are already
available which you can put into your
bigquery and start querying your data by
default it shows that it is aligned to
my project and I don't need to worry
about it I can look at saved queries if
I have already saved a particular query
I can look at job history I can look at
transfer scheduled queries and
reservations so bigquery basically
initially had its own version of SQL
which was slightly different from
standard SQL but in 2016 bigquery 2 was
released that supports SQL 2011 standard
you can always select standard SQL now
bigquery when it comes to pricing we
need to remember that the storage is
where the storage cost is very less here
approximately 0.02 cents per GB per
month it is almost similar to near line
where you can also have low cost that is
0.01 cents per gigabyte per month there
is no charge for reading data from
Storage when it comes to querying and
that's where the cost is incurred so one
terabyte per month is free and after
that it costs few cents per gigabyte so
this is mainly for high volume customers
there is a flat rate by pricing which
can be used so when you talk about
querying you can save your query results
you can create data set to store the
results now results are put in a temp
table in cash and after you are done
with that you can delete data set and
delete all the data so when you talk
about loading data into bigquery you can
get the data from cloud storage Google
Drive cloud data store stackdriver stack
uh driver other options you have cloud
bigtable or other web interfaces so you
can download from URL such as CSV Json
Avro you can create data set create
table and create from Source by doing a
file upload so 10 megabyte or less files
can be uploaded using web interface as
an option you can also use command line
and then you can start working with your
bigquery so here you can also work with
streaming data by basically pushing in
streaming data into your bigquery which
allows you to add one record at a time
now you could use something like cloud
data flow which allows you to use a
particular pipeline about cloud data
flow we will learn later so you can
benefit from different features of
bigquery and thus use Google's offering
to work on your structured data or I
would say data which suits well in data
warehouses now these are some of the
storage related Services which Google
Cloud offers although we will learn
about using bigquery and running or
uploading some data by creating add data
set here by say creating connection or
using a public data set so as of now I
have this you can also access the
command line to work with this but we
will learn in detail about bigquery in
later sessions now here you can scroll
down and you also have an option within
Big Data space and that is your data
proc so when you talk about data proc
this is again a managed service which
allows you to run spark or Hadoop jobs
so especially if you are interested in
Big Data workload so for big data
processing for machine learning you can
always use cloud data proc this uses
compute engine instances under the hood
but takes care of management of these
instances so it's a it's a layer on top
to spin off clusters it's a managed
service is it's cheaper pay when the
jobs are running only it's fast because
it is integrated with other Google cloud
services you have open source components
pre-installed and data proc is
integrated with yarn to make cluster
management easier when you talk about
data proc you can click on create
cluster and that basically allows you to
set up your cluster by choosing a
particular region which you would want
to use for example I'll choose europest
4. here it tells what kind of machines
you would want to use and by default it
has populated as the machine here which
is 4 CPU and 15 gigabyte now since you
might be using a free account let's not
go for the high-end machine let's go for
N1 standard 2 and then you can scroll
down it says what is the primary disk
what is the disk type and this one was
for your master machine that is machine
which will have the master processors
running then you have have your worker
node configuration which tells this will
be let's choose a lower end machine and
we can choose how many worker nodes you
would have so it says minimum two you
can choose the ssds and their capacity
it talks about yarn course and yarn
memory which will be allocated and here
we have then option of clicking on
create
so once you click on create this will
basically spin up a cluster wherein you
can straight away start submitting jobs
to this you can basically go ahead once
your cluster is ready you can go into
the cluster you can submit a job you can
choose a type which is spark or any
other application which you would want
to run and then basically you can use
this fully managed service which allows
you to run your big data clusters you
can obviously control access via roles
or Access Control list and you can have
access as it is at project level or
based on your data proc cluster or even
at your worker nodes so we'll learn
about data proc in later sessions so as
of now you see here the cluster is
getting created it says the cloud
storage bucket which it is using is this
one now I can click on this and open
link in a new tab it still takes me into
console but now it is showing me the
bucket which is being used by your data
proc cluster this is the bucket which is
being used and it is being used for an
underlying metadata which gets stored
here so you look at the cluster related
folders you can click in these folders
and then it can see what is the script
output what it is doing and so on now I
can come back here to my bucket which
will basically show me what kind of
buckets have been created so you see
data proc service automatically created
some buckets which will be holding some
data you also have some other buckets
which were created based on other
services which we used the access
control is fine grained in all cases
plus it also shows R bucket so
underlying it is using compute instances
it is basically using let's go here and
let's go to compute engine and let's
look into VM instances
so data proc which has spun up a cluster
is also using the VM instances which we
see here are running it is using the
buckets and it has made a cluster ready
to use so you can click on this cluster
and that shows me my cluster related
details if there are any jobs running
what are VM instances what kind of
configurations it has used and you can
look at different details here you can
look at the logs you can click on jobs
and that will show you if you have
basically run a job on this ready to use
cluster so it says there is this
particular job which was run which was a
spark job you can click on submit and
this one tells you what is the job ID
what is the region you would choose for
example we will again choose for example
Europe West 4 it tells what is the job
type so you can run all these type of
jobs in this cluster such as Hadoop
spark Pi spark Hive Pig Presto you can
give your jar file so if you have
packaged your application is a jar you
can mention that here you can pass in
some arguments you can also say some
other jar files add some properties and
then click on submit which will run your
job on this ready to use cluster now
since we have tested it I can basically
go ahead and do a delete I don't want to
incur any cost on these managed Services
which are running so there are a lot
more information about using these
Services which Google Cloud platform
offers and we can continue learning
about these Services as we explore your
Google Cloud console or even your
command line option now we can come out
of this one by clicking on this menu and
then we have other options such as
kubernetes you have Cloud functions you
have your networking related Services
monitoring related Services different
kind of tools what you have you have
other big data specific Services which
you can learn about and for each of
these service Google has a very good
documentation available for example when
you talk about publish subscribe
messaging system it is a real-time
managed service which basically is a
Pioneer which was used and now you have
a famous service such as Kafka which is
being used for your published
subscribing or messaging system kind of
requirements
so to conclude about Google Cloud
platform Services you can always go to
cloud.google.com and look into the
document section now here you have list
of different featured products you also
have list of your different domains and
services which Google Cloud offers and
you can learn about all the different
Services which are offered by Google
Cloud here you can click on featured
products and that basically shows you
compute engine Cloud run cloud storage
you have Cloud SQL bigquery Vision AI
you can scroll down and look at your
artificial intelligence and machine
learning related Services platform and
accelerators API management
foreign
offers different services in mainly in
your compute storage and databases you
have networking related Services Big
Data specifics developer tools Cloud AI
identity and Security iot Management
tools API platform and so on so
basically learn about the gcp services
which Google Cloud platform offers and
in detail you can play around with
different Services which are offered by
creating a free account and as I
demonstrated you can use any one of
these Services quick start them
basically connect to them put in your
data or use a managed service to manage
your data and benefit from Google Cloud
platform thus having modernized
infrastructure for your different use
cases and with that we have reached the
end of day four so far we have learned
integration and working of devops with
Cloud on day 5 of devops learning week
we will reveal the next stage where you
get to master the popular devops tools
thanks for watching and don't forget to
subscribe to stay tuned for more from
Simply learn